allez donc est-ce qu'on a un défenseur
pour l'amendement numéro
635 monsieur nagelen oui vous êtes merci
monsieur le Président on on arrive à à
un moment clé du texte avec ces articles
3 3 et 4 bis sur notre vision que nous
devons avoir de l'immigration pour notre
groupe c'est clair on doit être beaucoup
plus dur avec ceux qui ne respectent pas
l'ordre public et et les principe
républicain par contre on ne doit pas
occulter la réalité des travailleurs en
situation irrégulière et une certaine
nécessité sur le marché du travail en
France ce que propose cet amendement
c'est en fait un un rétablissement de
l'article 3 avec quelques quelques
motivation quelques modifications déjà
avoir exercé pendant 12 mois au cours
des 24 derniers mois c'est un élément
qui pour nous paraît essentiel 8 mois
sur 24 ça fait un/ers on pense qu'il
faut sur les deux dernières années avoir
travaillé au moins la moitié la moitié
du temps et un autre critère qui pour
nous est essentiel c'est que la liste
des métiers en tension soit faite au
niveau départemental on trouve que la
région le cercle la région est beaucoup
trop grand on doit impérativement
réduire pour avoir une cohérence
territoriale merci le suivant est-ce que
vous êtes signataire monsieur nelen
non monsieur valallot le
887 merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président il s'agit d'un amendement
rétablissement l'article 3 dans sa
version originale ça n'est pas l'article
rédigé par le groupe socialiste c'est
l'article rédigé par le gouvernement
dans une loi qui était vantée comme
équilibrée et donc c'était un élément
qui nous paraissait central même si le
ministre lui-même disait que cet article
3 ne méritait ni les bravos de ceux qui
le considè comme l'alpha et l'oméga du
texte ni les hénissements de ceux qu'
l'estimaient affreux sans doute mais il
avait du point de vue des associations
de notre point de vue quelques vertus
notamment le fait de supprimer
l'obligation préalable de l'employeur
toutes les limites nous les connaissons
nous aons l'occasion d'en débattre le
fait que ce soit réservé au métiers en
tension avec la part d'Ala et de
bureaucratie et d'injustice qui vont
avec le fait que lesavilleurs des
plateformes ou les indépendants ne soi
pas concerné le fait aussi qu'il
s'agisse d'un dispositif expérimental
mais comme c'est certains ont pu le dire
c'est mieux que rien et le Sénat ayant
proposé essentiellement rien nous
proposons à votre suffrage ce que vous
avez plébiscité dans vos expressions
publiques depuis des semaines voir des
mois vous pouvez poursuivre avec le 889
monsieur
V pardon oui je
peux alors c'est un amendement qui dit
au fond
ce que nous souhaiterions nous
défendons l'idée que le travail donne
droit au séjour qu'il faut sortir d'une
hypocrisie considérable dans laquelle
des secteurs entiers de l'économie
fonctionnent parce qu'il y a des
travailleurs étrangers et que beaucoup
d'entre eux sont en situation
irrégulière avec cette situation
paradoxale que docin paye des impôts
paye des cotisations mais sont maintenus
dans des situations de non droit nous
arrivons parfois dans des situations
d'absurdi où des travailleurs étrangers
régul aant une autorisation de travail
du fait de délais préfectoraux
considérabl voit perdre leur droite à
travailler ce que nous souhaitons c'est
que quand on occupe un CDI depuis 6 mois
ou quand on occupe un CDD depuis 6 mois
on puisse avoir une carte de séjour
plannuel pour l'un temporaire pour
l'autre évidemment que cela ne soit donc
pas limité au métiers en tension je
rappelle que l'aie restauration que
j'évoqu ne fait pas partie de la liste
des
métiersention vous avez également 890
monsieur
rien ne vous échappe monsieur le
monsieur le Président
euh il s'agit d'un d'un d'un amendement
qui réintroduit l'article 3 sans le
limiter au champ des métiers des métiers
en tension ce qui me permet me permet de
d'insister sur la la puissance
d'intégration par le travail j'entends
beaucoup de élateurs de la valeur
travail aujourd'hui finalement le
reconnaître à d'autres qu'à ceux qui
exercent un certain nombre de de métiers
dans l'hôtellerie restauration la
propreté les travaux publics le bâtiment
l'aide à la personne j'entendais il y a
quelques jours le ministre de
l'Industrie dire que nous aurions besoin
dans les 10 ans à venir de 100 à 150000
travailleurs dans ces secteurs nous
devons défendre la base industrielle
française lutter contre la
désindustrialisation sans confondre la
défense de l'industrie avec la défense
du productivisme ça ne sera évidemment
pas la confusion que nous opérerons il y
a parmi les métiers évidemment du soins
à la personne de l'aide à domicile des
métiers du soin également beaucoup de
besoins don le seul département des
Landes par exemple il manque 500 aides à
domicile ce sera des métiers évidemment
pour lesquel nous nous batons s'agissant
des conditions de travail des conditions
de formation de la reconnaissance de
l'utilité sociale et évidemment de la
rémunération le 724 qu'est-ce qui le
défend monsieur porte merci monsieur le
Président ici c'est un amendement qui
qui élargit l'article 3 initialement
prévu puisque nous notre position elle
est de considérer qu'il faut régulariser
l'ensemble des travailleurs sans papi
qui sont sur le territoire national on
les estime à peu près à 800000 ce sont
des gens qui ont permis de tenir le pays
debout qui sont utiles mais qui travaill
dans la peur toujours sous pression et
qui mérite d'être régularisé on
considère qu'il faut sortir de cette
vision utilitariste que certains
seraient dit essentiel d'autres non
essentiel l'ensemble des travailleurs
sans papier de ce pays mérite d'être
régularisé et nous on veut élargir cette
régularisation avec un titre de plein
droit pour les étudiants étrangers qui
sont aussi présents sur le territoire
national et qui ne devrait pas avoir
chaque année à renouveler face à une
administration qui est aussi engorgée
c'est aussi un élément de pression qui
ne leur permet pas d'étuder des
environnements sereins et enfin on veut
également élargir aux parents d'enfants
étrangers qui n'obtiennent pas un titre
de plein droit aujourd'hui alors qu'il
se trouvent en France en compagnie de
leur enfants français pour nous c'est
une injustice absolue donc on souhaite
élargir véritablement l'article original
qui était initialement prévu par ce
gouvernement qui ne cesse de dire qu'il
veut avancer sur la régularisation
régularisation régularisons pardon tous
les travailleurs sans papier de ce pays
l'ensemble des étudiants étrangers et
les parents qui ont un enfant français
dans ce pays Madame Dupont le suivant
merci monsieur le Président donc cette
cette discussion commune se concentre
sur un le le point enfin l'un des points
important de ce texte sur la
régularisation dans les métiers en
tension et l'amendement que nous nous
portons à plusieurs voix en définitive
vise à réintroduire la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papiers de plein
droit dans les métiers et zones
géographiques en tension cette mesure
qui étit prévue dans le texte initial
présenté par le gouvernement étaé
supprimé par le Sénat au profit d'une
version permettant une régularisation à
minima parfois même moins avantageuse
que le droit actuellement en vigueur
alors que cette régularisation répond
concrètement au besoins de recrutement
des entreprises sur nos territoires tout
en permettant aux personnes étrangères
concernées de survenir à leurs besoins
et c'est une réponse efficace
à le enfin pour contrer justement la
propagation de l'économie souterraine
dont on parle plus peu dans le débat
mais je pense que régulariser vise aussi
à assaainir notre économie et c'est une
une mesure d'importance à laquelle nous
sommes très attachés monsieur Vallot le
suivant
oui merci monsieur le président euh
effectivement par cet amendement qui est
un amendement de réplie je dirais parce
que on on vise à introduire à
réintroduire l'article 3 qui était euh
qui a été finalement supprimé au Sénat
je pense qu'ici il faut rappeler que le
travail doit devenir le moyen de
régularisation plus simple pour éviter
justement les situations d'exploitation
de cladestinité de précarité
d'illégalité je crois que j'insiste
particulièrement parce que pas plus tard
que au début de la semaine lors de la
cozak qui a eu lieu euh avec l'ensemble
des parlements nationaux euh sous la
question migratoirees euh il est revenu
à plusieurs reprises cette question
finalement de de de de métier
d'entention mais ça en en sachant en
même temps que aujourd'hui ce certains
métiers qui ne sont pas en tension c'est
parce qu'ils emploient un certain nombre
de de personnes étrangères de
travailleurs étrangers demain il risque
de devenir aussi ces métiers en tension
donc la limitation donc au sol métier
dit ention l'exclusion des périodes de
séjour en qualité d'étudiants
travailleurs saisonniers de demandeurs
d'asile dans la prise en compte des
délais exigés tous ces verrous font
perdre aujourd'hui du sens au principe
de régularisation par le travail et
c'est pour cette raisonlà nous proposons
cet amendement monsieur sainthuile ouis
merci monsieur le Président à tort ou à
raison sur ce texte l'équilibre sera
qualifié en fonction de la discussion
sur l'ame et sur la capacité ou pas à
régulariser les travailleurs sans papier
sur les métiers dit entention la
discussion elle peut être longue sur la
volumétrie sur le temps de travail sur
les zones géographiques ou pas sur la
tension ou pas et ça va polariser les
débats jusqu'aux 4 B sans doute nous
nous avons signé ici un amendement que
je pourrais qualifieré de manière un peu
pompeuse de transpartisan il est pris
repris par d'autres et je m'en réjouis
parce que nous considérons finalement
que la version initiale était une bonne
base de travail pour pouvoir discuter
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons ce premier amendement
le suivant est CELI de monsieur Brun
qu'est-ce qui le défend monsieur CAC
merci monsieur le
Président le Sénat a donc supprimé
l'article 3 l'article 3 étant celui qui
a
été proposé par le
gouvernement j'imagine que vous n'alz
pas contesté le fait qu'on puisse le le
défendre ardemment et notamment en
proposant la réintroduction de cet
article
3 dans ce pays on peut cotiser n'en
tirer aucun droit très souvent le
président de la République nous rappelle
que lorsque l'on a des droits on a aussi
des des devoirs en l'occurrence ici nous
parlons d'étrangers qui travaillent qui
cotisent qui n'ont pas de droit c'est
donc les devoirs sans les droits
euh ils sont en règle d'une certaine
manière à l'égard de la République dès
lors que pour un certain nombre d'entre
eux ils ont perdu leur titre de séjour
et on peut considérer d'une certaine
manière que la République n'est pas en
règle à leur égard en les faisant
travailler avec donc ses ses devoirs et
et pas ses droits c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons de réintroduire
l'article 3 et de considérer que ce qui
contribue à notre économie et à la vie
sociale de ce pays mérite des droits et
pas seulement des devoirs alors je crois
qu'il n'y a pas de défenseur pour
l'amendement
suivant par contre Monsieur saintthuil
vous êtes présent pour le 1404 oui je
suis moi-même monsieur saintthuil donc
je vais défendre l'amendement de
Monsieur
saintthuil en en étant rapide encore une
fois il y a plusieurs visions et
plusieurs versions sur ce texte ici
c'est une version en entre guillemets un
peu plus large qui pourrait permettre à
certains sans doute de considérer qu'il
y a une forme d'appel d'air pour
reprendre les expressions à la mode du
moment puisque il n'y a pas de bornage
temporel sans doute que le bornage
temporel pourrait répondre à la grande
inquiétude de celles et de ceux qui
considéraent qu'il y aurait un danger
particulier donc c'est un amendement qui
permet sans doute une discussion plus
large sur le
sujet Madame
Dupont
merci monsieur le Président donc les
travailleurs sans papierers contribuent
à l'économie et la vie sociale de notre
pays et je je souhaite rappeler le
nombre de ces travailleurs qui
aujourd'hui est estimé entre 600000 et
800000 personnes en
France et si ces travailleurs cessaient
leur activité des secteurs entiers de
notre économie se trouveraient en arrêt
et on l'a vu récemment d'ailleurs avec
une mobilisation dans le BTP sur
l'Île-de-France il y a quelques temps je
je crois qu'il y a euh une des règles
d'apparente rigidité qui masquent en
réalité un profond déséquilibre dans
notre système économique qui s'appuie
sur un marché du travail d'application
totalement inégale et une forme
d'exploitation de de main d'œuvre sans
protection qui est ainsi générée et cet
amendement transpartisan qui fait suite
à un travail qu'on a conduit afin non
plus de se pencher sur nos différences
mais ce qui nous rapproche vise à
collectivement porter cette exigence de
régularisation des des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension et
s'inscrit donc dans cette discussion
général pour vraiment avancer et aller
aussi loin que possible dans l'intérêt
des personnes concernées des
travailleurs et bien sûr de nos
entreprises monsieur Nagel vous avez le
dernier amendement de la discussion
commune merci monsieur le Président pour
reprendre ce que j'aiénoncé tout à
l'heure on a besoin sur ce texte d'avoir
des critères qui soient des critères
établi sur ce que doivent être les
métiers en tension combien de temps la
personne serait en capacité de pouvoir
exercer ce métier et quels sont les
critères d'attribution cet amendement là
il durcit légèrement l'article 3 initial
du gouvernement en demandant une période
de 12 mois et je l'ai explicité tout à
l'heure mais en mettant aussi en place
un droit général d'opposition du préfet
euh c'est important le le préfet à la
tête de son administration représente
l'État dans dans le dans le département
il est le plus à même d'avoir des
informations extrêmement extrêmement
précises que peut-être qui pourrait
peut-être venir contrecarer ce que
dirait la loi si jamais elle était si
jamais elle était votée donc il est
nécessaire que le préfet
puisse s'opposer à une à une
régularisation de titrre de manière
générale monsieur le rapporteur vos avis
sur Madame la rapporteur pardon vos avis
sur ces
amendements merci Monsieur le président
alors si vous permettez mes chers
collègues puisque on arrive à un moment
important tous les moments sont
importants dans ce texte mais un peu
plus longuement si vous me permettez de
de faire une intervention qui vous
permettra de dire ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui la façon dont les choses
aujourd'hui se passent quelle était la
version dans le texte du Gouvernement ce
que le
Sénat a mis en place je ferai pas j'en
ai pas pour 3 He rassurez-vous mais et
que on arrive
ensuite à que je vous explique
finalement l'amendement qui a été déposé
par le rapporteur général et bien
évidemment il complètera pour vous dire
quelle est finalement la solution que
nous on trouve équilibrée et qui me
semble pouvoir permettre d'avoir une un
dispositif équilibré donc comment ça se
passe aujourd'hui euh vous le savez un
certain nombre de personnes aujourd'hui
sans papier travaille euh dans des
métiers euh dit entention euh et et pour
autant
euh on voit que euh les possibilités de
régularisation euh de ces de ces
personnes euh sont quand même assez
limité puisque aujourd'hui elles peuvent
le faire via ce que l'on appelle
l'admission exceptionnelle au séjour
appliqué via la circulaire Vals de 2012
euh mais ça présente trois difficultés
euh majeures euh la première vous le
savez les décisions préfectorales sont
discrétionnaires ça c'est le premier
point aujourd'hui euh elle ne tiennent
pas compte euh du critère des métiers en
tension puisqu'il n'existe pas pour pour
l'instant et le troisème point qui est
important c'est que l'employeur doit de
façon euh obligatoire participer à cette
demande de régularisation et vous voyez
bien les difficultés euh à laquelle ça
peut conduire la personne si l'employeur
n'est pas n'est pas coopératif c'est
pour ça que l'article 3 initial du
projet de loi et ça a été indiqué par un
certain nombre d'entre vous visait de
façon temporaire ça n'a pas été signalé
pour l'instant mais c'est une
expérimentation et il s'agit de voir au
bout de cette expérimentation s'il faut
euh voilà valider cette possibilité dans
le temps donc ça c'est un un point qui
qui doit aussi être signalé
vous voyez bien que il s'agissait donc
de délivrer une carte de séjour ça c'est
dans le projet loi initiale de plein
droit dans le cadre des métiers en
tension c'était pour des personnes qui
étaient donc en France depuis plus de 3
ans et qui pouvait justifier d'une
activité professionnelle salariée qui
figure dans des métiers et zones
géographiques caractérisé par des
difficultés de recrutement durant au
moins 8 mois consécutif ou non au cours
des deux dernières années et qui donc
occupent sont en emploi dans ses métiers
et ses zone cette procédure dans le
cadre du projet de loi initial était à
la seule initiative des étrangers donc
je j'insiste mais sans la nécessité du
du concours de de leur employeur le
Sénat qu'est-ce qu'il a
proposé il a à mon sens réduit de façon
importante la portée du du dispositif
pourquoi et du coup il a supprimé
l'article 3 et il a créé le le 4 bis
c'est parce que ce nouvel article 4 bis
il vient créer un article additionnel
dans le dans le chapitre du cza qui est
relatif à l'admission exceptionnelle du
séjour donc on voit bien que c'est pas
au même endroit il dispose que la
délivrance de la carte donc de séjour
temporaire portant la la mention soit
travailleur temporaire soit salarié
n'intervient qu'à titre exceptionnel il
a également allongé le critère je vous
disais initial c'était 8 mois et le
Sénat c'est 12 mois de plus l'article il
dispose que l'autorité
compétente prend en compte l'insertion
sociale familiale de l'étranger donc on
VO que les critères sont élargis son
respect de l'ordre public son
intégration à la société française et
enfin le dernier point sur lequel j'ai
insisté jusqu'à maintenant il prévoit
que l'autorisation de travail peut être
accordée après près vérification auprès
de l'employeur de la réalité de
l'activité alléguée là où le dispositif
initial je vous le rappelais disposer
que la carte de séjour valait
autorisation de travail le dispositif
tel qu'on le tel qu'on vous le
propose c'est effectivement un
dispositif d'équilibre pourquoi c'est
parce que on reprend dans un premier
temps du Sénat le maintien de la
délivrance des carte de séjour
temporaire qui porte la mention
travailleur temporaire ou salarié il
reprend également les réserves le
dispositif de réserve en indiquant que
la carte de séjour est délivrée sauf si
le représentant de l'État s'oppose pour
l'une des raisons énuméré donc vous avez
par exemple la présence de l'étranger
qui constitue une munace pour l'endro
public et néanmoins dès lors que
l'étranger remplit la totalité des
conditions et qu'il ne tombe pas dans
l'une de ces exceptions à ce moment-là
il se voit délivrer la carte de séjour
dès lors vous le vous le constatez je
l'imagine mes chers collègues que ce
dispositif est un dispositif d'équilibre
ça n'est ni une procédure
discrétionnaire ni un droit automatique
à la régularisation donc ça c'est notre
proposition et donc vous comprendrez que
par rapport à tous les amendements que
vous avez que vous venez de nous
présenter ce sera un avis défavorable au
profit du dispositif que je viens de
vous exposer je vous remerci
monsieur le rapporteur
général oui merci monsieur le Président
peut-être pour apporter quelques
quelques compléments s'agissant d'un
d'un sujet qui évidemment a fait
beaucoup et débattre et et parler ces
dernières semaines ces dernières ces
derniers mois bon il y a une une
hypocrisie réelle profonde à considérer
que nous avons à la fois des besoins
économiques tout en maintenant un
certain nombre de personnes dans une
situation de précarité
totale c'est ce pourquoi le gouvernement
dans le projet de loi initial a proposer
un une procédure ciblée de
régularisation il y a des phénomènes
d'exploitation il y a des phénomènes y
compris d'esclavagisme contemporain et
nous avons à la fois un certain nombre
de filières économiques ce sont les
fameux métiers en tension dans lesquels
certain nombre de personnes travaillent
depuis longtemps payent leurs cotisation
social payent leurs impôts ont des
contrats de travail parfois donc je le
disais depuis plusieurs années sont même
parfois des piliers de l'activité
économique de telle ou telle entreprise
de tel ou telle PME de tel ou telle
hôtel restaurant que sais-je encore et
donc il nous a paraarît
indispensable de créer une procédure ad
hoc de régularisation ciblée sur ces
fameux métiers en tenstion j'ai parfois
entendu un certain nombre d'arguments
pardon de les répéter par exemple celui
il a été évoqué assez régulièrement au
Sénat en particulier de l'appel d'air
mais avec le dispositif proposé par le
gouvernement avec le
dispositif que je vous proposerai
d'adopter à l'article 4 B il ne peut pas
y avoir de d'appel d'air ça n'existe pas
il y a à la fois une condition de
résidence de 3 ans et une borne dans le
temps au 31 décembre 2026 et nous vous
proposerons de l'allonger parce que je
vous rappelle que le projet de loi a été
examiné en Conseil des ministres au mois
de février 2023 donc il y aurait
raisonnablement nécessité d'allonger le
délai audelà du 31 décembre 2026 dans
des proportions évidemment acceptables
et conforme à notre objectif mais si
vous cumulez la résidence de 3 ans et si
vous cumulez la borne dans le temps il
n'y a aucune personne aucune personne
aujourd'hui présente sur le territoire
dans son pays d'origine qui pourra
bénéficier du processus de
régularisation
aucune et lorsque j'entends l'appel
d'air je ne vois pas comment ça peut
fonctionner il s'agit bien de personnes
qui travaillent en
France qui sont présentes en France avec
une condition de séjour de 3 ans le
Sénat a fait une proposition qui au fond
et double la première il faut le noter
c'est qu'après avoir indiqué à plusieurs
reprises et pendant plusieurs semaines
et à grands renfort de communication que
il n'était pas acceptable que la France
engage une politique ciblée de
régularisation j'ai même entendu le
slogan zéro
régularisation le Sénat a validé a
accepté la nécessité en France d'un
processus ciblé de régularisation plus
ciblé que le nôtre
plus étroit que le nôtre ça n'est pas le
nôtre et c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs je vous proposerai des
aménagements le Sénat remet en cause
deux points qui me paraissent
fondamentaux le premier on l'a
insuffisamment souligné au cours des
dernières semaines et c'était la clé de
l'article 3 initial et je souhaite qu'on
le réintègre c'est l'autonomie de la
demande de
régularisation par rapport à l'employeur
mais c'est ça qui estond
c'est comme le dit souvent le ministre
de l'intérieur c'est de couper
l'écosystème d'exploitation de
subordination et on le fera à d'autres
occasion et sur d'autres sujets avec les
sanctions administratives d'ailleurs à
la gare des employeurs qui serait
mavéan avec aussi la question des
logements indescents des vendeurs de de
sommeil pour d'autres catégories de de
situation il faut que nous puissions
réintroduire l'autonomie de la demande
par rapport à l'employeur or l'article 4
bis introduit par le Sénat remet
l'employeur au cœur du dispositif rien
ne peut se faire au terme de l'écriture
du Sénat sans l'employeur et ça nous
paraî absolument problématique deuxème
point qui est essentiel c'est d'avoir
remis entre les mains du seul préfet
l'appréciation de toutes les
situations le préfet aurait donc un
pouvoir absolu général discrétionnaire
et au fond serait placer dans la même
situation que l'application de la circ
Vals or nous voulons créer un un
processus ad hoc pour répondre à des
situations tout à fait spécifiques et
donc nous ne sommes pas en accord avec
le Sénat sur ce point nous sommes en
accord avec le Sénat sur la nécessité
d'une procédure ciblé de régularisation
elle a toujours été ciblé dans notre
esprit j'indiqué même la borne dans le
temps la résidence de 3 ans mais nous ne
sommes pas d'accord avec cette idée que
le préfet serait seul à décider pourquoi
mes chers collègues parce que que nous
savons à quel point ce pouvoir
discrétionnaire
entraînerait des inégalités
d'application territorial très forte
avec parfois des injustices une
casistique des situations qui ne
seraient pas conforme à l'esprit
d'égalité qui conduit aussi ce
dispositif quels sont les aménagements
que je vous proposeerai d'adopt et qui
justifieront un avis défavorable aux
amendements qui viennent d'être proposés
lorsque nous aborderons l'article 4 bis
je l'ai dit réintroduire l'employeur
c'est
indispensable la nécessité de faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de dépendance
entre l'employeur et la personne en
situation irrégulière et l'employeur
devra le cas échéant subir des contrôles
mais c'est bien normal est-ce que la
personne en situation irrégulière est la
Seu dans cette situation et dans telle
ou telle entreprise quelles sont les
conditions de rémunération qui lui sont
réservées ou qui leur sont réservé
quelles sont les conditions de travail
sont-elles respectées je le redis cette
autonomie de la demande de régulation
est indispensable et puis ensuite de
faire en sorte que il n'y ait pas
automaticité de la régularisation qui
était l'esprit de l'article 3 initial
pas d'automaticité et pas de pouvoir
discrtionnaire non plus et faire en
sorte que le l'autorité administrative
le préfet lorsqu est engagé la procédure
de régularisation puisse l'interrompre
tout moment ne pas délivrer bien s le
titre le retirer aussi pour des
conditions qui me paraisse pouvoir nous
rassembler je ne reviens pas sur la
condition de polygamie elle est
transversale elle concerne tous les
titres de séjour elle est rappelé dans
l'amendement que je propose parce qu'il
faut bien la rappeler mais elle est
évidente elle vaut pour tous les titres
de séjour c'est la question bien sûr
aussi des menaces à l'ordre public qui
pourrait comprendre
quelques semaines quelques mois après
que un ressortissant de nationalité
étrangère en situation irrégulière et
bénéficie d'un titre de séjour pour les
métiers en tenstion qui pourrait
comprendre qu'il pose des problèmes d'
d'ordre public qu'il provoque des
troubles à le public et que cette
situation n''est pas été appréciée dès
le départ au point de justifier la non
délivrance et puis il y a aussi la
question du comportement des agissements
nous sommes je pense collectivement
attachés à ce que les principes et
valeurs de la République à la condition
qu'il soit défin bien sûr pas rester
dans le vague surtout avec des termes
aussi importants mais de faire en sorte
que lorsque des agissements des
comportements contraires au principe é
de la République sont constatés le
préfet puisse ne pas délivrer puisse
retirer voilà les aménagements sur
lesquels nous aurons l'occasion de
débattre à l'article 4 bis est-ce que
c'est équilibré est-ce que c'est
doublement efficace au
point en réalité ça c'est du nominalisme
bon est-ce que ce dispositif serait
efficace oui je crois est-ce que il
correspondrait à des besoins économique
je crois est-ce que il permettrait de
lever des liens de subordination qui
sont de la maltraitance à l'égard des
ressortissants nationalité étrangère en
situation irrégulière qui n'ont pas
toujours voulu leur irrégularité qui
n'ont pas toujours souhaité elle est
parfois la résultante de procédure
administrative d'une grande complexité
vous savez que nous souhaitons les
simplifier est-ce que cela est juste je
crois possibilité de d'introduire sa
demande de régularation de façon tout à
fait autonome vis-àvis de l'employeur et
la possibilité pour le préfet qui
représente l'ordre public qui représente
l'état de refuser la délivrance pour des
menaces à l'ordre public et pour des
agissements contraires au principe de la
République mes chers collègues avant que
vous ne commenciez à chuchoter dans tous
les sens s'il vous plaît je voudrais il
me semble que c'est assez sérieux pour
que nous puissions nous écouter moi je
vous écouterai en tout cas dans le
silence imaginez si je parlais pendant
que vous vous exprimiez
je voudrais dire à Christophe nagelen
que évidemment la
question de la meilleure adaptation
possible de la liste des métiers en
tenstion réalité locale pardon elle est
essentielle elle est essentielle nous
avons quelques difficultés d'ordre
logistique technique il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui à l'échelle départementale
les données agrégées qui permettent une
actualisation
et liité d'analyse des métiers en
tenstion ni Pôle emploi ni l ne sont
organisés de façon à départaliser les
données et surtout à les actualiser de
la façon la plus régulière et rapide
possible donc nous avons là une
difficulté qui n'est pas d'ordre
politique qui est d'ordre technique moi
je l'engagement que je prends je je je
je le dis je le fais on le fera et
Monsieur le Ministre d'ailleurs le
confirmera c'est que nous
puissions trouver un dispositif
d'hyper territorialisation de la liste
des métiers en
tension plutôt pour la séance il faut
encore que nous y travaillons mais vous
le savez car nous avons déjà échangé sur
ce sujet et donc pour la séance je
proposerai peut-être d'ailleurs cela
pourrait-il être un amendement de votre
groupe cher Christophe nagelen un
dispositif de territoriation qui permett
à la fois de tenir compte de ce que nous
sommes plutôt régionalisés en terme de
données mais la nécessité déclinaison
locale aussi précise que possible et qui
doit je pense d'ailleurs associer comme
en Suisse les partenaires sociaux les
consulaires peut-être d'autres
institutions qui permettront d'avoir une
codesence locale précise pas simplement
statistique mais aussi j'allais dire
concrète de terrain des réalités locales
voilà mes chers collègues les éléments
que je souhaitais communiquer à ce stade
de nos
discussions en émettant vous l'avez
compris un avis défavorable sur les
amendements contenu des dispositions que
nous serons appelés à débattre dans le
cadre de l'article 4 bis alors j'ai de
nombreux inscrits madame fossillon
oui merci euh on vit ici on bosse ici on
reste ici voici le le slogan scandé
depuis des années par de très nombreux
travailleurs sans papier slogan que je
partage je crois que ces milliers
d'hommes et de femmes qui travaillent
dans de très nombreux secteurs utiles à
la société qui euh vivent dans un
système totalement hypocrite quant à
leur situation puisque ils n'ont pas le
droit de travailler mais pour pouvoir
être régularisé il leur faut des fiche
de paye aujourd'hui il faut mettre fin à
ce système hypocrite et reconnaître les
droits affectter des droits à ces
travailleurs qui sont largement
exploités qui sont une main d'œuvre
malléable pour de très nombreux
employeurs je pense à l'un d'entre eux
qui m'expliquait il y a peu que quand le
droit du travail ne permet à un
travailleur avec papier avec papier de
ne travailler que 3 heur sur un marteau
piqueur lui on travaille 8 par jour par
jour sur le marteau picker et bien leur
régularisation c'est tenté de mettre fin
à ça de ne pas les placer en situation
d'exploitation devant devant leur
employeur de ne pas les mettre en
situation de grande vulnérabilité
comme ils le sont aujourd'hui donc pour
nous la régularisation des travailleurs
sans papier est une mesure urgente juste
que nous allons défendre ici jusqu'au
bout je veux dire quelles sont pour nous
les mesures importantes dans le cadre de
cette discussion évidemment et bien
l'autonomie de du salarié devant la
préfecture lui permett de pouvoir
déposer son dossier sans dépendre de
l'employeur c'est une mesure absolument
essentielle le fait aussi qu'il ait un
titre de plein droit ça c'est absolument
essentiel pour nous et enfin mais
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir il me
semble vraiment que la limitation dans
les métiers en tension est une mesure à
la fois trop restrictive mais ce qui
mais qui est aussi inscrit la
régularisation dans une dans une visée
trop utilitariste merci alors pour les
besoins du débat et comme je vous suis
tous intéressés sur cette article
précisément je donne 2 minutes à chacun
des orateurs de la discussion commune 2
minutes madame GeV
merci monsieur le Président euh le
groupe Renaissance évidemment euh
soutient la rédaction initiale du
gouvernement donc l'article 3 que
différents groupes nous propose de
réintroduire en adoptant cette ces ces
amendements euh le groupe Renaissance
soutient la rédaction initiale du
gouvernement puisque évidemment comme
l'a rappelé le le le le rapporteur
général il s'agissait bien d'un
dispositif ciblé qui je rappelle
prévoyait qu'un étranger qui exerçait
une activité salariée dont euh
l'activité salariée figurait dans la
liste des métiers euh et des zones en
tension durant au moins 8 mois sur les
24 derniers mois et ayant une résidence
ininterrompue depuis 3 ans puisse se
voir délivrer euh une carte de séjour
temporaire cette rédaction d'un an
cette rédaction nous y étions d'autant
plus attachés que un point nous semble
fondamental il a été rappelé par le
rapporteur général c'est que le salarié
étranger ne peut pas voir sa
régularisation
confié dans les mains uniques de
l'employeur on a un certain nombre de
témoignages qui ont été portés à notre
connaissance dans le cadre d'audition
dans le cadre de rencontrre qu'on peut
faire sur le terrain qui nous disent
très clairement que il y a des personnes
étrangères qui se retrouvent dans les
mains d'employeur indélicat qui ne
souhaitent pas les accompagner dans ces
procédures de régulation et nous ça
c'est un point auquel on est extrêmement
attentif alors après pourquoi on va être
amené à rejeter ces amendement de
suppression et donc cette rédaction
initiale en tout cas pour certains qui
l'ont proposé de l'article 3 parce qu'on
n pas sans savoir qu' a eu un certain
nombre de débats au Sénat qui ont amené
à une rédaction de de compromis entre le
gouvernement entre la majorité
sénatoriale et entre les groupes rdpay
et territoire pour les propositions que
nous font le rapporteur parce que la
réécriture du Sénat ne nous donne pas
complètement satisfaction nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler
Monsieur
marcangéi Merci monsieur le Président
d'abord il y a il faut rappeler les
éléments de contexte parle d'une
circulaire une circulaire porte le nom
de circulaire Vals ça a donné lieu
ensuite à une première rédaction de la
part du gouvernement qui était l'article
3 euh et ensuite il y a un débat
parlementaire qui s'est déroulé au Sénat
et je vais vous dire pourquoi est-ce que
la version qui avait été issue du
compromis euh passé au Sénat euh était
de nature à davantage nous convenir
d'abord parce que euh l'article 3
initial il crée un nouveau titre je
crois que l'un des objectifs principaux
de de ce ce texte dans son ensemble
c'est de simplifier et c'est de réduire
le nombre de titres euh or l'article 4
bis euh tel qu'il a été voté au Sénat et
tel qu'il sera proposé tout à l'heure
par monsieur le rapporteur général ne
crée pas de nouveaux titres
ensuite il y a également il faut le dire
les éléments pris en compte afin de
délivrer ce titre euh ceux qui remettent
l'article 3 dans le jeu si je peux me
permettre l'expression ne veulent pas
qu'il y ait une forme de
personnalisation ils veulent le plein
droit ils ne veulent pas que un certain
nombre de conditions soient examiné et
nous y sommes opposés nous sommes
opposés à cette obtention de plein droit
sans que à un moment la réalité de la
nature des activités soit prise en
compte soit que le style euh euh le mode
de vie
comportement l'adhésion à un certain
nombre de valeurs de celui ou de celle
valeur de la République j'insiste bien
dessus soit pris en compte donc le
groupe horizon et apparenté votera
contre ces amendements de
réinttroduction de l'article 3 et nous
discuterons tout à l'heure de ce que
Monsieur le Rapporteur général a
proposé monsieur Lucas merci Monsieur le
le président quelques éléments de
réflexion alors que centame un débat qui
va nous prendre quelques
j'imagine vous avez nous avons débattu
depuis des mois dans cette assemblée à
l'occasion de divvertex d'une prétendue
valeur travail nous nous considérons
qu'il faut désormais accorder de la
valeur aux travailleurs et donner droit
à ceux qui travaillent c'est
une non pas un cadeau c'est la
reconnaissance d'une réalité et d'un
rôle dans la société même si nous
considérons nous qu'on ne peut pas
entrer dans cette discussion en faisant
des nouveaux arrivants des variables
d'ajustement économique au bon gré de
d'une liste parcellaire de métiers en
tension et de zones géographiques
déterminer que cet article 3 initial il
est mieux que rien mais il est presque
rien c'était dans le texte initial du
gouvernement une maigre contrepartie de
bon sens économique et et d'humanisme au
Rabé et une forme d'article àibi je veux
dire pour anticiper les arguments qui
nous seront opposés puisque les sondages
sont évoqués
depuis TR ou 4 jours maintenant par
l'extrême droite et la droite
radicalisée sur la prétendue adhésion
des Français à une politique de fermeté
que pour le coup et là les sondages nous
les rappelleront une écrasante majorité
de français et de Français sont
favorables à la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier et une majorité
de Français là même la quasi unanimité
des Français a applaudi les travailleurs
et les travailleuses de la première
ligne pendant le covid il appartient
maintenant de donner des droits à toutes
et à tous et un dernier mot puisqu'il me
reste un peu de temps on va nous faire
faire le refrain de l'appel d'air
j'attends avec impatience que celles et
ceux qui vont développer cet argument
démontre une étude statistique une
réalité historique un fait un chiffre
qui démontre qu'il y a quand on mène des
politiques d'inclusion quand on mène des
politiques de régularisation un appel
d'air je seraai impatient de les
découvrir madame
genunevard merci merci monsieur le
Président alors cela ne vous étonnera
pas c'est un un des points absolument
essentiels à nos yeux
que cette question de la régularisation
nous sommes frontalement opposés aux
amendements qui viennent
d'être exposé parce que ils partent du
principe
que le travail donne droit au séjour de
façon
inconditionnel et là c'est quelque chose
qui est porteur
d'excès d'appel d'air en effet de
régularisation massive alors même que
les Français monsieur Lucas disent
sondage après sondage qu'ils veulent
réduire l'immigration en France parce
que on ne peut plus intégrer et que ça
pose énormément de problèmes ça vous ne
pouvez pas nier que les Français y
compris ceux de votre électorat sont
frontalement opposé à toute mesure qui
viserait à augmenter le nombre
d'étrangers dans notre pays de façon
massive bien donc ces amendements sont
catastrophiques parce que en effet ils
ouvrent la porte à des régularisations
extrêmement importantes je vous rappelle
le nombre des étrangers en situation
irrégulière entre 700 et 900000
personnes dans notre pays mais au fond
vous avez préparé les choses puisque
vous avez supprimé le délis de séjour
irrégulier il est donc aujourd'hui
possible de venir sans autorisation dans
notre pays et de n'être pas inquiété
puisque ce n'est pas un délit pour vous
et euh vous avez supprimé l'AMU donc
désormais on peut venir ce n'est pas un
délit on peut accéder à un panier de
soins total et
gratuitement tout ça va dans le sens
d'une ouverture sans frein non seulement
vis-à-vis des personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui dans notre pays en situation
irrégulière mais ce sont des signaux
catastrophiqu qui sont donné à tous ceux
qui voudraient ainsi venir dans notre
pays re régularis et dispos de l'ENSEM
des droit madame
Toria merci monsieur le Président bon
nous on on vient d'entendre que le
l'article proposé par par le Sénat
serait un compromis nous ne le pensons
pas nous pensons que le Sénat a durci ce
texte ça c'est une première chose que je
voudrais dire ensuite il faut sortir de
l'hypocrisie parce que effectivement il
y a 800000 travailleurs sans papier
aujourd'hui qui font vivre le pays qui
participe qui participe à l'économie du
pays donc nous nous pensons qu'il faut
tous et toutes les régulariser sortir de
cette hypocrisie de manière que de de
même que nous pensons qu'il faut aussi
donner un un titre de séjour purriannuel
à tous les étudiants et à tous les
parents des enfants scolarisés si on
veut justement que les étrangers
s'installent dans notre pays moi je
n'emploie pas ce mot d'intégration et
encore moins celui d'assimilation qu'on
a entendu hier mais si on veut que les
étrangers puissent s'installer dans
notre pays il faut leur donner cette
possibilité jusqu'à présent nous avions
une vision très raciste et très
xénophobe de de ce texte et des débats
et là aujourd'hui nous avons la vision
utilitariste qui a toujours qui a
toujours existé et je veux vous rappeler
par exemple j'ai à l'esprit la chanson
de François Beranger quand le le citron
a été pressé on peut jeter la peau donc
les métiers en tension ça voudra dire ça
ça voudra dire que une fois que les
métiers ne seront plus en tenenstion on
déménagera tous ces travailleurs on les
enverra ailleurs ou on les renverra dans
leur pays alors qu'ils auront contribuer
à l'économie de notre
pays alors avant de passer la parole à
Madame Diaz ce que vous dites madame
torignia est inexact puisque après la
carte de séjour temporaire ou
l'admission exceptionnelle de séjour qui
serait délivré à un étranger dans un
métier en tenstion celui-ci pourrait
solliciter une carte de séjour
pluriannuel comme c'est écrit dans les
projets initials du gouvernement et dans
le projet d'amendement de compromis du
rapporteur madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président donc
nous voilà enfin arrivé à un article
pivot du texte l'article 3 un article
qui parle de travail et donc
permettez-moi tout d'abord de regretter
l'absence continue du ministre du
Travail euh cet article cette volonté de
rétablissement de l'article 3 symbolise
cette espèce d'union sacrée qu'il existe
entre une partie de la macronie et la
PES dont l'idéologie mmigrationniste est
totalement assumée puisque vous cignez
ensemble des tribunes dans Libération
nous avons entendu depuis ce matin un
certain nombre de propos contestables
premier par exemple c'est que le travail
irrégulier contribue à l'économie oui à
l'économie souterraine incontestablement
et puis que les travailleurs irréguliers
répondent à une besoin de main d'œuvre
écoutez je trouve que ces propos sont
assez méprisants à l'égard des Français
dont vous soupçonnez qu'ils sont trop
faignants pour accepter certains méti
et puis ces arguments sont
particulièrement malhonnêtes parce que
si vous avez entendu les chefs
d'entreprise ils vous l'ont dit les
chefs d'entreprise ne demande pas la
régularisation des travailleurs et pire
il ne souhait pas être instrumentalisé
par ces débats donc nous au
rassemblement nationale nous réitérons
notre ferme opposition à la création
d'une filière d'immigration
supplémentaire et nous alertons sur les
risques de dérivve que présenterait cet
article parce qu'aujourd'hui vous nous
expliquez que euh tout va être encadré
sauf que sous la pression des
associations immigrationnistes et de
l'extrême gauche demain la liste des
métiers antention va être allongée les
zones vont être élargies et les
bénéficiaires vont aussi être plus
nombreux et donc demain on élargira la
régularisation au travailleurs à son
conjoint et cetera et cetera donc nous
en plus nous alertons sur le risque que
pourrait faire cet article pourrait
peser à la baisse sur les salaires et
donc nous nous le répétons nous ne
souhaitons pas créer une filière
d'immigration supplémentaire nous ne
voulons pas réguler l'IM vous avec ce
texte là vous dites que vous voulez
réguler l'immigration mais vous ne
voulez pas expulser vous ne voulez pas
dissuader de venir vous voulez juste
régulariser les clandestins merci
Monsieur de la porte
oui je pense que
après ces diatribes et ces fantasmes de
l'extrême droite il faut peut-être qu'on
revienne à à la réalité cette réalité
c'est une réalité à laquelle nous sommes
toutes et tous confrontés chaque jour
dans nos circonscriptions c'est celle
d'une grande hypocrisie et d'une grande
injustice c'est celle de tous ces
travailleurs qui viennent nous voir et
qui nous disent mais écoutez je suis là
je suis en France mes enfants ils vont à
l'école je suis carleur je suis maçon je
suis aide à domicile je travaille à
l'hôpital et je suis dans une situation
qui est intenable je suis dans un
travail en situation
irrégulière et ça cette zone
d'hypocrisie cette grande injustice
c'est ce que l'article 3 proposait
d'atténuer légèrement c'était un socle
minimal mais monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez dit finalement qu'il y avait un
esprit d'automatisation initialement
dans l'article 3 c'était le texte du
Gouvernement c'est celui que vous êtes
en train de renier aujourd'hui vous avez
dit voilà il n'y aura plus
d'autobacicité qui était l'esprit de
l'article 3 alors même que cet article 3
n'était d'ailleurs qu'un socle minimal
puisqu'il visait des métiers en tension
et que l'on sait très bien que le
travail irrégulier est par nature dans
des métiers qui ne sont pas forcément en
tension puisqu'ils ne sont pas reconnu
comme tel par pôemploi puisque par
exemple dans la restauration dans le
bâtiment on ne va pas forcément être en
tenstion puisqu'on trouve des gens pour
remplacer les travailleurs de façon
irrégulière la Défenseur des droits par
ailleurs a pointé une autre
hypocrisie celle de conditionner à 3 ans
parce que en faisant cela en
conditionnant à une durée dans le temps
vous encouragez finalement le travail
illégal le séjour irrégulier et la
précarité donc cette borne temporelle
elle ne nous paraît pas acceptable ne
rajoutons pas à ce que nous souhaitions
c'est-à-dire un droit opposable n
n'pposons pas au droit opposable
l'arbitraire et le non droit alors
Monsieur
nagelen Merci monsieur le Président
alors nous c'est on est relativement
clair on fait pas de numérologie donc ça
s'appelle un article 3 ou un article 4
bis ça nous est complètement égal
l'important c'est ce qu' va y avoir dans
cet article euh monsieur le rapporteur
général nous avons eu l'occasion
d'échanger à de nombreuses reprises
ensemble la départementalisation de la
liste des mé en sension et pour nous un
sujet extrêmement important vous nous
dites on n pas les informations alors
moi je comprends pas parce que pour
l'emploi m'envoie régulièrement par
bassin de vie donc pour le bassin de
Remirmont et pour le bassin de gérarmé
dans lesvoges les exact de pour l'emploi
tout comme d'ailleurs de nombreuses
administrations qui arrivent aujourd'hui
à le faire par circonscription donc je
pense qu'on peut on pourrait même
travailler sur quelque chose de beaucoup
plus précis que le le département on
trouvait que l'échelon départemental
était le était le le plus intéressant
parce que si je prends la région Grand
Est Strasbourg et le tio n'ont pas les
mêmes problématiques donc à un moment
donné on a vraiment si on veut être en
capacité de prendre des décisions qui
collent au plus près des préoccupations
des habitants on a besoin de cette de
cette de cet échelon dire aussi que
demain il faudra que la décision ne soit
pas uniquement prise par le préfet vous
l'avez dit c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on a déposé un amendement à l'article
4 bis pour pouvoir mettre autour de la
table les
consulaires les représentants des
administrations et pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs un représentant du conseil
départemental du conseil régional et les
parlementaires afin de pouvoir ensemble
état représentant des chambres
consulaires élus pouvoir discuter
ensemble de ce que sont de ce que
doivent être les métiers en tenstion
parce que ce sont tous ces acteurs qui
sont plus proches des réalités du
terrain et enfin Madame
Ménard merci monsieur le Président moi
je voudrais juste vous dire pourquoi
revenir à l'article 3 de ce projet de
loi qui vise à régulariser les
clandestins qui occupent des métiers en
tenstion est à mon avis une fausse bonne
idée d'abord je vous rappelle que les
régularisations n'ont jamais cessé
depuis François mitteran il y a eu la
circulaire Sarkozy de 2008 qui avait
créé une liste de 30 métiers en tension
qui permettait l'embauche de
travailleurs étrangers avec un
certificat de travail puis la circulaire
Vals de 2012 qui a régularisé les
étrangers en situation irrégulière qui
vivent en France depuis au moins 5 ans
et ont un contrat de travail ou une
promesse d'embauche et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que ces
régularisations sont loin d'avoir régler
le problème d'immigration en France ce
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui cet article
3 lui il veut octroyer une carte de
séjour de plein droit pour des
clandestins en France depuis plus de 3
ans et qui exercent un métier en tension
durant 8 mois au cours des deux
dernières années le Sénat lui a souhaité
prendre en compte des critères de
comportement d'adhésion à nos modes de
vie d'insertion tout simplement et à
allonger la durée de travail nécessaire
ça me paraît un minimum et ce qui me
gêne dans vos arguments c'est cette
petite musique de défiance envers les
préfets dont les décisions seraient
discrétionnaires en gros certains
seraient des méchants qui ne
régulariseront personne mais dans ce cas
pourquoi ne pas appliquer cette défiance
à d'autres domaines et réduire
drastiquement les prérogatives de ces
serviteurs de l'État et aussi envers les
employeurs qui seraient forcément des
vilains patrons qui profiteraient de la
précarité de leurs employés pour ne pas
les régulariser et puis dernière
argument l'appel d'air vous prétendez
que c'est un faux argument qu' en aura
pas mais est-ce que vous croyez vraiment
que les passeurs qui organisent les
filières vont s'embarrasser de détail et
expliquer les conditions nécessaires
pour pour éventuellement obtenir un
titre de séjour ils diront tout
simplement tu n'as qu'à dire que tu es
maçon serveur ou livreur et tu seras
régularisé viens donc en France voilà
c'est pourquoi je suis totalement
opposée à ces amendements de
réétablissement de l'article 3 je vous
remercie je vais suspendre 5 minutes
pour que vous puissiez aller voter en
séance et ensuite le ministre répondra à
tous vos
arguments c'est c'est pas
maintenant
on va on va on va poursuivre
et on va
pours décidément cette salle de
commission donc ce que je vous propose
c'est qu' on poursuivre au contraire et
que j'ai le retour séance pour que je
puisse interrompre la commission lorsque
ce sera nécessaire si vous pouvez aviser
les collègues qui sont qui sont partis
et comme ça le ministre va vous répondre
en attendant monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
alors c'est effectivement un moment
important que c article 3 puis l'article
l'article
4 même s'il n'est pas l'essentiel de ce
texte c'est une disositions ou des
dispositions qui sont cohérents avec
l'ensemble du texte bon de qui
parle-t-on parce que même encore
maintenant et après des mois des
semaines de de débats parlementaires et
médiatique on continue parfois à ne pas
parler du texte en lui-même mais parler
parfois de choses qui auraient pu y être
ou sont dans les médias mais mais pas
dans le texte on parle de travailleur
qui sont en irrégularité du point de vue
du droit du séjour mais en régularité du
point de vue du droit du travail c'est
ça notre difficulté on parle de gens qui
sont déjà sur le sol national et qui ont
des fiches de paye et parfois des
contrat de
travail nous parlons de ces personnesl
et la difficulté c'est que il vientnent
nourrir
l'énorme en effet nombre de personnes
qui relèvent des fameux niniis ni
expulsa ni régularisable parce que cela
fait très longtemps sous divers
gouvernements qu'ils sont arrivés sur le
territoire national nous ne parlons pas
de gens qui sont en effet comme
rapporteur général à l'extérieur du
territoire national parlons des gens qui
sont sur le territoire
national et ces gens qui ont des fiches
de paye payent des impôts avec l'impôt à
la source puisque un taux neutre
s'applique payent des cotisations et
pour autant n'ont pas les droits qui
relèvent du travailleur donc il y a deux
solutions soit on expulse ces personnes
don commençant par condamner les
entreprises qui embauchent les personnes
de cette manière bien soit régularise
une partie ou toute partie de ces
personnes le problème c'est que le droit
aujourd'hui ne permet de faire ni l'un
ni l'autre et le texte résout les
questions des uns et des
autres d'abord je voudrais rappeler à
chacune et à chacun ici que l'article
enfin disposition la plus importante de
l'article 3 c'est de permettre à
l'employé au salarié puisqu'on parle de
travailleur salarié de pouvoir être
régularisé sans son employeur
aujourd'hui
vous ne pouvez pas régulariser un
employé si l'employeur ne signe pas le
SERFA pourquoi il veut pas signer le
SERFA l'employeur d'une part parce qu'il
va payer une contribution à l'OFI et
qu'il a aucune envie sans doute de la
payer mais indépendamment de ça il sait
très bien que c'est la démonstration
qu'il a employé quelqu'un qui n'aurait
pas dû employer c'est un patron en
grande partie
voyou et c'est pour cela que l'article 8
que nous vous proposons plus tard dans
le débat permet en même temps que nous
libérons si je dis le jou de
l'exploiteur de l'employeur sur
l'employé de connaître ceux qui
embauchent des personnes irrégulières
sans papier à qui ils font de vrais faux
documents pour pouvoir non seulement les
poursuivre pénalement même s'il y a peu
de poursuite pénale malheureusement dans
notre pays moins de 500 procédures par
an alors que le ministère de l'Intérieur
inspection du travail en engage 15000
mais surtout de donner aux mains des
préfets une fermeture administrative et
des amendes extrêmement fortes pour
pouvoir arrêter le flux continu des
personnes qui sont embauchées de manière
irrégulière avec de vrais faux contrats
de travail ou de vrais faux bulletins de
salaire ce qui est très important donc
c'est de prendre le texte dans sa
globalité aujourd'hui en refusant le
texte non seulement vous ne réglez pas
le problème de l'employer de l'employeur
peut-être pour la partie gauche de
l'hémicycle mais en plus vous ne tarifez
pas le flux des personnes irrégulières
en étant hypocrite en laissant les
patron continuer à embaucher des
personnes irrégulières sans jamais être
condamné donc vous allez continuer à
faire ce flux c'est le premier point si
vous ne libérez donc pas l'employé de
l'employeur dans la demande de
régularisation Vous ne connaîtrait pas
le continent caché de ceux qui
exploitent des personnes de manière
irrégulière dans des conditions souvent
à
dire deuxème sujet nous parlons de qui
au sens de l'action et des activités on
parle des métiers en tenstion ces
métiers en tenstion ils sont pas si
nombreux que ça d'ailleurs les exemples
que vous
prenez souvent ne sont pas correspondent
pas à la réalité la restauration n'est
pas un métier ention
aujourd'hui non mais aujourd'hui la
restauration ne correspond pas à métiers
en attention oui mais je voudrais le
redire parce que ça a été encore pris
tout à l'heure comme exemple de serveur
et deuxièmement nous parlons de zones
géographiques où il y a des difficultés
d'embauche c'est-à-dire que les
propositions de régularisation qui ont
été imaginées dans l'article 3 dans la
modification faite par le Sénat dans la
modification proposée par l' rapporteur
général lit les deux lit la liste des
métiers en tenstion et lit les zones
géographiques tendu pour le marché du
travail donc quand j'entends qu'il y a
des endroits où il y a 12 13 % de
chômage je prends l'exemple de la région
haut--fance le texte ne prévoit pas de
régulariser ces personnes dans cette
région c'est pas ce qui est écrit dans
le texte en revanche il est évident que
si je prends l'exemple de la Bretagne où
il y a un taux de chômage très peu élevé
ou évid ément on a besoin de personnes
pour travailler dans l'agriculture par
exemple ou dans les travaux publics oui
le texte s'applique à la région Bretagne
donc quand j'entends que c'est une
régularisation nationale massive et
indistincte de la question du chômage
c'est tout à fait faux troisièmement le
gouvernement vient vers vous pour vous
dire aujourd'hui il y a d'hypocrisie
partout et pardon Mesdames et Messieurs
les parlementaires il y a d'hypocrisie
partout un il y a d'hypocrisie de la
part en effet des employeurs à réclamer
des main d'œuvres étrangères non déclaré
il pay en des faet moins cher avec des
droits syndicaux qui n'existent pas des
protections sociales qui n'existent pas
et à la fin il faut pas se plaindre
qu'il a plus de monde à laame si les
gens qui pay des cotisations peuvent pas
bénéficier de la sécurité sociale faut
qu'on soit un petit peu cohérent parce
que inspection y a des actions du
travail comme partout
de permettez-moi de vous dire que il y a
d'hypocrisie législatif parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous le faisons en
circulaire et moi j'entends les
arguments de la gauche il y a aucun
problème mais à chaque fois que vous
êtes dans la majorité vous faites jamais
ça vous vous n'avez jamais fait ça vous
navez il y a un moment je prends
l'exemple la circulaire Vals voilà la
circulaire la circulaire la circula Vals
la circula Vals non non mais la
circulire Vals sous le président de
François s président François Hollande
non mais ne
ne ne contestez pas ne contestez pas la
vérité le gouvernement socialiste de
Monsieur Hollande a préféré a préféré
l'hypocrisie il a préféré ce que nous
aurions pu faire évidemment prendre une
circulaire c'estàd ne pas venir non mais
c'est pas question de Rouard c'est une
question d'honnêteté intellectuelle
Monsieur L voilà et et quand vous étiez
baouiste quand vous étiez baouiste au
modem vous étiez sans doute dans cette
forme là de contestation de ce que de
cette
hypocrisie socialiste vous prenez une
circulaire qui consiste à régulariser
des personnes sans le dire au légis oui
mais il faut pas qu'il continue sa déri
parce que si en moins de 10 ans il passe
de Baou les fill ça risque d'être aller
assz
EXIF non je ça dépend non je ne crois
pas je ne crois
pas on va pas commenter le parcours de
monsieur l on va commenter l'article 3
parce que c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant pour les Français dans ce
pays il y aura des thèses sans doute
plus tard donc la
question la question est de savoir si on
est hypocrite faisons-nous faisons-nous
mesdames et messieurs les députés
faisons-nous faisons-nous mesdames et
messieurs députés aujourd'hui des
régularisations et compris par le
travail la réponse est oui d'ailleurs
tous les groupes politiques
m'écrivent mais tous les groupes
politiques m'écrivent pour demander des
régularisations
aujourd'hui tous les groupes politiques
m'écrivent tous les groupes politiques
m'écrivent monsieurput et vous savez
très bien et c'est normal et c'est
normal et c'est
normal
simplement simplement simplement non
tous les groupes
alors attendez monsieur le ministre
juste un petit moment si si on perd un
temps fou pour faire répondre le
ministre moi je vais gagner du temps sur
vos intervention que je refais passer
tout à une minute y compris sur les
sujets sensibles d'accord donc on écoute
le ministre lorsqu'il
répond tous les groupes politiques
m'écrivent et qu'est-ce que l'on fait
aujourd'hui bah voilà tout se fait un
petit peu sans le dire au Parlement sans
le dire au français sans le dire en
cachette des courriers sont envoyés on
le dit au préfet vous avez rendez-vous
avec votre préfet irrégularise
régularise pas le gouvernement arrive
devant vous et vous dit prenez des
critères fixer les critères dans la loi
alors moi je veux bien entendre des
arguments comme on l'a entendu depuis le
début de la commission des lois pour
dire sur le niveau A2 alors que c'est
clairement du domaine règlementaire là
on veut dire comment ça se passe on va
même savoir comment se passe l'examen de
français et même à quelle heure do les
gens on doivent mettre dans la loi et
puis quand on vous dit quand on vous dit
quand on vous dit prenez les critères de
régularisation que vous soyez pour une
large régularisation ou pour rest
régularisation vous le refusez bon donc
c'est évidemment c'est évidemment c'est
évidemment pas possible parce qu'on
aurait pu discuter madame jeunevard on
aurait pu discuter monsieur nagelen on
aurait pu discuter monsieur marcangelli
avec les parlementaires du Sénat ou même
vous-même pour dire bah les critères de
l'article 3 tel que fixé par le
gouvernement ne nous vons pas pourquoi
d'attendre 3 ans faisons 5 ans ou 7 ans
pourquoi demander 8 mois faisons 12 ou
14 mois pourquoi les métiers en tenstion
et pas d'autres métiers pourquoi les
zones géographiques et en effet Monsieur
Nag moi je partage totalement votre
demande et encore une fois je pense
qu'on peut trouver un moyen de vous
donner satisfaction dans l'hémicycle sur
les sur la territorialisation il faut
qu'on le fasse à ministaire du travail
vous le comprendrez parce que sinon ce
serait une promesse qui n'aurait pas de
lendemain mais c'est le principe même de
la de la réforme de dire c'est en zone
géographique particulière donc on a
ouvert la voie et compris à une forme de
départementalisation donc et avec les
branches professionnelles et on vous dit
voilà prenez les critères et donc là on
comprend que finalement il y a il y a
deux possibilités qui s'expriment ceux
qui disent mettons pas de critère
régularisons tout le monde c'est
évidemment pas possible et pas
acceptable et ceux qui disent on veut
même pas en parler continue d'être
hypocrite vous avez qu' prendre une
circulaire heureusement entendu par ces
arguments le Sénat y compris sa majorité
a souhaité donc que nous puissions
mettre dans la loi un certain de
critères sur lequels on peut pas être
d'accord ou pas d'accord enfin j'imagine
que si Monsieur rotillot lui-même a voté
cet article modifié c'est donc bien
queil correspondait à à une réalité et
puis moi je je je veux le dire ici vous
encouragez
vous encouragez l'inverse de ce que vous
voulez faire et je dis notamment au
groupe
LR lorsque vous refusez cette
disposition par principe prenons
l'exemple d'une dame qui
travaille cette dame
travaille euh dans dans un secteur de
métier ention si l'employeur ne veut pas
signer son SERFA elle ne peut pas être
régularisée même si le parlementaire qui
m'écrit le souhaite même si le préfet le
voudrait même si le ministre voudrait
c'est un article de loi
bien et comment elle peut être
régularisée cette dame bah si elle fait
un
enfant si elle fait un enfant elle peut
te régulariser en Vals vous pensez que
c'est c'est intelligent de dire de
pousser les gens c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui bah vous avez des critères
madame de régularisation il faut que
vous fassiez un enfant par exemple c'est
c'est absurde surtout que pardon ce
tytre de séjour temporaire 1 an n'ouvre
pas droit au groupement familial et
conditionné pour la réussite
pluriannuelle puisquen effet c'est une
possibilité à l'examen de français qu'on
a fait dans l'article 1 permet de ne pas
justement pour reprendre l'expression
tout à l'heure de la France insoumise de
tirer les salaires vers le bas puisquon
a vous avez voté l'article 2 à
l'unanimité qui prévoit que désormais
l'employeur doit donner pendant les Hees
de travail les cours de français qui
rend par nature le salarié moins
compétitif et effectivement allant vers
l'article 8 permet quand elle dénoncera
son son employeur de sanctionner très
fortement l'employeur et de fermer son
entreprise d'ailleurs je me demande si
cette attaque systématique pour des gens
dont je rappelle ça a été posé comme
question ça concerne pour Val sans
travail 7000 personnes par an et on a 12
à 13000 dossierers par an donc je sais
pas où sont les chiffres de centaines de
milliers de personnes mais rien nous
empêche par ailleurs comme ça fait par
l'excellent sénateur spinner qui
n'appartient pas à la majorité
parlementaire de mettre des cotas je
rappelle que le sénateur spinner au
Sénat sénateur LR ancien maire du 16e
arrondissement on peut pas dire que ce
soit un gauchiste absolu a dit on va
prendre l'article 3 et on met un quota
mais mettez des Cotat mettez 8000 10000
5000 par an si vous le souhaitez si vous
avez peur de l'appel d'air si on
considère que ce sont des cas
particuliers alors évidemment il y a des
modifications du Sénat qui sont tout à
fait heureuses moi je veux dire que le
fait qu'on doit regarder si les gens nai
pas de casier judiciire et s'ils sont
conformes évidemment dans leur vie au
valeurs de la République je le prends
bien volontiers c'est euh c'est dans le
texte du Gouvernement pour l'article 13
aucune raison de pas le mettre dans
l'article 3 dans l'article 4 bis alors
on terminera par dire Mesdames et
Messieurs les
parlementaires et notamment je je veux
le dire aux interventions du groupe
socialiste on aurait vraiment aimé voter
ce texte article 3 bon c'est quand même
pas mal et puis là vous reculez mais
attendez soyons clair je dis au groupe
socialiste vous avez dit dès le début
que vous voteriez contre le texte
immigration avant même avant même même
qu'on puisse même en dire un mot V
racontre regarde que d'autres groupes
politiques ne l'ont pas fait à exception
de la France insoumise donc euh il est
possible que vous pariez sur la connerie
du gouvernement c'est c'est une
possibilité qui consisterait à dire
voilà on va faire un article de
régularisation pour les travailleurs
euh mais la droite puisque moi il a une
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale la droite ayant dit que elle
ne voudrait pas d'article de plein droit
et on peut l'entendre puisque
effectivement nous discutons d' une
majorité relative très bien régularisons
en faisant l'article 3
mais donc en fait vous nous dites que
vous voulez l'article 3 mais vous
voterez contre le texte doncit vous
votez l'article 3 et en fait à la fin
vous voterez contre l'article 3 parce
que vous vez contre le texte donc ça
s'appelle ça s'appelle de l'hypocrisie
vous ne l'avez pas fait en
responsabilité vous le faites quand vous
êtes dans l'opposition vous poussez une
demande de régularisation tout en
voulant pas la régularisation puisque VZ
contre le texte personne ne comprend
rien on se croirait dans un congrès du
Parti socialiste avec de détendance et
sousendance donc arrêtez arrêtez cette
hypocrisie s'il vous plaît s'il s'agit
de trouver un compromis poussé par
rapporteur général je veux dire que sans
doute l'amendement 1665 du rapporteur
général mérite encore peut-être d'être
modifié dans le sens que propose
monsieur nelen notamment sur la
territorialisation je crois que ce qu'à
évoqué madame Jacquier Laforge sur le
fait que c'est ni une régularation de
plein droit ni un
devoir premier et seul du préfet et que
c'est un compromis entre les deux est
assez ingénieux j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire à monsieur le rapporteur général
que nous n'avons rien à cacher aux
branches professionnelles et aux
parlementaires et que comme ils
interviennent beaucoup pour les demandes
pour tel ou tel travailleurs qu'
connaissent mieux que nous on pourrait
imaginer aussi que les branches
professionnelles et les parlementaires
soient associés aux décisions dans des
des commissions adoc qui peuvent se cré
dans chacun des départements parce que
je suis aussi sensible aussi à
l'argument de dire moi mon préfet il est
très fermé moi mon préfet il est très
ouvert mais je pense qu'on peut encore
améliorer cette
amendement
1665 qui serait éventuellement adopté
mais il m'a paraît assez
nécessaire de pouvoir distinguer dans le
texte de loi que nous faisons la fermeté
absolue que nous voulons contre les
étrangers délinquants puisque ce texte
le prévoit ce qui n'avait pas été fait
auparavant et que nous réparons des
erreurs mais aussi la fin d'hypocrisie
parce que je pense que c'est ce que
demande nos concitoyens voilà euh
mesdames et messieurs les députés en
rejetant donc les articles de
restauration du 3 et en soutenant par
avance l'amendement de compromis de la
rapporteur et Monsieur rapporteur
général monsieur Val et prend
votre d'abord dire que au ministre que
quand il était rentré en discussion
exclusive avec Monsieur sooti j'ai
effectivement dit que c'était mal barré
pour que nous soutenions
une un texte qui serait coécrit avec la
droite il y a manifestement au moins
deux ministres c'est ce que less
appellent le Dole ganger l'ami
imaginaire celui qui siège au Sénat et
qui dit une chose celui qui siège à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui en dit une
autre
nous avons continu joué le rôle du
parlementarisme de fait et à chaque fois
qu'on peut amener des victoires au
français et au français nous le faisons
et nous avons même soutenu des textes et
amendé des textes du du
gouvernement
monsieur le ministre qu'il est fallu
sans doute aller au-delà de la
circulaire Vals j'en suis aujourd'hui
convaincu et c'est comme parlementaire
jeétais pas avant pas plus que ministre
que je m'exprime et que je m'exprime
aussi à travers une position qui est
celle délibérée par le Parti socialiste
dans la clarté de ce que nous défendons
l'absence de clarté et l'hypocrisie
aujourd'hui pardons vous le dire
monsieur le ministre mais elle est dans
la duplicité de vos expression entre le
Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale mais vous non plus ne cherchez
pas je je vous réponds avec la même
dialectique que la vôtre voilà Monsieur
le Ministre bon
alors heureusement c'est l'assemblée qui
délibère aujourd'hui et la commission
des lois et donc je mettre au voix les
amendements qui ont été étudiés pour
l'article 3 successivement l'amendement
numéro 635 de Monsieur Castellani qui
vote pour qui vote contre rejeté
l'amendement
636 il était non soutenu l'amendement
887 monsieur Vall qui vote pour qui vote
contre
rejeté amendement 889 de Monsieur Vallot
qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté l'amendement 890 qui vote pour
contre
rejeté l'amendement 724 qui vote pour
contre rejeté les amendements identiques
1444 est suivant qui vote
pour contre rejeté l'amendement
identique 1095 et suivant qui vote pour
qui vote contre
rejeté l'amendement 638 de monsieur
nagelen qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
rejeté après l'article
3 est-ce que vous pouvez faire une
présentation commune de vos amendements
monsieur
tacher
Tach est vous pouvez faireation commune
de vos amendementsors merci monsieur le
président euh on va aborder un sujet
extrêmement important qui est celui de
l'autorisation de travail des des
demandeurs d'asile euh aujourd'hui ils
n'ont effectivement pas le droit de
travailler avant une avant une durée
d'au moins euh d'au moins 9 mois euh et
même euh et même quand enfin non c'est
plutôt 9 mois euh le critère légal et au
bout de 6 mois il peut y avoir une
autorisation avec euh avec finalement
euh euh un accord du préfet donc là on
propose de faire quelque chose de
beaucoup plus euh beaucoup plus ouvert
et qui est finalement aligné sur ce qui
se fait un peu partout en Europe à
savoir ouvrir le marché du travail au au
demandeurs d'asile un mois après le
dépôt de leur demande dans les mêmes
conditions que pour les réfugiés il est
vraiment important que sur cette
question puisqu'on entend parler
d'intégration par le travail par vous
monsieur le ministre par un certain
nombre de parlementaires de la majorité
on puisse réellement avancer il est tout
à fait c'est une anomalie complète en
Europe que les demandur d'asile ne
puissent pas travailler et c'est un vrai
frein pour leur intégration future donc
je vous propose avec cet amendement
qu'on qu'on mette fin à cette anomalie
merci vous avez défendu lesquels
monsieur monsieur tacher vous avez
défendu lequel euh j'ai défendu le
premier évidemment qui serait le plus
intéressant c'est-à-dire au bout d'un
mois je peux faire rapidement les deux
autres puisque il s'agit ensuite de
ouvrir au bout de 2 mois ou de TR mois
si véritablement un mois ne convenait
pas mais véritablement j'insiste encore
une fois les demandeurs d'asile quand
ils ne peuvent pas travailler pendant
tout le temps de l'instruction une fois
qu'ils deviennent réfugiés c'est très
difficile d'accéder à l'emploi donc si
vraiment on parle d'intégration par le
travail c'est dès qu'ils arrivent en
France qu'ils doivent pouvoir travailler
donc le 1489 est défendu 1490 aussi et
le 1491 c'est cela ça c'est ça madame la
rapporteur sur ces trois amendements
s'il vous plaît euh merci monsieur le
Président donc sur tous ces amendements
qui concernent en fait l'accès au
travail pour les les demandeurs d'asile
on y reviendra sur l'article 4 He que je
souhaite rétablir si je partage vos
convictions sur le fait effectivement
qu'il faut pouvoir permettre au
demandeurs d'asile d'accéder au travail
à mon sens euh la l'équilibre qui a été
trouvé euh par l'article 4 me semble bon
sur finalement le fait que la protection
en tout cas la nationalité à laquelle
appartient le demandeur d'asile a un
niveau de protection élevé qui permet
effectivement de pouvoir dès le dépôt et
à ce moment-là il y a pas de des délais
comme vous l'indiquez puisse accéder
tout de suite au marché du travail ça me
semble un bon équilibre et c'est pour ça
que sur les amendements que vous
proposez qui ne limite pas euh enfin
finalement la nationalité du demandeur
et au taux de protection qui irait avec
pour toutes ces raisons c'est un avis
défavorable sur ces amendements là mais
on va continuer à avir le débat sur
l'article 4 je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre oui je veux dire au députés
taché que je comprends ces demandes moi
je je militerai comme je l'ai fait au
Sénat pour le rétablissement de
l'article 4 il correspond pas tout à
fait à ce que vous dites puisque là nous
parlons de taux de protection puisqu'il
s'agit en effet de pouvoir donner des
autorisations de travail aux gens dont
on sait que ils ont une très grande
chance d'être en effet à la fin
bénéficier de la protection asilaire
c'est pas le cas de vous le savez bien
de toutes les nationalités qui viennent
chez nous et qui passent par la demande
d'asile pour on peut le dire soit par
des passeurs soit tout seul détourner la
procédure pour aller imigration de
travail donc ce qu'on peut imaginer
monsieur le député c'est d'abord qu'on
restaure l'article 4 ce qui serait déjà
une très bonne chose deuxièmement qu'on
parle du niveau de taux de protection
aujourd'hui on a dit un tau de
protection de 50 % en dessous on ne fait
pas l'avance sur les 6 mois au-dessus on
faitavance sur les 6 mois c'est
réglementaire je suis tout à fait prêt à
discuter évidemment pour que ce soit
soit législatif soit que l'on modifie
dans la consultation que que l'on peut
mener mais il me semble qu'un mois ou de
mois me paraît un peu tôt d'ailleurs
vous savez même les les associations qui
accompagnent les demandeurs d'asile
disent eux-mêmees qui ne peuvent pas
travailler immédiatement après avoir
parcouru des parcours de vie très très
difficiles faut faut qu'on regarde
ensemble en tout cas je ne rejette pas
par principe votre demande juste pour
dire également qu'il y a une disposition
qui ne touche pas les demandurs d'asile
qui touche les travailleurs étrangers de
simplification je sais que vous y êtes
attentif finalement de autorisation de
travail qui est euh distinguer du titre
de séjour donné par la préfecture et ce
qui est bien dans l'article du
rapporteur général et la discussion
qu'il a eu avec le Sénat c'est que pour
pour ce qui est du métier entention un
titre de séjour vaut autorisation de
travail ce qui simplifie grandement la
vie de tout le monde moi je proposerai
dans le texte de ce loi texte de loi
notamment dans l'hémicycle on puisse se
dire on va fusionner les deux types de
séjour V autorisation de travail ce qui
permettrait de gagner beaucoup de temps
respecterait les personnes travailleuses
respecterai aussi la demande du marché
du travail et simplifierit la vie
administrative on peut aussi travailler
sur ça c'est pas votre demande Surand
d'asile c'est sur les travailleurs
étrangers qui travaillent mais mais qui
correspond à mon avis à ce que vous
souhaitez faire puisque si ils n'ont pas
de chance d'avoir d'asile ils veulent
travailler de manière d'immigration
économique et ça respecte plus en
parcours donc un avis défavorable sur
vos amendements mais vous renvoyant à
votre soutien je l'espère sur l'article
4 qui permettra de la discussion
peut-être dans l'hémicycle ouis très
bien vous voulez maintenz monsieur tcher
oui j'ai des amendements qui vont dans
le sens de ce que dit Monsieur le
Ministre ensuite pour fusionner le titre
de séjour l'autorisation de travail donc
j'espère qu'on pourra euh en parler à ce
moment-là et les adopter à ce moment-là
alors sur vos amendements le 1489 qui
vote pour qui vote contre rejeté le 1490
qui vote pour contre rejeté et le 1491
pour contre
rejeté le suivant est toujours le vote
mon 1485 peut-être en présentation
commune avec le suivant également
allez-y le 1485 monsieur le Président
chers collègues il vise finalement à
mettre fin à cette taxe que doivent
payer les employeurs qui finalement
recrutent un travailleur étranger moi
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à à
plusieurs reprises je considère
contrairement à ce qu'on entend souvent
très à droite de cet hémicycle que la
préférence nationale elle existe déjà en
France et c'est un exemple probant on
doit effectivement quand on veut
employer un un travailleur étranger en
situation légale payer des taxes
extrêmement importantes je ne comprends
pas pourquoi si un chef d'entreprise
veut recruter un travailleur d'ailleurs
parce qu'ilestime plus compétent qu'il n
la nationalité ou non il doit pouvoir le
faire sans avoir ce type de frein encore
une fois je le redis il y a tout un tas
de domaine dans notre pays où en fait la
préférence nationale existe déjà
contrairement à ce que l'extrême droite
essaie de nous faire croire à longueur
de temps donc je propose avec cet
amendement au moins sur la partie du
droit et de l'accès à l'emploi de mettre
fin à ce principe que je combat
évidemment et al le 1496 prentation
commune vous l'avez défendu également
est défendu madame la rapporteur sur ces
deux amendements s'il vous plaît c'est
des c'est des faits av pour les mêmes
raisons que j'ai indiqué précisemment
alors je vais les mettre au voix qui
vaêre pour le
contre rejeté le 1487 qui vote
pour contre
rejeté le 1053 qui est-ce qui le défend
monsieur Lucas merci monsieur le
Président nous entendons protéger
l'étranger salarié sans titre qui
demanderait sa régularisation pour motif
profession i d'éventuelles mesures de
rétorsion de la part de son employeur il
y a c'est été dit tout à l'heure
effectivement des employeurs indélicats
je trouvais très beau ce terme
trèspudique on ne peut pas écarter
l'hypothèse dans laquelle un employeur
qui apprendrait la démarche de
régularisation engagée par son salarié
procède au licenciement de celui-ci par
crainte d'une sanction d'administration
de sorte à éviter un tel effet pervers
cet amendement propose d'assimiler ses
salariés à des salariés protégés au sens
du Code du travail le temps de la
procédure de régularisation le
licenciement ou la rupture du contrat ne
serait pas possible mais serait soumis à
une autorisation de l'inspection du
travail celle-ci déterminera alors si le
licenciement ou la rupture du contrat de
travail repose sur un motif autre que
celui de la démarche de régularisation
qui a été
engagé madame la rapporteur
oui merci Monsieur le le président en
fait je comprends votre votre
préoccupation euh sauf que tel qu'il est
rédigé l'amendement semble en fait pas
opérationnel et et pas opportun sur donc
ce sera un avis défavorable sur
l'opération ité en fait il y a une
discordance entre l'exposé et le
dispositif juridique que vous proposez
parce que dans l'exposé des motifs vous
associez la protection par l'inspection
du travail à une rupture de contrat de
travail à l'initiative de l'employeur
consécutif donc à une demande de
régularisation présentée par un salarié
étranger sans titre mais la référence à
l'engagement d'une démarche de
régularisation en fait elle est absente
dans le dans le dispositif que vous
présentez donc en fait si on adoptait
votre amende
en
l'état finalement l'étranger en
situation irrégulière licencié par son
employeur bénéficierait quel que soit le
motif de licenciement d'une protection
comparable à celle accordée au aux
délégués syndicaux alors ça c'était le
premier point le deuxème c'est ça semble
pas opportun parce qu' en application du
L
8252-1 du Code de travail un travailleur
en situation irrégulière et aujourd'hui
déjà autorisé à saisir le le Conseil des
prudommes pour contester la la rupture
du contrat de travail donc en fait il
bénéficie déjà d'un recours et donc sur
le fond si je comprends votre
préoccupation en fait le meilleur moyen
d'y répondre c'est pas de permettre à
l'étranger concererné d'être placé sous
la protection de l'inspection du du
travail à mon sens le meilleur moyen ce
serait de permettre à la personne
concernée d'être à l'initiative de sa
procédure de régularisation pour motif
professionnel et c'est ce que prévoit
notre notre projet de loi donc ce sera
un avis défavorable je vous remerci je
le mets au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le suivant les deux
suivants peut-être monsieur tacher en en
présentation commune oui alors donc on
revient toujours sur la question des
autorisations de travail et de ce que je
j'appelle la préférence nationale dans
l'emploi il y a effectivement déjà le
fait que les employeurs doivent payer
des taxes mais avant ça il y a toute une
procédure dérogatoire qui doit consister
dans le fait de publier euh en de
prouver pour l'employeur que il n'a
absolument trouvé aucun euh euh
travailleurs qui ont la nationalité
française pour pouvoir recruter un un
travailleur étranger si ça c'est pas de
la préférence nationale je ne sais pas
ce que c'est et donc effectivement sur
cette question des des des autorisations
de travail le ministre il faisait
allusion tout à l'heure et et disait que
ce serait peut-être intéressant de les
fusionner directement avec le titre de
séjour pour ne pas avoir cette double
instruction et avoir des gens qui ont le
titre de séjour mais non'ont pas
forcément l'autorisation de travail
propose de de de supprimer tout cela
encore une fois laissons les chefs
d'entreprise finalement choisir les
travailleurs qu'ils veulent en fonction
de leurs compétences et pas en fonction
de critères de nationalité tout cela n'a
aucun sens madame la rapporteur vos avis
oui alors ce sera un avis euh
défavorable alors si je partage votre
préoccupations sur les autorisations de
travail on aura l'occasion d'en d'en
rediscuter euh elle peut avoir un
intérêt et et notamment je tiens juste à
à indiquer hein que ça peut être aussi
euh le cas par exemple quand il y a une
visite médicale pour les saisonniers
donc si vous la supprimez pour tout
voilà il peut y avoir des des cas dans
lesquels ça peut être nécessaire de la
conserver donc c'est un avis défavorable
et je crois que le ministre va aussi
s'exprimer sur ce
sujet monsieur le ministre oui comme je
dit Monsieur le Député moi je suis prêt
à avancer sur ce sujet peut-être dans
l'hémicycle pour pour trois raisons la
première un c'est que c'est normalement
du domaine réglementaire mais je suis
prêt à à prendre un engagement
législatif pour pouvoir montrer qu'il y
a une fusion à obtenir entre le titre de
séjour autorisation de travail ça
simplifiera la vie d'absolument tout le
monde je pense qu'il faut pas que ce
soit trop dur non plus dans dans dans
notre norme parce que le jour où il y a
des modifications à la marge on sera
obligé de reconvoquer une loi et
évidemment c'est toujours plus simple de
le faire de manière réglementaire maisi
je suis prêt à travailler avec vous sur
ce point deuxièmement je pense qu'on
peut aussi travailler du coup sur les
dispositions qui consistent parfois
constater quelqu'un qui était
régulièrement sur le territoire national
devient irrégulier alors qu'il travaille
tout à fait convenablement et qui est
arrivé régulièrement mais par notre
propre incurie administrative les gens
demandent un rendez-vous en préfecture
sur un titre de 5 ans ou de 10 ans ils
n'obtiennent pas à temps parfois la
préfecture met 6 mois 8 mois 9 mois à
répondre et la personne qui quel que
soit son métier et j'ai vu encore très
récemment des ingénieurs concernés par
ce sujet donc il s'agit pas que du de
difficulté de métier entention d'avoir
un titre de séjour et donc ils perdent
leur travail ou l'employeur se met dans
l'irrégularité par solidarité avec son
salarié alors qu'il normalement sous
leoccupe peut-être même duqtf donc c'est
complèement totalement absurde de notre
part en attendant la réforme des
préfectures que j'ai évoqué déjà
plusieurs fois je proposerais qu'on
puisse imaginer comme les Allemands le
font avec une sorte de tolérance pour
que ces personnes qui ont un contrat de
travail qui sont arrivées régulirement
sur le territoire national et que
l'administration rend irrégulier du fait
de notre propre incue ne connaisse pas
ni des ETF ni d'incertitude dans leur
vie de travail ça c'est deuxième point
on pourrait travailler en même temps que
cette autorisation de séjour après
troisèmement la contrepartie de ça par
que sa bien pourquoi ça a été inventé
c'est de vérifier la véracité du travail
voilà et donc la véracité du travail je
pense qu'elle se vérifie autrement que
par une double démarche administrative
elle se vérifie en fournissant un
engagement de l'employeur qui dès le
début du titre de séjour et et pas dans
la parallèle autorisation de travail je
terminerai par dire monsieur le député
qu'il a aussi un autre point c'est
l'autorisation de travail avec le séjour
quand les gens changent de
travail Chang d'employeur ils doivent
redemander une autorisation de travail
donc ça c'est assez absurde il faut bien
l'avouer et donc je j'ai pas vu je crois
d'amendement de votre part sur ce point
mais je suis prêt peut-être que le
président he alors moi je suis prêt à
travailler également dans les myyque
pour que quand on donne une autorisation
de travail et qu'à titre de séjour quand
ça correspond au besoin de la main
d'œuvre et dans les condition de de de
langue française et et et de valeur de
la républiqueon a déjà évoqué bah voilà
qu'on donne la le l'autorisation pour
l'ensemble des employeurs pas pour
chacun des employeurs parce que là
évidemment ça créé pour la personne
étrangère comme pour l'administration
française une situation qui Cayette
voilà donc je suis prêt auss travailler
ce qu'on peut peut-être faire monsieur
le député avec ceux qui s'intéressent à
cette question et avec Madame la
rapporteur sous son autorité peut-être
c'est trouver un amendement global qui
permette de parler d'autorisation de
travail renvoyer au règlementaire avec
des principes qui lent l'administration
et et la parole du ministre et qui
simplifie de manière générale ce sujet
tout en vérifiant évidemment qu'il
s'agit d'un d'un vrai travail mais j'ai
bien compris que c'était pas c'était pas
un détournement que vous proposiez mais
bien une
simplification défavorable mais en vous
encourageant à y trraavailler pour la
semaine
prochaine alors Monsieur tacher madame
je vais je vais je vais les maintenir
parce que c'est c'est c'est des
amendements importants j'entends en
revanche l'ouverture que que vous faites
monsieur le ministre pour la séance donc
s'il y a possibilité d'avoir un
amendement global pour faire que ces
autorisations de travail et ces tytes de
séjour soi fusionné que ce soit dans la
loi moi je je je suis disponible pour
pour discuter de cela j'ai entendu aussi
ce que vous avez dit sur la continuité
des droits et j'avais un amendement hier
après-midi qui proposait justement que
quand par l'incurie administrative de
nos préfectures je reprends vos termes
on on avait un titre de séjours qui
n'était pas délivré à temps que ça
conduisait à des ruptures des droits on
puisse avoir une présomption de
continuité des droits donc c'est très
bien si on arrive à avancer làdessus sur
les autorisation de travail mais
vraiment il faudrait qu'on puisse le
faire pour l'ensemble des droits parce
qu'il y a des gens qui se voient refuser
leur titre de séjour au moment d'un
renouvellement et qui se retrouvent
effectivement à perdre leur logement
social à perdre leur formation
professionnelle à perdre des droits
sociaux pour cette raison donc je
j'entends l'ouverture que vous faites
sur ce point et je vous reproposerai des
amendements en séance pour la continuité
des droits d'une manière générale parce
que véritablement je pense que là-dessus
si on veut parler d'intégration on doit
pouvoir avancer c'est la
PR alors madame je pardon vous voulez C
ou l'prèsc oui merci monsieur le
Président si il y a une préférence en
effet il faut déjà travailler avec les
étrangers en situation régulière qui
vivent dans notre pays qui peuvent se
trouver sans emploi c'est à notre avis
dans cette direction qu'il faut aller je
rappelle que dans notre pays nous avons
presque 6 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi dont 3 millions en catégorie A
qui sont donc employables c'est là qu'il
faut aller chercher pour combler les
besoins dans les métiers et les régions
en
tensionsieur monsieur tacher par rapport
au au propos de Monsieur le Ministre sur
le fait que la d'abord le le le titre
Val l'autorisation de travail c'est
notre amendement 1645 qui est identique
avec Madame la rapporteur après
l'article 4 bis et on a un autre
amendement le 1646 identique également
je crois avec Madame buffet et Madame
pochon pour que les cartes de les pardon
les autorisations de travail qui soient
délivré concernent aussi les saisonniers
de sorte à ce que s'il change de travail
et bien ils maintiennent l'autorisation
de travail et qu'elle ne sort pas
retirée comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
voilà 1645 et 1646 après l'article 4 B
alors sur ces amendements que je vais
mettre au voix qui votre
pour86 qui vote contre rejeté le502 qui
vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté on arrive à l'article 4 madame
Abad le
1083 merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement a été travaillé avec
l'Association pour le droit à
l'initiative économque l'a dit
spécialiste de l'accompagnement de
l'entrepreneuriat notamment des
personnes les plus précaires qui nous
dit que 85 % des créateurs d'entreprise
accompagnées passent le cap des 3 ans et
que parmi eux 16 % des ressortissants
étrangers à créer des entreprises auprès
de laad donc la création d'entreprise
est est un est un fort levier
d'intégration tout comme l'activité
salariée donc cet amendement tout en
rétablissant l'article 4 du gouvernement
qui permet aux demandeurs d'asile
originaire de pays pour lequel le taux
de protection internationale est forte
c'est-à-dire ceux dont on sait qu'ils
auront une grande chance d'être admis à
l'asile propose pardon j'ai vraiment du
mal propose comme l'activité salarié
qu'on intègre aussi l'entrepreneuriat si
l'objectif de l'article 4 est de
permettre aux demandeurs d'asile de
s'assumer financièrement le plus vite
possible ma proposition va dans le même
sens
plus nous aurons de demandeurs d'asile
travaillant et indépendants
financièrement plus ils
s'intègreront et moins ils dépendront de
l'aide des demandeurs
d'asile qui monsieur de la porte oui
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
ici de mettre fin à non seulement une
espèce d'injustice qui est souvent vécu
par les demandeurs d'asile comme une
marque de la France d'hostilité à leur
égard puisquil n'urait pas le droit de
travailler et donc de s'engager dans un
parcours d'intégration plein et entier
mais aussi par ailleurs pour répondre à
nos collègues notamment de l'extrême
droite qui disent souvent voilà les cûts
faramineux de l'immigration pour les
finances publiques voyez si quand on
était demandeur d'asile on pouvait
travailler et bien on n'urait pas à
vivre de la solidarité nationale et cela
cela permettrait donc voilà de que
l'État puisse faire des économie mais
surtout cela favoriserait la cohésion
nationale et l'intégration de celles et
ceux qui ont fuit leur pays notamment la
guerre les violences les persécutions et
donc leur permettre aussi de s'engager
dans une reconstruction madame auonau le
733 merci monsieur le Président
effectivement par cet amendement nous
nous souhaitons permettre aux demandeurs
et demandeuses d'asile de
pouvoir travailler dès l'introduction de
leur demande auprès de
l'OFPRA le projet actuel limite ce droit
au demandeurs et demandeusees originaire
d'un pays figurant sur une liste fixée
annuellement par l'autorité
administrative ce qui pose donc une
inégalité de traitement entre les
demandeurs et demandeuses alors qu'il
n'y a aucune raison de de les distinguer
pour nous il s'agit de répondre au
principe de dignité de la personne
consacré par une jurisprudence
constitutionnelle et il nous appartient
donc de permettre à à ces demandeurs et
demandeuses d'accéder euh au travail je
rappelle que actuellement compris pour
celles et ceux qui euh peuvent ou
pourraient avoir la location qui est
accordé à cette demandeur et
demandeusees elle est de 14 € par jour
et tout le monde peut je pense se rendre
compte que avec de tels revenus il est
impossible de pouvoir vivre dignement et
c'est aussi les raisons pour
lesquellesci que un certain nombre de
ces demandeurs et demandeuses d'asile se
retrouvent à la rue dans des conditions
indignes voilà pourquoi il faut leur
permettre de travailler dès le premier
jour merci alors le suivant c'est le
vôtre madame la rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président donc en fait cet
amendement il vient rétablir l'article 4
tel que présenté par par le
gouvernement et d'ailleurs je je je me
réjouis he que cet
amendement soit apporté par de de
nombreux collègues en l'état du droit
actuellement le demandeur d'asile peut
accéder au marché du travail au bout de
6 mois si l'OFPRA n'a pas statué dans ce
délai là il y a de nombreux rapports qui
ont été rendus sur le sur le sujet je
pense notamment à celui de 2020 de nos
collègues de la commission des finances
Stella Dupont et Jean-Noël Barron
barreot excusez-moi Barron relatif à
l'intégration professionnelle des
demandeurs d'asile et des
réfugiés ce que je vous propose
avec cet amendement c'est de donc
rétablir le dispositif initial et qui
permettrait donc dès l'introduction de
la demande d'asile de pouvoir accéder au
marché du travail et la condition c'est
que le demandeur d'asile doit être
originaire d'un pays pour lequel le taux
de protection internationale accordé en
France est supérieur à un seuil qui
serait fixé par décret et figurant sur
une liste qui serait fixé annuellement
par l'autorité administrative il y a
deux objectifs qui sont poursuivis avec
le rétablissement de cet article c'est à
la fois accélérer le parcours
d'intégration des étrangers donc il est
hautement probable qu'ils auront
vocation à rester sur notre territoire
et par ailleurs lutter contre l'emploi
illégal des étrangers s'agissant du taux
de protection minimal retenu j'imagine
que le le ministre voudra s'exprimer sur
ce point je vous que aussi que la
rédaction va aussi ouvrir la possibilité
de suivre cette formation on en a parlé
d'ors et déjà linguistique et
professionnel à ces mêmes demandeurs
d'asile c'est donc un progrès
extrêmement important c'est un un
article
d'équilibre ce qui veut donc dire que je
seraai
défavorable aux autres amendements qui
touche à cet article afin de
pouvoir conserver l'équilibre tel que
proposé je vous
remercie alors madame giverernet
oui merci monsieur le Président la
suppression par le Sénat de cet article
4 nuit à l'équilibre en restreignant
l'accès des travailleurs étrangers au
marché du travail français alors que les
demandes sont fortes dans les métiers d'
intention cet article 4 instaurit un
dispositif d'accès au marché du travail
sans délai pour les demandurs d'asile
dont il est fortement probable au regard
de leur nationalité qu'ils obtiendront
une protection internationale en France
le groupe connaissance de la commission
des affaires étrangères teint à rétablir
cet article avec la présente mesure
seuls les demandeurs d'asile
ressortissant de pays dont le taux de
protection excède un seuil élevé
pourront accéder sans délai au marché du
travail c'est pourquoi à travers cet
amendement nous souhaitons réintroduire
cette version de l'article 4 je vous
remercie j'ai également déposé un
amendement de rétablissement d'article 4
peut-être vous dire pourquoi on cherche
à faire travailler dès dès le départ dès
le dépôt de la demande les personnes qui
seront par leur nationalité qui ont le
plus grande chance d'être protégé
d'abord parce qu'on a inversé le
processus d'examen des demandes d'asile
avant 2019 les personnes qui étaient
prioritairement examiné à l'asile
étaient les personnes qui avaient le
plus de chance d'être protégé donc si on
doit donner concrètement quelles sont
ces nationalités ce sont les Syriens ou
les afghan mais ce qui voulait dire que
on conservait le plus longtemps possible
celle qui avait le moins de chance
d'être éligible ce qui alimentait une
trappe à l'irrégularité puisque des
personnes qui albanaises notamment
Georgiennes avaient très peu de chance
d'AV recevoir une protection rester 6 7
8 mois avant de voir leur demande
examiner en 2019 le ministère de
l'Intérieur a inversé cette démarche il
répond d'abord aux nationalités qui ont
le moins de chance d'être protégé de
sorte à ce que si elles ne sont pas
protégées elles sont ensuite alors
reconduites si elles ne sollicitent pas
de nouveaux titres en revanche ça veut
dire que les personnes qui sont sérien
ou afghan se trouvent dans la situation
de celle qui étit avant Georgienne ou
albanaise c'est-à-dire 6 7 8 mois sur le
territoire a priori avec de grandes
chances d'être protégé mais sans pouvoir
travailler de sorte que on condamne ces
personnes a bénéficié de l'ADA ce qui
est à la fois une hérésie économique et
puis ce qui est une difficulté
d'intégration puisque ça veut dire que
pendant 6 mois on conserve sur le
territoire des personnes qui ont
vocation à rester mais qui ne peuvent
pas y travailler et c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'article 4 proposé
initialement par le gouvernement est
tout à fait
justifié le 640 Monsieur nelen Merci
monsieur le Président cet amendement qui
est porté par l'intégralité de notre
groupe il a une vision simple en réalité
la la liste des personnes et des
demandeurs d'asile qui seraient
concernés et et fixé elle peut être être
évolutive et quand on accueille
quelqu'un et ben on trouve simplement
que c'est plutôt justifié qu'il commence
à travailler tout de suite déjà pour de
manière très pragmatique et ça a été dit
par de nombreux de nombreux groupes
aujourd'hui quand un demandeur d'asile
est en France il a la DA il il est il
est et il habite dans dans des locaux
qui ne sont pas forcément adaptés et ben
nous on préfère que on puisse le laisser
travailler tout de suite qu'il puisse
créer aussi de la valeur qu'il puisse
payer des impôts potentiellement et donc
qu'il ne soit plus dépendant aussi de la
solidarité nationale donc en réalité
c'est quelque chose de très pragmatique
au lieu d'attendre 6 mois on sait que
dans tous les cas il pourra le faire
donc autant le faire autant le faire
tout de
suite Madame
Dupont oui merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement visa rétablir
effectivement l'article initial du
gouvernement et comme Madame la
rapporteur vient de l'évoquer c'est un
amendement qui auquel je tiens
particulièrement en tant que rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances
puisque ça fait de nombreuses années que
je travaille sur ce sujet du travail des
demandeurs d'asile et et donc de leur
intégration notamment avec Jean-Noël
Barot et c'est vrai que nos rapports ne
sont pas que pour caler les armoires
quelque sorte pas qu'à caler les
armoires mais à éclairer nos débats et
nos propositions à faire évoluer la loi
et en l'occurrence euh faciliter
accélérer le travail de tous les
demandeurs d'asile au-delà des plus
protégés comme on le propose aujourd'hui
me semble avoir du sens et mériterait
qu'on continue d'avancer sur ce sujet
monsieur Mandon
oui monsieur le Président merci euh
effectivement notre groupe est très
attaché au concept à l'idée
d'intégration et ici il est important de
se caler sur une approche équilibrée et
donc notre groupe considère qu'il
convient de de rétablir l'article tel
qu'il était initialement présenté donc
voilà nous nous avons présenté et rédigé
cet article en l'état madame
gnou oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président il s'agit ici pour le groupe
ence de rétablir l'article dans sa
initiale qui qui était dans la dans la
version du
gouvernement l'objet de cet article
président de la commission des lois a
rappelé que il y a quelques années avec
la loi colon nous avions inversé les
instructions de demande de droit d'asile
pour faire en sorte que ceux qui ne
relèvent pas du droit d'avisile puissent
être éloignés du territoire
national dans le même sens
puisque maintenant on a obtenu en fait
des dél raccourcis il nous semble
extrêmement important an que ceux qui
relèvent qui risquent de relever le plus
de la protection internationale et donc
qui vont être éligibles à l'asile
puissent rentrer de façon accélérée sur
le marché du travail de façon à pouvoir
s'intégrer dans notre pays le plus vite
possible et ne pas vivre des a mais bien
vivre du
travail M la rapporteur je présume un
avis favorable mais oui vous présumez
bien monsieur le Président alors j'ai
quelques
inscrits oui monsieur pardon déc pas
alors oui peut-être une précision madame
la rapporteur vous êtes favorable aux
amendements identiques mais défavorable
au aux trois premiers amendements pour
les orateurs monsieur gilet
oui chers collègues vous voudriez donc
permettre avec cet article au demandeurs
d'asile de travailler sans conditions en
méprisant les 5 millions de Français
sans emploi mais vous encouragez avec
cette mesure le dévoiement du droit
d'asile car dans tous nos pays nous
assistons à un dévoiement du droit
d'asile par les trafiquants par des
réseaux ou des personnes venant de pays
qui sont qui ne sont pas pardon en
guerre ces paroles ce que je viens de
vous dire là ce ne sont pas les paroles
de Johan Gil ce ne sont pas les paroles
de Marine Le Pen c'est Emmanuel Macron
lui-même qu'il disait le 10 novembre
2020 le dévoiement du droit d'asile il
existe vous encouragez également avec
cette mesure une immigration massive
vous encouragez également l'irrégularité
et Infiné la régularité ation massive
que vous êtes nombreux ici à appeler de
vos vœux je m'explique parce que un
demandeur d'asile arrive il entre donc
illégalement sur le territoire national
il peut donc travailler avec ce
dispositif il est ensuite déboutté dans
sa demande du droit d'asile une cttf lui
est délivrée cette otf ne sera jamais
exécuté tant le ministre de l'Intérieur
est incapable de les faire exécuter il
se retrouve donc en situation
irrégulière mais en même temps il
continue de travailler puisqu'il a avvez
commencé à travailler en tant que
demandeur d'asile et une finé grâce à
aux mesures que vous nous présentez et
notamment à l'article 4 bis dont on
parlera bien tout à l'heure il sera
régularisé voilà tout à fait le la
vision que vous avez et bien de de
l'immigration et la la votre volonté qui
est réaffirmée ici de vouloir accentuer
l'immigration et de faire subir au
français cette immigration massive dont
ils ne veulent plus alors ça fait
beaucoup d'erreurs pour un seul et même
propos mais je laisserai le ministre de
l'intérieur répondre et rectifier ces
nombreuses inexactitudes monsieurilet
madame
jeunevard merci monsieur le Président
nous nous sommes absolument opposés au
principe de régulariser un demandeur
d'asile enfin de permettre à un
demandeur d'asile d'accéder au
travail d'accéder au travail avant même
que sa situation n'est été examinée et
qu'il n'it reçu une réponse en cas de
réponse positive évidemment il accède à
une autorisation au séjour il a le droit
à tous ce qui accompagnent cette
autorisation mais tant que celle-ci n'a
pas été délivrée nous sommes absolument
opposés à la régul à la à la délivrance
d'un d'un d'un d'un droit au travail je
pense que c'est ouvrir la voie à tous
les trafics qui se fonderont sur cette
possibilité il faut toujours se mettre
du point de vue de l'utilisation
frauduleuse qui peut être faite des
autorisations que nous
délivrons monsieur de la porte
oui merci le la le rétablissement que
vous proposez finalement c'est une
prétendue générosité mais c'est de
nouveau une forme d'arbitraire parce que
ce que dit la rédaction c'est peut-être
autorisé c'est donc une faculté de
l'administration et c'est non pas une
autorisation de plein droit en fonction
des des nationalités permettez-moi
également de faire un point sur la
question des pays sûrs aujourd'hui dans
la liste des pays surûs et bien
finalement si on restreint à ça on ne
sait pas exactement ce que pourrait être
ces pays qui permettrait l'accès alors
peut-être Syrie éitrée Afghanistan
certes mais que direz-vous aux Guinéens
qui fu l'excision que direz-vous
finalement à toutes celles et ceux qui
seraient hors de ce droit d'accès et
donc finalement aujourd'hui le texte
risque reste extrêmement flou quant aux
critères de détermination des pays non
sûrs et par ailleurs ça ne prend pas en
compte les situations individuelles et
finalement les personnes qui aujourd'hui
font une demande d'asile et qui sont
pour la plupart dans des situations de
précarité je finirai par évoquer juste
une situation il y a à wistriam des
soudanis la moitié d'entre eux ont fait
une demande d'asile il y A à C des
Afghans c'est à peu près pareil et aucun
d'entre eux ou très peu ont laada donc
ça veut dire aujourd'hui qu'il y a aussi
une problématique d'accès au droit plus
largement pour les demandeurs d'asile ne
serait-ce que pour avoir le minimum
vital monsieur de la porte il y a au
moins trois choses qui sont qui sont
inexactes là je peux pas tout laisser
passer non plus sur d'abord c'est c'est
un droit ensuite ce n'est pas une liste
des pays sûrs c'est une liste établie
par rapport au degré de protection des
nationalités qui peut évoluer chaque
année ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on
protège quasiment à 93 % les les Afghans
parce que c'est un pays en guerre et
parce que par ailleurs il y a une
occupation du pouvoir par les talibans
et que c cette le évolue donc elle est
beaucoup plus évolutive et beaucoup
beaucoup plus rapidement que la liste
des pays sûs et par ailleurs pour les
les Guinéens qui subiraient enfin les
guinéennes plus précisément qui
subiraient une excision il y a une
protectiontion qui est déjà octroyé au
titre de la loi Colom des articles que
nous avons voté il y a déjà un petit
moment moi je vous répondais précisément
par rapport à l'article
4 monsieur Boyard oui merci monsieur le
Président alors l'article que vous
mentionnez de la loi colon est
totalement inopérant je pense que c'est
important de le dire j'entends depuis le
début de de cette journée beaucoup de
principes qui sont énoncés de la part de
la droite et de l'extrême droite que
j'ai maintenant du mal à distinguer et
j'aimerais rappeler quelque chose les
principes que vous exposez ils ne
s'appliqueront pas à vous vous ça
changera rien à votre vie que cette loi
a été votée ou pas on parle de personnes
qui elles n'ont pas la chance de pouvoir
décider de leur sort et on parle de vie
humaine et j'ai l'impression que parfois
vous avez tendance à l'oublier je je
vois aussi que vos principes sont fondés
sur un principe assez simple c'est
l'anti-immigration sur tous les sujets
il y a une suspicion il y a un mépris
aussi et un mépris qui est encore plus
plus caractérisé dès lors qu'il s'agit
d'immigration africaine ou d'immigration
du Moyen-Orient sauf que dès lors qu'on
a des principes il faut les confronter à
la réalité et en l'espèce dans cette
article quelle est la réalité on parle
de personnes qui vivent avec 14 € par
jour avec Lada pendant 8 mois c'est pas
un inconfort c'est dangereux de vivre
avec 14 € par jour pendant 8 mois
comment est-ce que vous payez le loyer
comment est-ce que vous pouvez vous
nourrir comment est-ce que vous pouvez
vous soigner mais tout ça c'est des
difficultés concrètes mais ça bon bah
écoutez apparemment ça rentre pas dans
vos principes alors j'aimerais vous
rappeler un autre principe qui est un
principe de liberté d'égalité et de
fraternité un principe qui est au milieu
de la cour d'honneur de l'Assemblée
nationale et il y a une boule au milieu
qui est censé symboliser l'universalité
de ces droits dè lors pourquoi est-ce
que vous ne voulez pas les réserver à
tous moi je je je vois la liste qui est
proposée mais pourquoi est-ce que une
autre personne qui ne fait pas partie de
cette liste elle devrait vivre avec 14 €
par jour alors que si jamais vous vous
les laissez travailler c'est même pas
une question d'intégration c'est juste
une question de pouvoir les laisser
vivre pouvoir les laisser survivre parce
que vous pouvez dire ce que vous voulez
à gauche à droite au centre ce n'est
possible pour aucune française et aucun
Français de voir des personnes vivrent
dans la détresse et dans la misère dans
la rue parce que vous les faites vivre
avec 14 € par jour dès lors l'amendement
de Madame auono me paraît être le plus
juste et le plus efficace Madame Dupont
oui merci monsieur le Président euh je
je je m'interroge toujours lorsque
j'entends parler de dévoiement de
l'asile à chaque fois que l'on parle des
des demandeurs d'asile moi il me semble
que que notre problème en matière
d'asile relève en définitive de d'un
manque de voie de migration régulière
parce que lorsque certains déposent une
demande d'asile alors que c'est pas
forcément leur objet premier moi ça me
questionne et quand j'ouvre le dossier
je me rends compte que les voies de
migration régulière de migration
économiqu régulièr sont extrêmement
resserré et en fait génèent cette
encombrement de l'asile donc l'origine
de notre problème ce n'est pas tant
l'asile que le manque de voie régulière
de migration et il me semble que c'est
un dévoiement de l'immigration
économique que l'on connaît plutôt que
l'inverse et il me semble toujours utile
de le rappeler pour ne pas se tromper et
amener justement l'extrême droite en
particulier à pointer en permanence
l'asile et les réfugiés et les étrangers
dans notre pays et enfin Madame Rousseau
Monsieur Merci monur président en fait
la question au cœur de cette loi c'est
de
donner de ne donner des droits qu'aux
personnes qui travaillent et qui
travaill dans les métiers en tension et
en fait l'idée derrière cette loi est
double c'est un que les salariés qui
acceptent des conditions de travail
difficiles bah finalement puissent avoir
accès à une forme de régularisation mais
pas les autres et que les salariés qui
servent le PIB français puissent aussi
avoir accès à des droits mais en fait là
les amendements qui sont proposés
aujourd'hui augmentent la possibilité
d'avoir accès à un emploi et ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que ça sert
deux choses et ça sert à l'intégration
de ces personnes et non pas à
l'assimilation comme on l'a entendu hier
mais bien à l'intégration de ces
personnes à l'intérieur de notre pays
mais ça permet aussi de lutter contre
des filières d'employeurs peu scrupuleux
ou de logeurs peu scrupuleux puisque
tant que ces personnes n'ont pas accès
au travail et bien elles sont entre les
mains de personnes qui sont des vendeurs
de sommeil des logeurs de sommeil et des
loyeurs peu scrupuleux qui les font
travailler 8h sur des marteau piqueurs
comme l'expliquait madame fossillon tout
à l'heure donc en fait il y a absolument
besoin d'ouvrir des droits à ces
personnes pour qu'elles rentent dans une
capacité à s'intégrer dans le pays il
n'y a pas d'ouverture d'une espèce
d'immigration qui menacerait les emplois
français il y a au contraire le respect
de droits humains essentiels que nous
devons aux personnes qui arrivent sur
notre pays monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
alors moi aussi je je veux évidemment
apporter tout mon soutien au
rétablissement de l'article 4 voulu par
le par le gouvernement et essayer
deexliciter en en répondant au questions
aux observations peut-être dire au début
au représentant du rassemblement
national que les demandeurs d'asile ne
sont pas des personnes irrégulières le
d'asile il demande l'asile alors
évidemment quand on lui refuse l'asile
non non mais non il est pas rentré
irrégulièrement puisque la Déclaration
des Droits dehomme et du citoyens et le
préembule de 46 monsieur à moin que vous
soyez contre la D à moins que vous soyez
contre la déclaration des droit de
l'homme et citoyens ce ce qui ce qui ce
qui est une possibilité ce qui est une
possibilité mais alors là voilà vous
avez de siècle et demi de retard parce
qu'il fait être là en 1789 sinon
monsieur Loman pourrait peut-être vous
rappeler comment ça s'est passé mais sin
je dois on doit avir la bande
enregistrer quelque part de vous
inquiétez pas non il est il est prévu
très explicitement dans notre droit et
pas au sein de la cdH dans notre droit
profond dans la déclaration de citoyens
dans le préambule de 46 que ceux qui
veulent demander l'asile doivent le
faire sur le territoire de la de la
République donc quand vous demandez
l'asile quand quelqu'un se présente à
nos frontières et dit je viens pour
demander l'asile il n'est pas irrégulier
le droit français est notre droit au
sens du bloc de constitutionnalité le
reconnaît comme comme régulier jusqu'au
jour où on lui dit non jusqu'au jour où
on lui dit non mais tant qu'il est
demandile irrégulier il a la protection
de la nation c'est pour ça que nous lui
versons une prestation sociale qui
s'appelle là non non vous avez dit qu'il
est rentré irrégulièrement non non non
non quand il vient demander l'asile il
n'est pas rentré irrégulièrement non
vous verrez d'ailleurs qu'il y a des
dispos non vous verrez qu'il y a des
vous verrez qu'ilur des des amendements
adoptés d'ailleurs au
Sénat et d'autres que j'ai déposé qui
prévoi justement de lutter contre les
détournements du droit d'asile notamment
des personnes qui arriveraient
irrégulièrement qui ne demanderaient pas
l'asile et lorsqu'ils sont arrêtés par
la police disent mais moi je viens pour
demander l'asile là je peux entendre
qu'il s'agit de personnes qui essayent
de contourner le droit d'asile et vous
verrez d'ailleurs qu'on a une
disposition pour dire que le asil doit
être évidemment étudié mais pas en leur
laissant la liberté sur le sol national
donc là on est sur ce sujetl mais
surtout le reste quand quelqu'un vient
sur le territoire national il a un
certain nombre de jours de temps pour
demander l'asile il n'est pas considéré
comme irrégulier monsieur le député
c'est un point très important parce que
sinon on comprend pas ce que c'est que
la demande d'asile en France et
d'ailleurs c'est le cas de tous les pays
au monde voilà de tous les pays au monde
qui ont un minimum de de vie
démocratique et qui accepte l'asile je
rappelle d'ailleurs monsieur monsieur le
député que la Cour suprême britannique
on ne parle pas assez de cet arrêt de la
Cour suprême britannique parce qu'on a
entendu parler
l'envie votre soutien du brexit vous
allez voir on va reprendre la la
maîtrise de l'immigration je voudrais
pas vous faire l'aveu pour dire qu' il y
a jamais eu autant d'immigrés clandestin
en Grande-Bretagne depuis qu'ils ont
quitté l'Europe que comandbien même il
quitterait la CEDH dit la Cour suprême
britannique alors qu'ils ont traité ils
ont quitté les traités européens il ne
pourrait pas mettre en place la demande
d'asile aux frontières exclusiv comme il
est proposé avec le Rwanda d'ailleurs
aucun pays ne l'a fait ni même le
Danemark pour l'instant on en parle
personne ne le fait et c'est pas une
question de traité européen c'est pas
une question de CEDH c'est une question
de démocratie après la question qui se
pose et c'est ce qu'essaie de faire le
titre 3 4 et 5 qui sont le cœur de ce
projet de loi monsieur le président de
la commission des lois c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quand on dit non à quelqu'un
et là il est effectivement irrégulier ça
c'est tout à fait vrai alors nous
n'avons pas le même système que les
Allemands système allemand mis en place
par la CDU et Madame Merkel je vis aussi
le rappeler hein c'est quoi c'est pour
des demandeurs d'asile qu'on a refusé
qu'on a refusé à qui on a dit non on ne
les expulse pas et on leur donne ce
qu'on appelle des tolérances les les
fameux Dung et cette tolérance elle
permet aux gens de ne pas être
régularisés mais de pouvoir travailler
c'est pas le système du tout qu'on
propose là le système qu'on propose ici
d'abord c'est un système qui consiste à
appliquer une directive européenne qui
avait été imaginée en 2008 puis en 2013
je remarquer Mame jeunevar qu'elle est
peut-être très opposée à cet article là
mais que par de fois le Parlement
européen gouverné par le P PPE a poussé
cette directive à élaborer et la fait
adopter c'est c'est un problème c'est
c'est quand même un problème parce que
là c'est quand même le PPE qui qui l'a
souhaité c'est pas en soit scandaleux
pourquoi parce
que mesdames messieurs les députés les
demandeurs d'asile quand ils arrivent en
France ils ont une autorisation
éventuelle de travail au bout de 6 mois
comme dans tous les pays de l'Union
européenne et cette autorisation de
travail dans tous les pays européenes ne
vaut pas dans de suite le recours qu'il
ferait éventuellement au juges si on
leur disait non à leur asile pour faire
valoir de leur vie privée et familiale
donc il n'y a pas de conditionnement à
ce droit que donne l'Union européenne
pour avoir un titre de séjour ensuite
s'il était donné dans un recours
postérieur à sa demande d'asile donc
c'est pas parce qu'on travaille qu'on a
ensuite le droit de s'en prévaloir
devant le tribunal pour être régularisé
ça c'est c'est faux et les tribunaux
désormais le disent puisque ça fait
depuis 2018 que ce droit existe bon le
deuxième sujet c'est qu'en effet pour
ceux qui ne travaillent pas qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont et là je dois avouer que les
arguments de Monsieur Boyard et Madame
Rousseau sont justes et ces arguments
qui devraient tous nous
toucher ne parodiez pas Madame rousse
parce que c'est pas très drôle ce qu'on
fait en ce moment là on essaie de donner
des droits au demandeur d'asile qui
travail aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe et ben il touche
laada et laada c'est effectivement moins
de 300 € par mois et donc c'est c'est
assez compliqué quand même de dire des
gens qui pourraient travailler sont
obligés de vivre avec 300 € par mois et
de rentrer du coup dans le logement
d'hébergement d'urgence que vous décriez
par ailleurs parce qu'il ne serait pas
tenu et de leur refuser le travail c'est
des cas très très concret lorsque nous
évacuons les Afghans qui nous ont aidé
pendant des années alors qu'ils ont
combattu les talibans il y avait des
interprètes dont on a bien besoin sur le
S national il y avait des médecins il y
avait des avocats quelle quelle
situation ridicule que de les accueillir
sur le sol national et de pas leur
permettre de travailler et d'apporter à
la France ce qu'ils doivent apporter
alors qu'on sait qu'on va leur donner
l'asile euh quelques mois après alors là
où je ne suis pas d'accord notamment
avec ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure sur
avec Monsieur de la porte sur le le le
le choix des des personnes c'est que
pour la première fois un gouvernement ne
vient pas vous voir y compris d'ailleurs
peut-être éce une partie des erreurs
précédentes en disant on va changer la
liste des pays sûrs d'abord on sait tous
que c'est un peu ridicule parce que
c'est l'OFPRA qui le décide à la fin et
c'est pas et c'est pas et c'est pas mal
que soit lofpra et deuxièmement cette
liste des pays sû a finalement peu
d'intérêt puisque désormais il y a de
telles jurisprudences notamment sur la
question de l'orientation sexuelle ou
sur la question de droit religieux que
que c'est vraiment ce payer de mot en
revanche le gouvernement a basé son
sujet sur la rapidité des procédures
puisque c'est à la CNDA de juger mais
également sur le taux de protection
alors on peut toujours discuter ce de
protection aujourd'hui je rappelle qu'il
est réglementaire ce que je disais tout
à l'heure à Monsieur tacher notre bar à
nous àcolier du sopt c'est 50 %. on peut
toujours discuter on peut toujours
discuter mais mais ce taux de protection
il englobe une partie de gens dont on
est à peu près certain qu'on le donnera
l'asile à la fin et ne joue pas le jeu
et ne joue pas le jeu de ceux qui
détournent le droit d'asile pour venir
dans notre pays par exemple les
Sénégalais les Ivoiriens les Marocains
il y a aucune raison qui demande l'asile
sur le sol national à quelques
exceptions près mais qui ne mérite pas
qui ne mérite pas me semble-t-il le même
taux de protection que ont par exemple
les femmes afghanes en effet qui
arrivent sur le sol national donc c'est
ce taux de protection qui n'a rien à
voir avec la liste des pays sûs c'est
pas notre critère me semble-t-il est
assez est assez cohérent est assez
démocratique je voudrais dire également
sur la question tout à l'heure qui a été
posé de de vous-même monsieur de la
porte en tout cas de l'affirmation de
dire ah bah oui mais on leur donne pas
l'autorisation de séjour l'autorisation
de travail pardon mais c'est pas par
rapport à la personne qu'on donne pas
l'autorisation de travail et j'ai
moi-même faire une ouverture tout à
l'heure auprès de Monsieur taqué pour
dire on est prêt à travailler sur ce
lien entre tacher pardon entre
l'autorisation de travail de séjour
c'est la vérification que l'entreprise
elle fonctionne bien on donne pas une
autorisation de travail à quelqu'un si
la boîte est en redressement fiscal est
en redressement social donc
l'autorisation de de travail que l'on
donne ne relève pas du la de la personne
qui demande à travailler mais VI de
l'entreprise qui va pas embaucher des
personnes étrangères dans des situations
parfois de vulnérabilité si respecte pas
déjà le droit du travail pour ces
salariés qui ne connaissent pas cette
vulnérabilité chacun en conviendra donc
je pense que ce propos n'était pas
n'était pas au rendez-vous alors
évidemment après la question c'est de
qui on parle parce que là c'est comme
pour les métiers entention on parle de
quelques milliers de personnes je pense
pas que ça vaille toutes les unes de
journaux qu'on a eu mais bon pourquoi
pas et là pareil pour les demandasile ça
concerne quoi ça concerne d'après nous
20 % 20 % de tous les demandeurs d'asile
donc alors je fais un petit calcul parce
que je pense qu'il faut quand même leur
dire ici nous avons entre 130000 et
150000 demandes d'asile on a augmenté de
20 % grosso modo depuis 5 ans je
constate d'ailleurs personne ne le dit
jamais que l'Allemagne était à 1550000
demandes d'asile il y a 3 ans ils sont à
270000 aujourd'hui la France est le pays
où la progression demande d'asile est le
moins important de toute l'Union
européenne et c'est le pays qui donne le
moins l'asile de toute l'Union
européenne non mais
je c'est un constat que je voudrais dire
ici quand j'entends un certain nombre de
sujets sur à l'asile c'est un
détournement procédure absolu ce n'est
pas vrai nous avons le pays où on a le
moins progressé en d'asile alors qu'on a
plus de 60 % d'asile en Union Européenne
et on voit l'Allemagne qui a doublé sa
demande d'asile en 3 ans alors que nous
l'avons augmenté de 10 % par lesffit des
difficultés du monde et par ailleurs par
ailleurs l'OFPRA puis la CNDA et c'est
pas simplement les critères de c'est pas
simplement les critères législatifs
puisque les juges de la CNDA sont
indépendants du pouvoir politique vous
le savez bien et par ailleurs appliquent
également les critères de la CEDH nous
nous sommes le pays qui est le le moins
sans doute attentif aux critères des
autres pays européens sur l'asile donc
franchement l'argument de dire la France
c'est celui qui donne le plus dro
d'asile est totalement faux la question
qui se pose c'est que nous sommes un
pays comme d'autres qui avons du mal à
renvoyer les personnes à qui on dit non
et c'est l'objet du titre 3 du titre 4
du titre 5 mais il faut pas confondre
les débats la difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est donc parler de 20 % de personnes
sur 130000 c'est ça dont on parle on
parle de 20 % de personnes sur 130000
qui sont à peu près certains d'avoir
l'asile dans notre pays donc franchement
cet article 4 ne mérite sans doute pas
tout ce qui a été évoqué ici il est un
très bon article qui permet de lutter
contre des personnes qui en effet
parfois sont sous la main des passeurs
sont sous la main des trafics sont sous
la main des marchands de sommeil ça a
été très clairement dit permet aux gens
de vivre de fr du fruit de leur travail
et encore une fois cette c'est tout à
fait vrai ce qu'a dit Monsieur de la
porte et limite la portée sans doute de
cet article mais on l'assume le préfet
peut s'opposer à cette demande de
travail si on considère qu'effectivement
c'est manifestement totalement détourné
c'est pas c'est pas un demande
autorisation de travail de plein droit
donc encore une fois euh c'est conforme
aux directives européennes porté par
l'hémicycle droit de du Parlement
européen c'est conforme à ce que font
tous les pays européens autour de nous
c'est conforme euh à à ce qu'on va faire
à la fin c'estors donner l'asile c'est
conforme à l'idée qu'on leur donne pas
un droit de régularisation si jamais par
extraordinaire on devait pas leur donner
leur donner l'asile et en effet je veux
redire une nouvelle fois que le
demandeur d'asile n'est pas un
irrégulier le demandeur d'asile est un
demandeur d'asile qui est protégé votre
pays jusqu'au jour où on lui dit non
définitivement dans ces cas-là on lui
dit repartir s'il repart pas ça devient
irrégulier mais ce n'est pas la même
chose et il faut être à mon avis un
minimum en conformité avec ce qu'on
imaginé les révolutionnaire de
1789 donc on va voter les amendements
sachant que les premiers amendements en
discussion commune de Madame Abad et
madame monsieur Vallot et Madame auonau
ont reçu des avit défavorables c'est
ceux que je mets au voix en premier lieu
att non ce sont pas les mêmes ce sont
pas les mêmes je alors je l' met
séparément l'amendement de Madame Abadie
avec avis défavorable du rapporteur qui
vote pour qui vote contre rejeté
l'amendement de monsieur Brun avis
défavorable de Madame la rapporteur qui
va
pour qui vote contre rejeté l'amendement
de Madame obono avis défavorable de la
rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté et donc là ce sont l'ensemble des
amendements identiques de la rapporteur
et suivant pour le rétablissement de
l'article 4 qui vote
pour qui vote
contre
adopté on a une discussion commune sur
les amendements après l'article 4 on
commence par Monsieur tacher pour
l'amendement
1488 euh88 ou 90 ah oui 88 ou merci
monsieur le Président B c'est toujours
la même idée hein c'est de pouvoir avoir
dans notre droit sous une forme ou sous
une autre ici il est proposé que ce soit
dès dès le dépôt de la demande d'asile
qu'un étranger devienne titulaire d'un
document provisoire lui permettant
d'exercer une activité professionnelle
une autorisation de travailler qui soit
finalement euh lié euh à la condition de
demandeur d'asile monsieur le ministre
vient de rappeler que un un un demandeur
d'asile n'était pas un travailleur
n'était pas pardon un euh un immigré en
situation irrégulière qu'il était en en
situation régulière le temps de sa
demande d'asile si en situation
régulière il doit y avoir une
autorisation de travail donc l'article 4
vient d'être rétabli pour ceux qui ont
un taux de protection élevé mais il y a
eu des arguments convaincants notamment
par collègue de la porte tout à l'heure
ou d'autres pour expliquer que bien
d'autres euh devaient aussi pouvoir se
trouver en situation
de travailler com même les pays dont ils
sont issus ont un taux de protection
moins important donc cet amendement
permettrait d'y
répondre le 1704 madame la
rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président en fait cet amendement il a
pour objet de modifier l'article
l554-1 du cza pour en fait étendre
l'accès du marché du travail au
demandeurs d'asile faisant l'objet d'une
décision de transfert en application du
règlement numéro
604-203 lorsque la décision n'a pas été
exécuté dans le délai de 6 mois à
compter de sa notification et en tout
état de cause dans un délai de 9 mois à
comptter de l'enregistrement de sa
demande en fait c la vise à mettre en
conformité notre législation avec les
dispositions de la directive
201333 qui prévoit que les États-membres
veillent à ce que les demandeurs et
accès au marché du travail dans un délai
maximal de 9 mois à compter de la date
d'introduction de la demande de
protection je vous
remercie alors l'amendement suivant
madame fossillon oui merci monsieur le
Président l'idée ici c'est en faisant
suite aux discussions que nous venons
d'avoir sur l'article précédent c'est
d'ouvrir ce ce droit au au travail des
demandeurs d'asile à tous les demandeurs
d'asile puisque même si je me satisfais
de la
réintroduction de de l'article 4 il nous
semble trop limité sur sur les personnes
et donc l'idée ici c'est de pouvoir
l'élargir ce qui nous semble assez
juste le 506 de Monsieur
Bou merci monsieur le Président dans la
droite ligne des collègues ouvrir de
plein droit le droit au travail pour les
pour les demandeurs d'asile dès le dès
le dépôt question de faciliter leur
inclusion par la suite évidment
monsieur po vous avez les deux suivants
oui merci Président vous l'avez compris
nous on est opposé au fait d'accéder au
marché du travail avant que
l'OFPRA est statué parce que sinon on
crée des situations où l'état de faê
devient plus fort que l'État de droit et
je pense que le message il est
important si on va au bout de la logique
un demandeur d'asile fait sa demande on
lui accorde l'accès au marché du travail
l'ofpr statut de cas de figure ou bien
il est accepté ou il est pas accepté
s'il est accepté pas de problème on
régul il aura senti de séjour s'il est
pas accepté vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre c'est à ce moment-là que les
problèmes se posent c'est la manière
dont on va faire exécuter le fait que
l'OFPRA lui aura pas délivré son titre
mais com on lui aura ACC comment on
l'aura admis au marché du travail
j'allais dire on se dotte des outils
pour que la situation de fait soit plus
fort que la situation de droit et c'est
ça le le problème de la défiance dans
notre pays et ça
ça avec le B qui va arriver et ça
renvoie un problème plus général trop
souvent l'État de droit s'adapte au
situation de fait et on alimente un
système dont on narrive pas à sortir
donc moi les deux amendements que je
vous propose le 164 c'est pas d'accès au
marché du travail tant que l'OF pr n'a
pas statué et le 165 est un repli pour
respecter la directive européenne dont
vient de parler notre rapporteur c'est
le délai de 9 mois je vous remercie
madame Chol le
merci monsieur le Président je vais vous
dire défendu parce que c'était un
identique avec celui que nous venons
d'adopter précédemment donc je trouve un
peu curieux qu'il apparaisse à cet
endroit là mais je suis satisfaite de
l'adoption des précédents
identiques monsieur kbrat le 730
monsieur porte pardon merci monsieur le
Président ici un amendement qui va dans
le même sens pour que l'attestation de
dépôt d'une demande d'asile vaille
autorisation de travail pour tous les
demandeurs d'asile sans aucune
discrimination parce qu'on l'a on l'a
rappelé c'est une question de droit
humain monsieur le ministre vous évoquez
beaucoup de pourcentages de chiffres
j'ai entendu parler de flux de volume on
est sur des êtres humains et sur des
droits humains et une question de digité
on ne parle pas en pourcentage donc pour
nous il faut que ces gensl puissent
travailler immédiatement ça a été
rappelé par mon collègue Boyard comment
voulez-vous qu'il vivent décemment avec
la somme qui est attribuée de 14 € par
jour c'est pas sérieux ils doivent
pouvoir travailler dès qu'il y a une
attestation de dépôt de demande d'asile
et enfin j'entends beaucoup de la part
de l' droite l'opposition entre les
Français et les étrangers sur les
slogans il y a beaucoup de chômeurs
français les autres vont leur prendre
leur travail vous n'avez réinventé vous
reprenez ce que vous aviez déjà dit en
1978 c'était les affiches de Jean-Marie
Le Pen qui disait 1 million de chômeurs
1 million d'immigrés la France et les
Français d'abord des slogans qu'on
entend aujourd'hui dans les
manifestations néonazis qui se tient
dans le pays donc vous êtes vraiment la
branche politique de ces gens-là qui
sont des raciste et qui SIME la terreur
dans le pays alors madame la rapporteur
vos avis je présume que c'est favorable
au vottre défavorable vous présumez
parfaitement monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous vouliez dire
un mot certainement oui je je je veux
dire un mot d'abord je je veux redire et
à Monsieur Poget de de qui parle-t-on
parce qu'on on va mettre vous avez bien
compris un sujet sur les taux de
protection on parle pas des demandeurs
d'asile en général si je prends
l'exemple des Afghans en
2021 en 2021 monsieur le député on est à
92 % de taux de
protection 92 % c'est qu'un afghan
notamment en l'occurrence une afghane
puisque 70 % sont des femmes
qui vient sur le sol de la République
pour demander l'asile on va lui donner
l'asile à 92 %. et là on parle de quoi
on parle de taux de protection plutôt
que de parler de durée parce que 6 mois
9 mois entre n so 10 c'est reculé pour
mieux sauter puisque je vais essayer de
répondre à votre question sur le fait le
droit vous avez pas tort sur cette
argument c'est que on pourrait
travailler peut-être sur le taux de
protection plutôt que sur la durée
l'idée c'est de pas donner cette
possibilité aux gens du Nigéria 16 % de
taux de protection il l'Albanie 15 % ni
la Géorgie 7 % ni des commor 6 % je je
suis parfaitement d'accord là ce serait
de ce serait hypocrite de la part du
gouvernement je dirais bah oui vous avez
raison on donne la possibilité de
travail alors qu'on fa demander l'asile
alors qu'on est sûr qu'on pas le
demander l'asile là c'est pas le cas on
vous propose de donner cette possibilité
de travail de pas vivre avec 300 € par
mois et pas vivre dans dans le logement
d'urgence et et de pas les soumettre
aussi à la prostitution aux difficultés
au trafic de drogue vous savez bien
comment les choses malheureusement se
passent quand vous pouvez pas faire
vivre votre famille ou dans l'illégalité
du travailleur irrégulier à des gens à
qui on donne à 92 % l'asile voilà donc
on peut toujours discuter du protection
je suis ouvert à cette discussion mais
mais ça me paraît pas un argument très
très recevable monsieur proet puisque on
vous propose pas nous en tout cas c'est
pas le cas du gouvernement la laoration
de travail pour pour tout le monde
deuxièmement votre raisonnement vaut si
on adopte pas les titres 3 4 5 qui
encore une fois sont directement
inspirés de ce qu'a fait le Sénat AC le
rapport buffet quel est le sujet
principal de l'immigration irrégulière
ou du détournement du droit d'asile en
France encore une fois c'est pas nos
jugements ils sont les plus durs
d'Europe c'est pas la maîtrise de nos
frontières à Epsilon prè on peut pas
considérer quand on regarde ce qui se
passe autour de nous qu'on soit les plus
laxistes c'est pas les réglementations
que nous imaginons comme je l'ai dit
alors que tout explose partout nous nous
arrivons à dans un monde difficile à
garder ce sujet là à peu près cohérent
c'est le fait que nous n'arrivons pas à
répondre rapidement aux gens nous
mettons à peu près 3 ans à répondre
définitivement à quelqu'un qui
vientander en France et qui a détourné
l'asile mais aussi on met parfois 3 ans
répondre oui à quelqu'un qui a le droit
à avoir l'asile donc le demandeur
d'asile arrive en France il n'est pas
irrégulier puisqu'il a lo demander sur
le SO de la République il fait une
demande la loi colon a passé de 9 mois
grosso modo à 5 mois le délai de l'ofpr
c'est une moyenne donc aujourd'hui c'est
5 mois en 5 mois on lui répond lu répond
il fait un appel là c'est à peu près 9
mois un an pour la CND 1 an et demi 1 an
et demi après on lui dit non on lui met
unqtf parce que le refus d'asile
aujourd'hui il ne vaut pas f c'est
justement ce que nous proposons dans ce
texte de loi donc on prend le qtf contre
lui il fait un recours parce qu'il est
suspensif là on est reparti pour 9. un
an puis ensuite on lui dit non et là il
fait un recours contre cette première
décision d'instance et il va en cours
d'appel administratifou au Conseil
d'État 3 ans au bout de 3 ans c'est pas
le fait qu'il ait travaillé
régulièrement qui pose problème ou
régulièrement s'il jamais été autorisé
c'est le fait qu'il se soit marié qu'il
ait fait des enfants et qu' sa privé
familiale est en France et là le juge
nous dit vous aviez raison de lui dire
non mais entretemps ben cher ami il est
là et entre-temps le pays d'origine nous
dit mais on va pas attendez vous allez
pas le reprendre c'est 3 ans 4 ans qu'il
est chez vous pour le peu qu'il soit
radicalisé les pays nous disent mais
attendez chez nous il était pas
radicalisé chez vous ilétait vous nous
renvoyer c'est sympa pour qui fait des
actes de délinquence on va pouvoir
démontrer alors c'est pas la loi
actuelle qu'on peut pas le renvoyer nous
proposons nous faut voir le projet de
loi globalement on dit oui à ceux dont
on est à peu près certains qui va donner
l'asile qui peuvent travailler de
manière anticipée sous autorisation du
préfet c'est pas l'yperlaxisme non plus
à tous les autres ont dit toute façon on
va juger maintenant désormais votre
demande d'asile la Cour nationale
d'asile et le qtf en moins de 9 mois
parce que ce qu'on propose dans
l'article 3 45 c'est non seulement on
améliore encore les d de l'OFPRA on on
ferme on enferme la CNDA dans une
décision plus rapide et par ailleurs le
le refus la CND va au qtf et on divise
des recours de 12 à 3 peut-être à deux
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois ce qui fait que la loi voter en
moins d'un an quelqu'un a une réponse
sur l'asile que ce soit que ce soit non
donc vous vous ne pouvez pas euh faire
comme s'il n'y avait pas l'article 3
titre 3 45 donc vraiment ce que je veux
dire ici c'est que c'est un texte celui
de d'article 4 qui permet aux gens à qui
on est à peu près certain de donner
l'asile qui ne vivent pas de laada à 300
€ par mois parce que après vous allez
dire oui mais laada augmente bah oui
mais les gens sont dans le logement
d'urgence ah bah ils prennent des places
ah bah il y a des difficultés ah bah ils
sont dans des réseaux de trafiquant bah
oui quand on a 300 € par mois au boutun
moment ça se comprend bon euh ça se
justifie pas mais ça se comprend et ça
peut et c'est pour ça qu'on essaie de le
régler à tous ceux à qui on va dire non
on vous dit on donne pas cette
possibilité et on va juger très très
vite et surtout mais désormais refus
d'asile vaudraqtf ce qui nous fera
gagner un an et demi de procédure c'est
pour ça que Monsieur buff a proposé ce
sujet et que nous le poussons également
donc encore une fois battons-nous
éventuellement sur les taux de
protection aujourd'hui on dit 50 % vous
pouvez me dire c'est pas assez on peut
toujours discuter de ce sujet mais de
passer de 6 mois à 9 mois objectivement
ne me paraît pas extrêmement diriment et
cohérent parce que dans ces cas-là il
faudrait mieux que vous disiez ce député
pas du tout bon mais comme vous savez
bien que parilleurs
ce serait pas possible et raisonnable
voilà donc moi je pense vraiment que cet
article 4 vaut vaut sur ce sujet en
revanche je veux dire à Monsieur tacher
que si j'ai fait une ouverture et je
crois qu'il l'a vu sur l'autorisation de
travail de manière générale ce serait
pas très juste en effet que de permettre
par exemple aux personnes qui ressortent
ressortissant des Commores ou Georgie
alors qu'ils ont moins de 5 à 6 %
d'asile de pouvoir travailler parce
qu'ils ont dans des asile ils peuvent le
faire dans des conditions d'immigration
de travail classique voilà mais pas en
faisant une demande d'asile là là je
pense que son amendement paraît pas
raisonnable trois intervenants donc
noustion monsieur goselin oui merci
monsieur le Président oui monsieur le
ministre on entend bien vos propos
effectivement on peut pas dire le
contraire un certain nombre de délais
sont améliorés raccourcis et ça va dans
le bon sens ces situations d'incertitude
sont mauvaises pour tout le monde à tout
point de vue juridiquement humainement
parlant et et l'idée n'est pas de de
tout interdire mais on crée quand même
des situations dans un certain nombre de
cas qui sont inextricables et et et ça
veut dire que on donne un signal
finalement pour certains psychologiques
que tout est acquis par avance alors
qu'il y a parfois des décisions très
contraires alors on prend l'exemple des
Afghans 92 % c'est le taux que vous avez
cité très bien c'est la réalité il est
pas contestable mais il en reste quand
même 8 % ce qui n'est pas rien dans
d'autres situations c'est plus que ça et
on on on donne pratiquement un droit
absolu ça veut dire qu'en réalité
effectivement d'une certaine façon et je
reprends les propos de notre collègue
Poget Éric on a en réalité un état de
droit qui court après l'état de fait et
ça ça ne nous paraît pas
acceptable Monsieur
leoman Merci monsieur le Président et
bonjour à toutes et à
tous cette idée de donner la possibilité
de travailler sans discrimination aux
personnes qui sont demandeurs d'asile
c'est une idée profondément aine puisque
c'est éviter les
discriminations sur l'accès au marché du
travail en raison de la nationalité et
monsieur le ministre vous m'avez fait la
sympathie de me citer plusieurs fois sur
les principes fondamentaux de notre
République je voudrais donc les signaler
l'article 120 de la Constitution de 1793
celle de la Première République disait
que le peuple français donne asile aux
étrangers bannis de leur patrie pour la
cause de la liberté et qu'il la refuse
au tyran ce qui est une bonne chose et
l'article 4 de cette république
définissait pour la première fois la
question de la citoyenneté en disant que
en gros au bout d'un an quand on
travaillait on pouvait devenir Français
voyez-vous en défendant cette amendement
finalement nous sommes dans une
tradition profondément républicaine et
quand je dis profondément elle a
maintenant plus de de siècles donc on
est carrément dans le
thème monsieur gilet
oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues quelques rappels et quelques
vérité
premièrement l'instruction par l'OFPRA
en théorie de 6 mois est en pratique
beaucoup plus longue 8 mois 21 jours en
moyenne sur si si bah sur les données
officielles c'est le c'est le rapport de
l'ofpr j'ai pas j'ai pas inventer les
chiffres monsieur le ministre sur
l'asile il faut rappeler que l'asile et
son dévoiement et vecteur au final
d'irrégularité puis de régularisation je
reviens sur ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure vous demandez la asile vous
allez travailler puisque vous souhaitez
que les demandeurs d'asile puissent
travailler vous êtes débutés on vous
délivre une qtf vous restez sur le
territoire national en situation
irrégulière et puis infé grâce à vos
mesures vous êtes régularisé et puis il
faut le rappeler le dévoiement de
l'asile c'est aussi des conséquences
pour la sécurité des Français la
décapitation de Samuel pati par un
réfugié Chechen l'incendie de la
cathédral de Nantes puis le meurtre d'un
prêtre par un débouté randais du droit
d'asile le meurtre c'est terminé
Mons
souanais Madame Dupont merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais revenir sur cette
obsession du rassemblement national sur
ce dévoiement de l'asile et cette cette
stigmatisation permanente des demandeurs
d'asile monsieur le ministre vient de
comparer les chiffres de la demande
d'asile en France et en Allemagne et les
arguments permanents qui visent à dire
que la France serait trop généreuse
serait la plus généreuse et ce et Cera
sont contestés de fait par cette moindre
attractivité de notre pays donc il faut
arrêter de de de de surfer sur des des
idées convenues qui ne s'appuient sur
aucun élément aujourd'hui nombre
d'étrangers ne choisissent pas la France
ne choisissent plus la France et que la
manière dont on accueille ou pas le
parcours d'obstacle la stigmatisation
des étrangers dans le discours politique
en particulier de l'extrême droite
contribue à abîmer l'image et le
rayonnement de la France la diggnité
nous impose d'avoir des politiques à la
hauteur de la patrie des droits de
l'homme mais bien bien accueillir chers
collègues impacte aussi l'image de notre
pays régulariser et accélérer le travail
des
monsieur très
bien simplement pour ajouter quelques
éléments notamment tiré de l'excellent
rapport de Stella Dupont sur
l'intégration des demandeurs d'asile qui
me permett aussi de dire que aucune des
conclusions n' on été vraiment tirées
dans cette loi qui n'est qui n'a
d'intégration que que le nom autorisé à
travaill les demandeurs d'asile dès le
dépôt de la demande ça réduit la dépense
publique et ça favorise l'intégration
des réfugiés une fois qu'ils sont admis
au au statut il y a sagissant de la
formation sur les langues pour ceux qui
sont admis dans le statut de réfugié
environ 16 mois entre le moment ils ont
déposer leur demande et le moment où
effectivement ils pourront accéder à une
formation en langue et je voudrais
reprendre à mon compte les résultats
d'un certain nombre d'études qui en
Allemagne a fait la démonstration que
les étrangers ayant pu accéder à
l'emploi dès leur arrivée sur le
territoire allemand s'inscrivent
durablement dans l'emploi et s'y
maintiennent nous avons un certain
nombre de pays européens qui autorise
l'accès imédien des demandeurs d'asile
au marché du travail l'Autriche
l'Espagne le Portugal la Suède et
s'agissant du Portugal et la Suède par
exemple il n'exige pas d'autorisation
administrative spécifique voilà pourquoi
nous défendons l'accès t demandeur
d'asile je voulais réagir
s je voulais réagir monsieur le
Président au propos de Monsieur
gilet vos propos monsieur gilet qui
consiste à mettre un signe égal entre la
demande d'asile et la
décapitation sont
dégueulasse immonde
honteux et je regrette je regrette
collègu que ces propos puissent être
prononcés y compris à l'Assemblée
nationale
et il s'ajoute à cela les mensonges que
vous préférez
systématiquement sur par exemple la
durée de traitement par l'ofprid des
demandes d'asile mais cessz collègues de
parler aux instincts les plus bas vous
êtes et vos propos l'ont été
repoussants monsieur le
ministre alors
Monsieur monsieur gilet monsieur
gilet le rapport 2023 de
l'OFPRA page 68 vous pouvez c'est sur
offpra.fr n'hésitez pas je vous lis
dossier le titre c'est assez facile à
comprendre je crois les dossiers en
instant c'est les délais de traitement
le délai de traitement qui s'était
maintenu à un niveau élevé en 2021 et na
avancé çacu qu'à partir du mois de
septembre 2021 a considérablement
diminué dans l'année 2022 le délai moyen
de traitement qui avait atteint 261
jours en 2021 à atteint 159 jours alors
si on fait le calcul sachant qu' a peu
près 30 jours par mois ça fait 5,2 mois
d'ailleurs l'OFPRA vous aide à le dire
puisque c'est entre parenthèses et c'est
en gras donc vous racontez monsieur
gilet n'importe quoi et vous sourcez
n'importe quoi c'est 5 mois le délai de
l'OFPRA aujourd'hui on devrait s'en
réjouir pour avoir rapidement des
réponses et vous arrivez à dire des
choses et lorsque je vous contredit en
disant non je pense pas que ce soit 9
mois mais 5 vous dites c'est dans le
rapport de l'OFPRA vous racontez
absolument n'importe quoi donc vos thèse
vos thèse monsieur gilet appuyez-les au
moins sur un semblant de
vérité on va on va voter alors
l'amendement de Monsieur tachier le 1488
avec avis défavorable de Madame la
rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté le 1704 de Madame la rapporteur
qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté
et il rédige
l'article il fait tomber tous les autres
on va suspendre 10 minutes on reprend à
11h45 précis sur l'article 4
bis écoutez tant pis on y va alors le
1171 il n'est pas
défendu en revanche de votre madame Dias
vous pouvez le
défendre merci monsieur le Président
donc le rassembl national a bel et bien
raison ce texte vise à créer une nm
filière d'immigration alors vous avez
beau essayer de prendre tout un tas de
précautions en nous disant que ces
régularisation bah d'abord ça va être à
titre expérimental mais on sait très
bien comment ça se passe c'est toujours
pérénisé par la suite on nous dit mais
vous inquiétez pas il y a une liste de
métiers en tension mais comme je luai
dit tout à l'heure il y a un risque réel
que sous les sous la pression des
associations immigrationnistes et de
l'extrême gauche il y a un élargissement
de ces métiers entention on nous dit
vous inquiétez pas ça correspondra qu'à
certaines zones géographiques sauf que
vu les amendements on a déjà vu passer
il y a un risque que finalement toute la
France soit reconnue comme une zone
géographique tendue on nous dit oui mais
vous inquiétez pas il faut une période
de résidence 3 ans mais on sait très
bien comment ça va se passer demain ça
sera 2 ans 1 an puis 6 mois puis
finalement cette condition sera levée
donc
euh donc vous nous dites en plus que sur
les métiers par exemple le BTP qu'il y a
urgence à à régulariser vous savez moi
il y a quelques jours j'ai été invité
par la Fédération française du bâtiment
à l'échelle de la région
nouvelleaquitaine et euh les prof
professionnel de la filière nous ont dit
vous savez ce qui est très très
dramatique pour nous en ce moment ce qui
crée de l'incertitude chez nous c'est
que nous allons devoir en raison de la
crise du logement licencier 100000
personnes d'ici 2025 alors le suivant le
737 n'est pas défendu madame la
rapporteur votre avis sur l'amendement
de
suppression défavorable
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
l'amendement de monsieur le rapporteur
général c'est le le fameux
amendement alors attends parce que
j'étais en train d'envoyer un texto
rappor général ou oui il s'agit de de
l'amendement annoncé à à plusieurs
reprises concernant les améliorations
que nous souhaitions apporter au au
dispositif pardon sénatorial je ne vais
pas revenir longuement sur ce que nous
proposons à nos débats et à nos votes ce
matin je veux toutefois rappeler que
plusieurs conditions nous paraissaient
indispensabl à
aménager d'abord par rapport à la
version initiale en lieu et place de
l'automaticité générale et absolue de
toute régularisation dans les métiers en
tension nous souhtions que le préfet ait
son mot à dire mais à l'inverse du Sénat
nous soutions que le préfet ne puisse
pas disposer d'un pouvoir
discrétionnaire et raison pour laquelle
j'ai proposé et je l'ai indiqué dans mes
propos liminires il y a déjà quelques
heures que lorsque la personne
introduise sa demande de régularisation
d'abord qu'elle soit en autonomie
complète vis-à-vis de l'employeur je
rappelle les liens de subordination je
rappelle les liens parfois
d'exploitation et je veux dire à Madame
Diaz
que c'est précisément en régularisant
que l'on évite les pression au salaire
bas c'est tout à fait l'inverse de votre
argumentation celle qu'en tout cas vous
avez tenu il y a déjà quelques heures
donc réintroduction de l'autonomie de la
demande par rapport à l'employeur et
puis ensuite de faire en sorte que le
préfet à tout moment au cours de la
procédure de demande de régularisation
puisse s'y opposer pour des raisons
tenant aux menaces à l'ordre publ je
pense que nous sommes tous d'accord pour
considérer que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter de régulariser quelqu'un qui
pourrait troubler l'ordre public ou qui
aurait commis des des faits qui
provoquer des troubles à l'ordre public
de la même façon que toute forme
d'agissement contraire aux principes et
valeurs de la République nous paraîtrait
tout à fait inacceptable mes chers
collègues j'aime bien parler mais alors
dans le vide moins de façon
générale alors je veux bien un peu
d'attention on écoute le rapporteur
général monsieur rapporteur général àisy
et je veux je veux souligner que
s'agissant des principes et valeurs de
la République qui pourrait donc être un
motif de refus selon l'analyse qu'on
ferait le préfet j'ai souhaité renvoyer
à la définition qu'on donne le Sénat
lui-même à l'article 13 pour que nous
soyons bien tous d'accord sur une
définition une définition précise voilà
je ne serai pas plus long parce que nos
débats vont vont continuer mais je je
pense que nous atteignons là une
disposition conforme à la cible qui
était la
nôtre un dispositif de régularisation
resserré qui correspond à des besoins
économiques qui permettent aussi de
tirer de l'illégalité et parfois de
conditions inacceptables de maltraitance
un certain nombre de ressortissant en
situation irrégulière limité dans le
temps je le rappelle avec une résidence
régulière sur le habituel sur le
territoire français de 3 ans borné au 31
décembre 2026 et je rappelle que le
projet de loi ayant été présenté en
Conseil des ministres il y a maintenant
près de 11 mois nous proposerons
probablement de rallonger la borne mais
ce qui ne change rien à l'efficacité du
dispositif madame avaD le
sous-amendement
1744 merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement simplement pour m'assurer que
l'activité salariée qui l'apprentissage
soit bien prise en compte dans le calcul
de la durée de travail effectué dans un
métier en tension en effet il arrive
parfois de façon disparate que
l'apprentissage soit considéré comme un
contrat aidé et pas comme une activité
salariée donc juste cet amendement pour
clarifier un point qui fait l'objet
parfois d'interpréter a ation
variable le suivant
c'est Monsieur monsieur nagelen le 1743
merci monsieur le Président on a un
certain nombre d'amendements visant à à
modifier cette ou à faire évoluer cet
article 4 bis et le premier celui que je
vous présente actuellement vise à
établir la liste à l'échelon
départemental j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
d'en parler à trois reprises depuis
depuis ce matin on pense que c'est le
bon le bon échelon aujourd'hui le texte
de loi définit une zone une zone
géographique avec le préfet de région en
tête nous on pense que ça doit se faire
à l'échelon départemental avec les
acteurs du département qui entourent le
préfet sur sur ce sujet là le suivant le
1759 monsieur
Valot de la porte allez-y prenez le
micro merci monsieur le Président ce
sousamendement il vise à étendre
l'expériment a ation à toutes les
activités professionnelles salarié sans
limitation liée à la notion de métier en
tenstion parce que vous voyez on l'a
expliqué tout à l'heure mais monsieur le
ministre a fait comme s'il n'avait pas
entendu ce que j'ai dit mais je vais
peut-être le redire plus clairement
monsieur le ministre a dit les métiers
de la restauration ne sont pas des
métiers entention pas encore parce que
il y a des travailleurs en situation
irrégulière dans la restauration et que
finalement cette situation fait qu'ils
ne sont pas comptabilisés comme tel du
fait aussi de cette irrégularité et donc
il y a là une grande injustice et
permettez-moi par ailleurs de dire que
si vous commencez à géographiser ou
territorialiser non seulement vous allez
créer une énorme usine à gaz mais en
plus de cela vous allez créer des
inégalités importantes entre les
différents départements ou même entre
les différents bassins
d'emploi monsieur Nagel le
1742 c'est C cette cet amendement vise à
à revenir à ce qui était proposé au
Sénat c'est-à-dire 12 mois de travail
sur les 24 derniers mois on pense que
c'est un un minimum de demander à la
personne d'avoir travaillé minimum la
moitié de son temps sur sur les deux
dernières
années le suivant monsieur valallot le
1760 monsieur de la porte oui merci dans
la même lignée que ce que nous avons
évoqué tout à l'heure il s'agit ici de
supprimer la faculté du préfet de
s'opposer la délivrance du titre pour
les motifs énumérés à l'alinéa 3 de cet
amendement dans la version initiale il
n'y avait en effet pas d'intervention du
représentant de l'État rappelons quand
même que c'était pour nous aussi l'idée
d'un droit opposable qui était rendu
possible alors que là finalement la
capacité du représentant de l'État c'est
une restriction qui ne nous satisfait
pas tout comme par ailleurs nous
souhaitions élargir le dispositif
monsieur Mandon le
suivant merci monsieur le Président cet
article 4 bis avec l'amendement présenté
précédemment par le rapporteur bouier et
est très important pour le groupe
démocrate parce que naturellement ça va
vers une intégration pousser des
personnes en situation irrégulière c'est
évidemment
elles manifeste le leur bonne volonté
elles ont un contrat de travail régulier
on l'a rappelé et nous pensons entre
autres que c'est par le travail pas
exclusivement mais que ça passe
naturellement par le travail qu'une
bonne intégration peut s'effectuer cet
amendement de mon groupe va un peu dans
le même sens que celui de Madame
Abadi on considère qu'au-delà des seuls
travailleurs salariés il faut prendre en
compte ceux qui sont en apprentissage et
j'allais dire aussi idéalement tous les
travailleurs pendant et je me permets
une certaine ouverture au-delà mon
groupe démocrate considère que limité au
seul métier en tenstion est en réalité
malaisé à mettre effectivement en œuvre
et on souhaitera pour la séance en
particulier ouvrir plus largement alors
c'est mon amendement le 1740 ensuite bon
d'abord vous dire que naturellement ça
n'est pas la version que je juge idéale
cet amendement du du rapporteur général
c'est un amendement de compromis voilà
je tiens à le dire très clairement
puisque je l'ai pas dit tout tout à
l'heure lors de l'examen de l'article 3
ce qui montre aussi la volonté de faire
aboutir ce texte pas pour nous pas pour
les députés pas pour les parlementairire
mais pour les bénéficiaires pour ceux
qui sont concernés par les
régularisations qui méritent autre chose
que un jeu politique entre nous autour
de cette question et qui mérite d'abord
d'avoir un droit un droit qui est
aménagé puisque il reste opposable dans
certaines circonstances et il ne l'IT
plus lorsque l'étranger par son
comportement trouble à l'ordre public
par son ses AG polygamie par ces ce non
respectes des Val de la République se
trouve finalement dépourvu de de cette
prérogative vous dire aussi que il y
avait des éléments dans le dans le texte
du Gouvernement initial que je souhaite
voir Modifier c'est l'objet de
l'amendement que je vous présente
c'està-dire que les périodes qui sont
travaillés par l'étranger quelle que
soit sa nature dire qu'elle soit
saisonnier qu'il soit étudiant qu'il
soit demandeur d'asile si ces Peres sont
travaillés alors ell doit pouvoir entrer
dans le décompte justificatif de cet
étranger cette période de 8 mois de
travail 12 mois moi je je préfère 8 mois
mais c'est d'ailleurs l'amendement du
rapporteur mais en tout cas que on
puisse unifier ce régime de ce point de
vue-là c'est l'objet de mon premier
amendement et mon deuxème amendement
monsieur le sousamendement monsieur le
rapporteur général en a déjà parlé il
s'agit puisque l'examen du texte a été
main de fois décalé en attendant son
application directe pour les demandeurs
que on on reporte la date d'application
non plus au 31 décembre 2026 mais au 31
décembre 2028 j'ajoute sur cet aspect
que tous ceux qui seraient inquiet ça a
été dit par le rapporteur tous ceux qui
seraient inquiet d'un app d' on compte
on compte bien les étrangers qui sont
présents sur le territoire à cette date
qui à la date à laquelle nous votons le
texte justifie de 3 ans de présence
qu'il peuvent prouver ce qui est déjà un
élément important et qui justifie aussi
des 8 mois de travail et donc le fait
que nous allions régulariser des gens
qui viennent à partir d'aujourd'hui il
est parfaitement illusoire sur ce
sujet l'amendement de Monsieur saintuil
je crois qu'il n'est pas défendu
monsieur de la porte vous avez un
identique au ah pardon j'ai pas vu
monsieur cast monsieur Castellani
allez-y oui effectivement c'est un
amendement de notre collègue saintthuile
euh qu'il qui vise à permettre d'inclure
pour le décompte de périodes d'activité
professionnelle dans les métiers en
tension ouvrant droit à un titre de
séjour donc les périodes de travail
exercé sous le statut de demandeur
d'asile de saisonniers et et d'étudiants
merci Monsieur de la porte
oui merci monsieur le Président vous
avez vous-même défendu cette cette
amendement il s'agit ici je le rappelle
de pouvoir comptabiliser finalement
l'ensemble des périodes d'activité y
compris donc celle sous statut demandeur
d'asile saisonnier ou d'étudiants euh et
c'est un
minimum merci alors cette cet cet
amendement proposé par le rapporteur et
et présenté tout à l'heure est
essentielle et une avancée certaine en
terme de régularisation des travailleurs
sans papierers dans notre pays pour les
métiers en tension euh donc on ne
revient pas au texte initial on est sur
un compromis je l'entends bien il me
semble qu'on doit aussi se projeter
au-delà de la première année de ce titre
salarié ou ou temporaire puisque dans le
texte initial était explicitement
mentionné la possibilité de délivrance
d'une carte de séjour pluriannuel à
l'expiration de la carte de séjour
temporaire mention travailleur
temporaire ou salarié d'un an dans le
cas où la personne est titulaire d'un
contrat à durée indéterminée d'un CDI je
ne vois pas cette mention dans la
proposition de monsieur le rapporteur il
me semble utile de l'ajouter de la
formaliser explicitement parce que c'est
un point de vigilance évidence il faut
pas se se contenter d'un an et ensuite
au revoir sans suite quand il y a un CDI
à la clé en
particulier monsieur Nagel
1762 alors c'est un sous-amendement qui
a été fait on parle beaucoup de
potentiel appel d'air le but de cet
amendement est dire ben ça ne concerne
clairement que ceux qui sont sur notre
territoire à la date de promulgation de
de la loi et que on s'engage aussi à ce
que des possibles personnes qui
viendraient juste après la promulgation
de la loi et qui ferait cette demande
d'ici 24 mois ne pourrait clairement pas
demander à à avoir ce titre ce titre
métier entention je pense que c'est
important de le le préciser parce que on
on entend énormément de choses je pense
qu'il faut être clair et c'est c'est ce
qu'essaie de de faire notre groupe en
disant on n'occulte pas cette parti
économique mais par contre il faut pas
que ça envoie un appel à potentiellement
faire venir des personnes grâce à de
manière illégale grâce à ce titre le
1739 n'est pas défendu le 1741 c'est moi
qui l'ai défendu tout à l'heure et
Monsieur de la porte vous en avez un
identique
monsieur non non le 1739 il est que que
signé par Monsieur saintuil je suis
désolé je vous assure que moi j'avais
que la signature de
Monsieur alors Monsieur monsieur
Castellani
défendez-le mettez le micro par contre
s'il vous plaît c'est un amendement
merci c'est un amendement de notre
collègue saint effectivement qui dit que
le rétablissement de la carte de séjour
temporaire est une mesure importante
pour l'économie mais que limite
d'application au 31 12 26 c'est trop
restrictive pour rendre pleinement
effectif le le dispositif et donc il
considère que c'est plus cohérent de
fixer la date à compter de la
promulgation de la de la présente loi
merci donc le mien défendu monsieur de
la porte de votre oui merci monsieur le
Président il s'agit ici comme vous
l'avez évoqué d'étendre la durée de
l'expérimentation de 3 à 5 ans 2026
c'est demain 2028 c'est un minimum et on
peut toujours dire que
le regret c'est que ça soit une
expérimentation mais voilà mieux vaut
une expérimentation que rien du tout et
Monsieur Castell je sais pas si vous
êtes signataire du
1737 oui oui absolument oui on reprend
le même problématique que précédemment
simplement en disant qu'il est cohérent
de fixer la date au 31 décembre 2027
merci le 1645 monsieur nagelen 645 pard
monsieur
alors ça c'est un un amendement qui en
fait
réécrit quasiment complètement cet
article en en avec les les différents
arguments que j'ai l'occasion de de
donner précédemment la liste des métiers
en tenstion au niveau départemental les
12 mois sur les sur les deux dernières
années donc ça c'est un résumé des des
trois précédents
amendements et le 740 je ne vois
personne pour le défendre monsieur alors
madame la rapporteur vos avis sur tous
les amendements oui merci monsieur le
Président alors sur le je vais essayer
de parce que j'avais pas une lias dans
l'ordre j'essayé de bien les faire dans
dans l'ordre le premier le
1744 euh c'est un un avis favorable pour
l'extension du dispositif au contrat
d'apprentissage le
1743 ça a été évoqué à plusieurs
reprises hein sur le fait que la liste
elle puisse être établie à un échelon
départemental c'est un avis favorable
également sur le 1742 qui étend de 8 à
12 mois c'est un avis défavorable on
souhaite rester sur le 8 mois à ce stade
le
1760 euh c'est un avis aussi
défavorable le
1757 ça reprend le contrat
d'apprentissage donc c'est un avis comme
pour Madame Abadie
favorable sur le
1740 du Président c'est un avis
favorable aussi pour comptabiliser les
périodes donc pour les saisonniers les
étudiants et les demandeurs d'asile le
1756 de Madame Dupont à mon sens il est
satisfait puisqueensuite les demandeurs
d'asile rentrent dans le droit commun
donc pour moi ce serait un retrait ou
défavorable celui de Monsieur neigelen
alors je je malgré votre présentation
chers collègues je suis désolé je le
vois pas il je sais pas s'il est encore
là ou pas oui il est là pardon c'est
tout au bout chers collègue en fait je
vois je vois pas exactement de façon
concrète à à quoi ça renvoie mais je je
vois bien le le sujet effectivement que
la personne soit bien sur le territoire
quand elle puisse être fait la demande
quand elle voilà je plus parler français
quand elle fait la demande mais en tout
cas il s'agit vraiment
effectivement que ce soit les personnes
qui soient sur le territoire français
donc à mon sens à ce stade c'est couvert
mais on peut peut-être en rediscuter
puisque voilà vu le délai tardif des des
de dépôt des sous-amendements peut-être
ça nécessite de les expertiser un peu
plus le
1739 qui a été présenté par Monsieur
Castellani en fait tous les les
amendements qui sont relatifs à la
durée voilà je pense que on peut
effectivement essayer de trouver un un
atterrissage en commun pour que on soit
d'accord que l'expérimentation soit
suffisamment longue pour être explicite
je vous remercie alors monsieur le
rapporteur général vous vouliez parler
oui quelques quelques éléments peut-être
d'éclairage supplémentair essayer de de
répondre à quelques-unes des
interrogations qui qui ont été portées à
l'instant sur la durée 8 mois 12 mois
bon nous sommes
aujourd'hui sur le dispositif initial je
je n'oublie pas qu'il y a une seconde
chambre ou une première puisque c'est la
chambre haute donc nous aurons
probablement l'occasion d'en rediscuter
avec avec le le Sénat de même sans doute
que sur la la durée à 2 ans mais ça
existe madame Ménard la commission mixte
paritaire c'est c'est comme ça ce sont
nos institution de la même façon sur sur
le N + 2 sur le N + 2 moi je pense qu'en
tout cas il faut tenir compte du délai
qui s'est écoulé depuis la présentation
du texte en conseil des ministres il
s'est écoulé cela ne m'a pas échappé
plutôt 11 mois 10 à 11 mois que 24 mois
donc mais pour l'instant je crois que
c'est important de en tout cas de se
donner cette souplesse contenu des
délais y compris de promulgation
d'application de la loi que nous ne
connaissons pas à ce stade mais là aussi
il y aura une discussion j'imagine en
tout cas en commission mixte paritaire
pour répondre à C Dupon sur la
possibilité et les passerelles vers les
cartes de séjour pliréannuel il était
indispensable de
le formaliser lorsque l'article 3
prévoyait la création d'un titre
spécifique là nous renvoyons à des
catégories de tiêtre existantes salarié
et travail temporaire nous rentrons donc
dans le droit commun de titres déjà
existants parmi la longue liste des
titres qui les 187 titres applicables et
par conséquent bien sûr que et c'est
parfois une divergence avec certains
d'entre vous bien sûr que ce que nous
souhaitons c'est tirer d'une certaine
façon de l'illégalité un certain nombre
de ressentissant qui remplissent les
conditions que nous avons déjà explicité
à plusieurs reprises pour que il puisse
assumer un parcours d'intégration et
donc à terme bien sûr que la logique et
que cette personne si elle respecte les
conditions de droit commun puisse
bénéficier à cette condition tiens le
redire d'une carte de séjour plannuelle
et donc une personne régularisée sur
cette base dans les limites que nous
connaissons pourra demander la carte de
séjour plurannuel et elle se leverra le
cas échéant attribué si elle en remplit
bien sûr les conditions je je voudrais
répondre à notre collègue Christophe
nagelen en effectivement de de de mieux
cerner peut-être l'amendement qui était
le sien je vois une cont deux
contradictions si vous le permettez
d'abord contradiction entre l'amendement
qui consiste à indiquer que la personne
est présente sur le territoire national
au moment de la promulgation du texte et
l'amendement de Monsieur Castellani qui
suit qui lui exige une présence de 3 ans
à partir de la promulgation donc je
d'expérimentation je sincèrement il y a
il y a là une percussion qui ne
correspond pas de la de façon générale
la condition de résidence à 3 ans elle
est antinomique avec votre propre
proposition mais pourquoi pas y
retravailler bien sûr pour la séance
publique et puis enfin je voudrais
apporter un éclairage peut-être sur
l'amendement de de notre président de de
commission des lois moi j'avoue sur ce
sujet que il me semble qu'il faut que
nous réfléchissions peut-être plus
longuement d'ici la séance publique en
tout cas c'est une proposition que je
fais monsieur le Président pour pour
plusieurs raisons euh le titre des
séjours saisonnier
qui pourrait donc bénéficier au terme de
ce sous-amendement du titre de séjour de
régularisation les saisonniers par
définition c'est un titre qui est limité
à un objectif très précis et je suis
issu d'un territoire viticole où ce
titre de séjour est extrêmement occupé
et donc au bout de deux de trois titres
de séjour saisonniers euh le risque est
que on soit dans une logique de
régularisation qui ne correspond pas au
motif initial motif saisonnier c'est pas
le motif travail et travail temporaire
ce n'est pas tout à fait même pas du
tout la même chose je je je souhaiterais
qu'on puisse réfléchir sur ce sujet si
vous l'acceptez bien sûr de la même
façon que les visas étudiants moi ce qui
me vient à l'esprit c'est que nos
étudiants étrangers peuvent travailler
dans la limite de 60 % de la durée
légale de travail et donc le motif de
venu sur le territoire national c'est le
motif d'étude ça n'est pas le motif de
travail or là vous proposez de
régulariser au titre du travail là aussi
je je pense qu'il faut que nous
puissions réfléchir de façon plus
précise peut-être et je dirais au fond
la même chose sur la demande d'asile une
personne qui est déboutté du droit
d'asile et qui aurait le cas échéant non
respectecter les décisions d'éloignement
tel que le ministre de l'Intérieur a pu
le signaler à plusieurs reprises ce
matin notamment je je vois mal comment
nous pourrions créer une forme
d'automaticité de demande en tout cas en
terme de de régularisation donc si vous
n'y avez pas d'inconvénient je je
préférerais un retrait monsieur le
Président sur cette amend en revanche
ouvrir au contrat d'apprentissage comme
vous le proposez d'ailleurs monsieur le
Président me semble parfaitement
justifié parce que nous savons tous
qu'il y a des ruptures de régularité ou
de séjour de régulier entre la sortie
entre le passage de la minorité à la
majorité et il y a là parfois des angles
morts qui créent des situations
d'insécurité et tenir compte de la durée
de contrat d'apprentissage dans la
régularité possible du séjour jour à la
main du préfet avec les trois catégories
de refus qui sont aujourd'hui possibles
au terme de l'amendement que je vous
propose me semble là en revanche tout à
fait justifié voilà les quelques
éléments que je souhaitais apporter à
notre discussion bon alors moi je je
monsieur je vous donne la parole tout de
suite mais je comprends je comprends
votre idée j'accepte de regarder pour la
séance les différents publics qui sont
qui sont concernés et que vous avez
énuméré pour les la prise en compte des
priodes de travail notamment au titre du
fait que ces priodes de travail font
l'objet de délivrance de de période
spécifique vous avez dit saisonniers
vous avez parléétudiants et on vient
d'autoriser le travail des demandeurs
d'asile donc pour ce qui concerne mon
amendement 1740 je le reti monsieur le
ministre merci Monsieur le le président
peut-être très rapidement parce que le
Rapporteur général a a tout dit et je me
suis moi-même exprimé me semble-t-il sur
le non rétablissement de l'article 3
dire que je je je souhaite également un
avis favorable sur les 1744 de Madame
Abad et de Monsieur hou sur les contrats
d'apprentissage en revanche sur les
indépendants le 1757 je peux comprendre
la la question posée par les
représentants du groupe modem mais euh
il faut qu'il faut voir le texte dans sa
globalité la création finalement euh
d'un statut de salariés ou
d'auto-entrepreneur qui fait naître un
travail légal même si les personnes sont
dans irrégularité de séjour ne respond
ne répondent pas à mon avis au au même
ressort dans un premier cas le salarié
je mets des guillemets est exploité par
un patron voyou qui utilise le sanspier
pour des conditions de travail
déplorables une pression sur le droit
syndical pression sur sur le Baras on
peut on peut considérer que le salarié
subit en premier lieu plutôt
queonorganise le le
trafic de quelqu'un qui a le pouvoir
capitalistique et donc c'est normal
qu'on protège ce statut de salarié si
j'ose dire en libérant la tutelle de
l'employeur sur l'employé c'est le age
moderne que nous essayons de combattre
dans cet article 3 puis 4 bis qui est
essentiel et en le dénonçant non
seulement on répond à une question
d'humanité de travail mais par ailleurs
on a l'information de qui l'exploite et
ça va de Perre avec l'article 8 qui
prévoit des sanctions extrêmement fortes
administratives contre l'employeur qui
embauche des personnes irrégulières donc
si je dire comme je voulais essexprer
d'exprimé dans
la l'explication liminaire lorsque vous
m'avez auditionné ce texte
à sincériser les choses à lutter contre
l'hypocrisie à mettre fin à des flux et
à dire regardons le stock et notamment
essayons de savoir qui exploite qui et
comment on peut combattre cela c'est la
fin de l'écosystème en tout cas le
maximum de fin d'écosystème irrégulier
donc je pense que ça correspond ce que
vous essayez de fa sur rapporteur
général dans les conditions d'équilibre
et comme l'a dit président des
commission des lois que je remercie de
de son pas en avant vers le texte qui
peut satisfaire un maximum de de
personnes qui qui réfléchissent à ce
sujet sur l'auto-entrepreneur ça me
paraît un peu différent puisque
l'auto-entrepreneur c'est quelqu'un qui
utilise le faille de l'administration
française qui peut créer son
auto-entreprise par complicité
administrative on va dire ça comme ça
d'une administration qui ne vérifie pas
la régularité du séjour et qui ensuite
est son propre patron alors c'est vrai
c'est pas vrai parce qu'on c'est toutous
ce que l' entrepreneur c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui est parfois utilisé par un
statut pour être exploité vous avez eu
cette discussion avec le min du travail
les directive européenne donc quand je
vous je vous le dis je sais moi-même que
ce raisonnement s limite et là aussi
l'idée c'est donc de mettre fin au flux
puisque vous avez un article 5
extrêmement fort qui met fin à la
possibilité de créer une auto-entreprise
quand on est irrégulier sur territoire
national je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'important et je comprends la
question finalement du du stock je ne
suis pas favorable personnellement à ce
que l'article 4 bis correspond à autre
chose qu'un statut de salarié parce que
je pense que ce serait à mon avis
légaliser une partie d'une activité qui
a quand même été imaginée par ceux qui
l'ont fait comme étant un détournement
classique de notre droit en rev je veux
bien comprendre qu'il y a des gens qui
effectivement ont été exploités en
disant bah je vais pas te prendre comme
salarié mais tu vas créer ton statut
d'entrepreneur et du coup ils en
reviennent à une assimination de
salariés donc ce que je propose avec un
engagement de de ma part qu'on le fasse
sous 3 mois avant l'application des
textes qui en sortirai c'est qu'on
construise vite sous la forme d'ailleurs
qui peut prendre un engagement plus
formel dans l'hémicycle y compris de ma
part un groupe de travail avec le
ministère d'économie et des Finances
parce que je pense que c'est un point
très important et ministère du Travail
pour qu'on regarde ce qui relève des
personnes qui ont détourné le droit des
étrangers pour pouvoir être régularisé
je pense que ça il faut que nous le
combattions mais pour ceux qui
correspondent à la philosophie de
l'article 4 bis désormais qui ont été
exploités que nous puissions être
attentifs à leur à leur sujet donc je
propose que on puisse retirer cet
amendement ou en tout cas voter contre
mais m'engager très fortement sur la
question des indépendants et un avis
défavorable pour le reste même si
monsieur nagen a compris que dans
l'émicycle on retravaillera avec le
ministre du Travail la
territorialisation départementale madame
brocard vous vouliez retirer un
amendement au profit d'un autre oui tout
à fait merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre pour toutes vos précisions et
et votre engagement donc effectivement
on va retirer le
1757 pour favoriser celui de Madame
abadier le 1744 qui se limite à
l'apprentissage madame Diaz
ou merci monsieur le Président c'est
affligeant que vous ignoriez tous les 65
% de Français qui considèrent que notre
pays compte déjà beaucoup d'étranger et
qu'accueillir des immigrés
supplémentaires n'est pas
souhaitable par cet article et par ces
amendements vous créez incontestablement
un appel d'air sans précédent et
croyez-moi ce sera un appel d'air qui
sera entendu par les passeurs moi je je
vous indiquais mes craintes il y a
quelques instants sur le risque de
pérénisation de ce dispositif présenté
comme expérimental bah déjà on on passe
un premier palier puisqu'on nous dit bah
tiens ça va pas être jusqu'à 2026 mais
ça va être jusqu'à 2028 je vous alertais
sur le risque d'élargissement des
catégories éligibles à la carte de
séjour de travailleurs et ben oui là on
voit dans ces amendements que finalement
on va l'élargir puis au aux saisonniers
puis aux étudiants puis aux apprentis
puis à ceux qui sont en formation puis
en autpreneur et cetera donc en fait là
vous ouvrez la voie à la régularisation
des entre 600000 et 900000 clandestins
qui sont dans notre pays et vraiment il
faut que les Français sachent que votre
texte a vraiment vocation à créer une
filière d'immigration supplémentaire
particulièrement dangereuse madame di
vous avez pas écouté que j'ai retiré mon
amendement 1740 voilà madame
Rousseau excusez-moi
merci c'est à moi c'est pas
moi merci monsieur le Président c'est en
fait l'amendement vise à à ce que les
personnes qui travaillent durant 12 mois
consécutifs ou non au cours des 24
derniers mois et qui justifient d'une
période de
résidence en réaction à la discussion
générale bon c'est pas grave vous aurez
une autre chance madame fussillon
et ah je pensais alors pardon madame
ftillon oui d'abord je vous fais part
quand même de de mon goût
particulièrement amère de ne pas avoir
pu défendre notre amendement de de
suppression de l'article 4 bis et les
conditions entre la niche fi et la
commission rendent tout ça difficile
mais vous ne m'empêcherez pas de penser
que quand même ça vous arrange un petit
peu monsieur le Président que nous
n'ayons pas pu défendre ces amendements
de suppression nous avons des nous
souhaitions supprimer cet article 4 bis
parce que pour nous il est évidemment à
la fois une régression par rapport au
texte initial déjà peu ambitieux de ce
point de vue-là mais aussi une
régression par rapport à l'existant donc
pour nous il est impossible de valider
ça ensuite sur les amendements qui sont
proposer pour tenter de proposer ce que
vous appelez un compromis en réalité ils
visent tous à répondre à une seule idée
défendue par la droite et l'extrême
droite c'est la thèse selon laquelle il
y aurait un appel d'air et vous répondit
en permanence à cette idée-là comme si
les vagues de régularisation qui avaient
existé dans notre pays même quand elles
ont été massives avait créé un
quelconque appel d'air je voudrais qu'on
arrête de tenter de répondre un temps
soit peu à cette idée l'appel d'air
n'existe pas il est un mythe complet et
ça suffit que vous vous saisissiez et
vous glissiez vers cette idée en y
répondant de manière rationnelle c'est
un mythe total et il n'y a pas de
rationalité à cette idé-là donc stop et
vos amendements en permanence quand vous
les défendez aujourd'hui et bien vous
avez l'impression que en accordant à
1000 travailleurs de plus dans l'année
parce qu'en réalité au fur et à mesure
on est sur quelques petits milliers et
bien vous créez une bombe politique ça
suffit il faut ramener de la rationalité
la rationalité c'est qu'il y a des
milliers et des milliers de travailleurs
aujourd'hui qui sont exploités et il
faut mettre fin à ça merci bon je vous
ai laissé 2 minutes contrairement à vos
collègues par rapport à la demande de
suppression j'ai pris j'ai pris quand
même à témoin la Commission à 11h57 en
demandant si je commençais en disant que
je vous n'étiez pas présente et les
collègues tous témoins ont demandé à ce
que vous commenciez donc je suis je suis
désolé c'est ça n'est pas malise de ma
part madame fossill monsieur mar on
reprend une
minute merci monsieur le Président je je
dispose de 2 minutes moi
aussi non non allez-y monsieur
ouais c'est ça bon écoutez d'abord
autant le dire le texte issu du Sénat
tel que le dangereux extrémiste qui est
le président Marseille ça se connaît
nous convenait parfaitement il nous
convenait parfaitement
et il c'est déjà l'objet d'un compromis
je le rappelle tout de même euh moi je
salue l'effort qui a été réalisé par
monsieur le rapporteur général pour
essayer dans le texte que nous avons à à
à discuter ici à l'Assemblée puisque
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas composée
de la même manière d'essayer de de
trouver également une voix de compromis
notamment
sur
l'opposabilité du droit avec un passage
sur un véteau préfectoral en maintenant
un certain nombre d'éléments euh
faisant l'objet de l'examen du du
dossier le fait de la présentation de la
carte de séjour aussi moi je je le dis
je pense que c'est un
progrès c'est c'est une chose qui
améliore le texte en revanche je je
voterai favorablement l'amendement de
notre collègue nelen sur les
délais puisque je je pense que 1 an vaut
mieux que 8
mois je je pense que l'amendement tel
que proposé par Monsieur rapporteur
général va alement dans le bon sens et
et nous le voterons en revanche je le
dis un certain nombre de
sous-amendements ont été proposés
d'autres ont été retirés je salue le
retrait de de celui de Monsieur le
Président pour que nous puissions en
discuter éventuellement en séance dans
quelques jours mais les sousamendements
qui ont été présentés nous ne les
voterons pas mis à part celui sur la
départementalisation souhaité par le
député
neigelen alors Monsieur monsieur
Dumont non c'est Madame pardon oui merci
monsieur le Président un petit bilan
d'étapes à ce stade de l'examen de notre
texte vous avez supprimé les quotas vous
avez rétabli
l'ame vous avez supprimé le délit de
séjours irrégulier et avec cet article 4
bis vous consacrez un droit à
régularisation pour les personnes en
situations irrégulières dans les métiers
en tension elle devient de droit vous
créez donc qu' un droit opposable et des
sources de contentieux probablement
infinies alors nous nous sommes c'est
une 4ème ligne rouge nous sommes
frontalement opposés à cette
disposition le pouvoir du de vetau du
préfet va être très difficile à
exercer moi je crois que il y a là
l'expression d'une méfiance à l'égard
des préfets qui avaient un pouvoir
discrétionnaire la
le droit de veto sera très encadré très
difficile et pour finir je reprendrai le
propos de Bernard brochan
ex directeur général de la DGSE qui sait
de quoi il parle et qui dit régulariser
les métiers en tension c'est amorcer une
pompe inépuisable nous le pensons
également c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous sommes résolument opposés aux
dispositions de l'article 4 bis
madame
gevnou oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président ni amorce d'une pompe
inépuisable ni à d' l'article 4 bis et
comme l'avait rapporté tout à l'heure
Florent bouer un article extrêmement
ciblé puisqu'il concerne des étrangers
qui sont déjà qui séjournent sur le
territoire depuis 3 ans et qui exerce
une activité salariée dans les métiers
ou des zones en
tout au plus 7000 personnes c'est ce qui
a été dit par le ministre tout à l'heure
alors nous nous apportons notre soutien
à l'amendement du rapporteur général qui
permet à la fois de mettre un terme à
une procédure qui serait uniquement
discrétionnaire pour venir la préciser
pour pouvoir faire en sorte que le
préfet puisse s'y opposer en cas de
menace à l'ordre public en cas de non
respect des principes de la République
et qui n'est pour autant pas un droit
automatique à la régularisation où
l'étranger serait dans les m unique de
son employeur nous serons également
sensibles à groupe conaissance au
sous-amendement déposés par nos
collègues Abadi et Houlier qui ont reçu
un un avis favorable des rapporteurs et
du gouvernement sur la sur
l'apprentissage et apportons également
un soutien alors est-ce que c'est
maintenant ou est-ce que c'est pour la
séance en tout cas sur la thématique de
la territorialisation des données qui
est présenté par monsieur nigelen qui
est un sujet porté également par
beaucoup de collègues de notre groupe
alors je donne la parole à Madame
torignia ensuite madame Dupon pour un
retrait d'amendement et comme le RN n'
eu qu'une minute c'est seul groupe qui
une minute on vous redonne une
minute monsieur Val je vous avez pas vu
vous n'aviez pas levé la main vous aurez
la parole ensuite monsieur nagelen aussi
vous préoccupez pas tout va bien se
passer pour reprendre une expression
consacréeor donc Madame t merci monsieur
le Président
donc je veux je veux ici dire
qu'effectivement vous avez eu des
méthodes un peu particulières puisque
vous suspendez la séance quand ça vous
arrange et vous la reprenez quand ça
vous arrange aussi donc nous n'avons pas
pu défendre nos amendements de
suppression mais nous avons gagné en
hémicycle un texte un le rétablissement
d'un article majeur qui va permettre de
voir le pouvoir d'achat des des
Françaises et des Français confortter
nous nous sommes nous étions donc pour
la suppression de cet article 4 bis
comme je l'avais expliqué déjà
précédemment parce que c'est une vision
utilitariste de de l'Immigration et de
cela nous n'en voulons pas ce n'est pas
un article de
compromis il y a donc 8 mois d'exercice
de l'activité durant les 24 derniers
mois il y a cette histoire de métier en
tension comme je l'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure qui fait que bah on a besoin des
étrangers on les garde on en a pas
besoin on les renvoie chez eux il y a
aussi le problème de la résidence
ininterrompue de 3 ans hein qui reprend
donc la formulation la plus stricte du
du Sénat donc ça n'est pas un amendement
de compromis euh et puis il y a aussi
donc l'opposition du du préfet qui reste
possible pour toutes ces raisons nous
voulions donc supprimer cet article 4 B
la la bataille est pas finie hein parce
que ça se jouera en séance et j'espère
qu'en séance nous pourrons y arver donc
c'est à cause de moi que vous avez pas
pu défendre l'amendement et grâce à vous
que l'amendement en séance l'article en
séance est passé c'est ça exactement
bravo Madame bravo Madame Tor pour cette
vision objective de la situation
monsieur valallot
oui simplement pour vous dire que
l'amendement tel qui résulte du Sénat
fait partie pour nous de la élection des
régressions dont le Sénat s'est rendu
coupable il est au fond le refus de
regarder la réité en face de régulariser
des travailleurs qui par ailleurs payent
des impôts payent des cotisations social
mais ne peuvent pas payer leur loyer
parce qu'ils sont pas capables de
produire un titre de
séjour nous avons tout à l'heure défendu
l'article originel proposé par le
gouvernement et défendu avec vigueur par
la majorité l'article
3 vous n'avez pas vous-même soutenu le
projet initial du
gouvernement nous avons là défendu un
certain nombre
d'amendements pour essayer que en
réalité ce cette réécriture ne soit pas
simplement cosmétique mais apporte un
véritable progrès déjà l'article 3 le
ministre nous disait c'est 7000 ce sera
7000 cas par an ce qui est déjà à peu
près ce qui se fait sur la base de la
circulaire donc comment dire que ce sera
vraiment une une satisfaction de dro de
droit supplémenta ça n'est pas le cas
donc nous on voulait un titre de plein
droit nous voulions l'élargissement à un
certain nombre de de travaux
régulièrement engagés comme étudiant ou
comme ou comme saisonniers nous aurions
souhaité que les indépendants et les
travailleurs des plateformes puissent
être prises en considération ça n'est
pas le cas alors c'est mieux que ce que
fait le Sénat c'est moins pire que pire
mais enfin franchement convenez qu'on
pas et qu'il y a encore du travail en
séance pour que ce soit utile et que
nous satisfaisions aux demandes non
seulement du secteur économique mais de
française et de Français dans leur très
grande majorité Monsieur
nelen Merci monsieur le Président vous
savez si on veut pouvoir mieux gérer
notre immigration mais surtout avoir
aussi une meilleure intégration il faut
déjà régler la problématique des
personnes qui sont présentes sur place
et pour se faire il faut le faire avec
trois points précis le premier c'est
déjà euh être au plus près des réalités
du territoire on l'a fait avec notre
amendement sur euh sur le la liste des
méentention au niveau desbemental ça
continuera avec la décentralisation de
l'OFPRA de l'OFI mais on doit aussi
avoir des critères beaucoup plus stricts
sur la notion de présence dans ces
métiers en ttention et c'est pour ça
qu'on avait déposé cet amendement euh
pour les 12 mois sur les 2 derniers mois
mais il faut aussi que ça n'appelle pas
à créer un billet un billet qui pourrait
tendre demain à apper une une
immigration que l'on ne saurait pas
contrôler ni accueillir c'est pour cela
que il est important le ministre le
rapporteur général nous a dit qu'on
allait en discuter en séance moi je
tiens vraiment sur ces deux points les
12 mois sur les 24 derniers mois et le
point précis d'à partir quel moment un
étranger en situation régulière ne
pourrait bénéficier de ce titre metier
enention qu'on en rediscute pour pouvoir
en séance déposer un amendement qui
cadre beaucoup plus ce qui est présenté
aujourd'hui Madame Dupont pour retrait
ça merci monsieur le Président
effectivement c'est un un point
d'importance je remercie les rapporteurs
sur leur réponse
concernant la précarité donc des
travailleurs sans papiers qu'on améliore
par votre
amendement mais il faut pas oublier
qu'au cœur de notre sujet on a les
difficultés et l'embolisation des
services des préfectures et que
réintroduire l'annualité permanente de
ces titres métiers enention poserait
difficultés aux préfectures elle-même et
bien sûr aux étrangers concernés donc je
pense que le caractère pluriannuel doit
être porté et être faire l'objet d'une
incitation forte de monsieur le ministre
auprès de l'ensemble de ses services
est-ce que vous vous maintenz votre
amendement alors le et je j'ai entendu
les arguments donc je le retire mais
j'en reparlerai en séance est retiré et
donc qui avait une minute pour le
rassemblement national aussi en plus oui
monsieur le Président chers collègues il
faut rappeler ce qu'est l'article 4 je
pense que c'est important on va placer
les choses à leur contexte on avait
l'article 4 bis pardon on avait
initialement l'article 3 que les
sénateurs y compris les sénateur LR
rappelons-le ont voté en commission des
Lois du Sénat ça je tiens à le souligner
et puis quand ils se sont rendus compte
que finalement ça commencé à savoir et
que l'opinion publique était défavorable
hop un petit compromis avec la majorité
avec la gauche avec tout le monde et on
pont l'article 4 bis en espérant que ça
passe inaperçu aux yeux du grand public
mais que dit cet article 4 bis comme que
disait l'article 3 bah c'est oui c'est
un appel d'air un appel d'air et nous le
maintenons parce Queen plus là où c'est
grave là où c'est grave c'est que vous
êtes en train de prévoir la
régularisation de gens qui n'ont pas
respecté les lois de la République vous
êtes en train de prévoir la
régularisation et de donner une prime à
la clandestinité à des gens
merci alors monsieur le rapporteur
général et après on vote très brièvement
pour dire à Monsieur nagen que nous
allons donc émettre un avis favorable
sur la
départementalisation aujourd'hui cet
amendement ne vole pas mais je pense
même qu'il décolle pas enfin pour vous
montrer que notre volonté est très forte
d'aller vers la territorialisation avis
favorable alors on va voter on commence
par l'amendement 1744 de Madame Abad et
moi qui alors il a reç favorable de la
rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote contre
adopté le l'amendement de Monsieur
neigelen pour lequel le rapporteur
général vient d'exprimer un avis
favorable 1743 qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est adopté
l'amendement de Monsieur valallot le
1759 c'est un avis défavorable madame la
rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté l'amendement 1742 de Monsieur
nagelen avec avis défavorable de Madame
la rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote
contre
rejeté le 1760 de Monsieur vot
défavorable qui vote pour contre rejeté
le 1757 a été retiré le mien je l'ai
retiré mais par contre on a de amend
identiques le 1755 et le
19761 avis déforable qui pour favorable
pour qui
contre vous avez changé vous avez changé
votre avis oui mais de touteçon moi j'ai
retirer le mien pour retravailler en
séance donc l'avis était favorable mais
il a été retiré pouravailler en séance
les autres ont été maintenus qui vote
pour qui vote contre ils sont rejetés
c'est bien ça 1756 retiré le
1762 c'est un avis défavorable aussi de
Madame la rapporteur qui vote pour
contre rejeté le
1739 avis défavorable qui vote pour
contre rejeté et le 17 141 avis
favorable madame le rapporteur monsieur
rapporteur oui qui vote pour qui vote
contre adopté il fait tomber le 1737 et
donc c'est l'article l'amendement à
l'article 4 bis ainsi amendé que je
souet à voix qui vote
pour qui vote
contre il est adopté réle 4
b monsieur le ministre ou monsieur
président j'avais demandé
la
pardon monsieur président mais j'avais
demandé la la parole avant que vous
puissiez passer au vote et vous m'avez
pas vu je je pense juste peut-être
répondre à à quelques quelques
interventions et notamment à
l'intervention de Madame jeunevard euh
madame jeunevard je je vais sur le cas
précis d' l'article 4 bis vous donner
deux cas euh qui
ont été amenés à à demander le la
régularisation au ministre de
l'intérieur par par des élusour et de de
cas très précises j'ai anonymisé
évidemment le le cas des des deux dames
parce que c'est deux
dames une dame est arrivée en France en
2011 elle est veuve elle assume seule la
charge de ces deux enfants scolarisés
elle est agente de propreté depuis 2019
avec des hires de travail qui lui font
quitter son domicile à 5h du matin pour
un retour à 22h elle est rémunérée entre
600 et 1100 € par mois ça
dépend de de ses salaires chaque mois
elle a une une feuille de salaire et un
travail effectif de supérieur à 40 he
par semaine sur quatre chantiers à Vitri
à livr Gargan à blanc et dans le Paris
16e l'employeur n'a jamais voulu signer
le CFA de régularisation cette dame elle
est toujours irrégulière sur le
territoire national ça fait donc plus de
13 ans qu'elle est sur le territoire
national elle est rentrée en 2011 donc
je vous fais pas de dessin et par
ailleurs ça fait depuis 2019 ça faut
dire que ça fait depuis plus de 4 ans
qu'elle travaille plus de 40 heur par
semaine et qu'on ne peut pas la
régulariser parce que je n'ai pas la
disposition de
régularisation non et ben non madame
parce que l'employeur ne veut pas la
signer non je je peux vous dire que non
puisque l'employur je peux vous dire que
non puisque je suis toujours en train
d'essayer de régiser cette personne don
le cas à mon avis ici démontre qu'on a
un certain nombre de sujets aujourd'hui
pour appliquer cette loi et c'est dans
une préfecture c'est dans une préfecture
qui n'est pas c'est dans une préfecture
monsieur Vall c'est une préfecture qui
n'est pas réputé pour
être trop interprétative deè cas une
dame est arrivée en France en 2010 et
elle cumule 56 bulletins de salaire dans
la branche du nettoyage là aussi on a
beaucoup de choses comme cela pour des
femmes dans dans le nettoyage la
préfecture a été informée des conditions
dramatiques et de grandeséalités qui
sont les siennes elle n'a pas d'enfant
car depuis les deux dernières années
elle dort dans une cage d'escalier à
plusieurs reprises on lui a proposé des
logements d'urgence et à ce jour elle
arrive à vivre dans un logement
insalubre et dont elle a une procédure
d'ailleurs qu'on aide auprès de son
marchand de sommeil pas régularisable
non plus parce qu'une très grande
entreprise française refuse de lu signer
son SFA et reconnaître qu'elle embché de
M irrégulière alors après madame
Genevard il y a deux autres arguments
peut-être et après je répondra à Madame
Diaz qui qui me paraît important de dire
vous citez monsieur brochant qui un
homme respectable personne n'en dis
convient mais mais quel rapport entre
l'ancien patron de la DGSE qui est
ambassadeur et le les métiers en tention
non mais non mais c'est pas question
deidame il n'a jamais monsieur brochant
eu à gérer une préfecture une
sous-préfecture des métiers en tention
la DGSE ce sont des gens très très bien
et formidable les diplomates également
mais mais quel rapport avec les métiers
en attention il s'occupe de la la menace
sur notre territoire en quoi ces dames
sont sont une menace sur notre
territoire madame jeunevard je pense que
on peut très bien avoir des des
arguments sans sans sans évoquer la DGSE
ça me paraît pas forcément nécessaire
surtout que vous verrez qu'il y a plein
de dispositions article 9 10 et 13 qui
vont répondre à votre demande et puis
enfin vous avez fait la liste madame
jeunevar je comprends bien pourquoi vous
l'avez fait mais moi je vais vous faire
la liste de tout ce qui a été retenu
depuis le début de ce texte le débat
annuel au Parlement plri-annuel avec des
objectifs chiffrés a été retenu le
regroupement familial avec le maintien
de d'e assurance maladie pour demander
regoupement familial et les obligations
de déposer des ressources régulières de
plus en plus de stable et suffisantes a
été retenu le regroupement familial avec
le maintien de l'exigence
d'apprentissage et le retour de la loi
de Nicolas Sarkozi sur le linguistique
avant d'effectuer le regroupement
familial a été retenu le regoupement
familial qui permet au maire aujourd'hui
de pouvoir s'appuyer sur une convention
avec le fille et de pouvoir devoir
pardon mettre en place leur pouvoir
plutôt qu'aujourd'hui se taire pour
permettre le groupement familial 100ans
K puisse faire son travail a été retenu
la reprise du retrait du titre de séjour
pour toute personne menaçant ou portant
atteinte à des élus a été retenu le
titre étranger malade qui a été instauré
par le Sénat avec la condition plus
stricte existé avant 2016 pour absence
de soins a été retenue la validation
pour les étudiants d'un contrôle du
caractèle réel et sérieux des études
pour disposer une carte pr annuelle a
été retenue le maintien de la
suppression de la réduction tarifaire
dans les transports en commun pour les
étudiants en situation irrégulière a été
retenu le 360°r proposé par Monsieur
buffet pour simplifier les demandes et
pour pouvoir aller plus vite dans le
retour des personnes et pour dire non
plus rapidement pour les cartes de
séjour a été retenu l'adoption l'article
1er qui prévoit comme vous le savez
l'examen de langue pourtre plannuel ce
que personne n'a jamais fait pour
obtenir un titre de séjour a été retenu
pour 370000 titres par an parce que là
on parle de 7000 titres 3700 titres par
an les gens devont examen de parler
français a été retenu l'article 2 qui
prévoit que les étrangers vont devoir
avoir pendant les heures de travail euh
des cours de français ce qui les oblige
sans doute à être moins compétitif que
les Français ét retenus donc merci de
pas caricaturer les choses il est vrai
que le Sénat n'est pas l'Assemblée le
Sénat le Sénat n'est pas l'Assemblée
nationale le titre madame jeard vous
pouvez être opposé à un texte qui
prévoit qu'il faut un examen de français
pour avoir un titre annuel mais vous
aurez beaucoup de mal à expliquer que
c'est pas ce que veulent les
Français on poursuit l'le l'amendement
500 monsieur
Baayou merci monsieur le Président il
s'agit d'un amendement pour faciliter et
organiser la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier c'est pour
mettre fin je crois que le le le
ministre parlait avec justesse d'incure
je crois des préfectur qui un cuurer
administrative des préfectures qui
malheureusement sont transformé en en
machine à fabriquer les sans papiers
c'est encore le cas d'un restaurateur
que nous avons vu à Boulogne c'était
lundi un salarié qui travaille qui qui
fait son boulot qui paye des impôts qui
a des enfants scolarisés et qui du jour
au lendemain perd son droit au travail
ou en tout cas bascule dans
l'irrégularité administrative et pour
son employeur évidemment c'est un
dilemme c'est le cas de nombreux
nombreux nombreux nombreux travailleurs
dans dans ce pays et donc il s'agit de
régulariser ces travailleurs qui ne
demande qu'à qu'à s'inclure qu'à
s'intégrer dans notre
communauté et donc pour ça il faut
affranchir la délivrance de la carte de
l'aval de l'employeur et réduire le
champ discrétionnaire du préfet c'est le
sens de cet amendement merci alors le
793 madame fessillon
oui un un amendement qui vise à étendre
la proposition initiale de de l'article
3 et qui permettrait d'étendre la
régularisation aux travailleurs sans
papiers qui ne sont pas dans des métiers
en tension vous le savez aujourd'hui ils
sont très majoritairement c'est vrai
dans des métiers du bâtiment du
nettoyage du soins et du lien de la
sécurité ils ont été en première ligne
pendant la crise du covid ils effectuent
pour la plupart d'entre eux des missions
extrêmement utile à la société pourtant
ils sont invisibilisés invisibilisés par
une
clandestinité forcé et donc nous devons
les protéger de
l'exploitation qui est celle de beaucoup
beaucoup de leurs employurs je veux
simplement vous relater les les propos
de de l'un d'entre eux euh qui dit tout
le monde sait que nous n'avons pas de
papier l'agence d'intérim les chefs il
nous traite d'emblé différemment on est
insulté sous pression à croire qu'un
chef qui ne crie pas qui n'insulte pas
n'est pas un chef si on se défend on
nous répond fin de mission et il dit le
travail est obligatoire pour gagner sa
vie tout le monde le sait ici tout le
monde le fait le problème c'est pas le
travail c'est de ne plus être un esclave
voilà à quoi nous devons répondre
aujourd'hui en régularisant les
travailleurs sans papier vous pouvez
défendre le 1058 et le 1072 qui vienent
à la suite madame F aussi il sont dans
la discussion commune j'ai j'ai défendu
le 1058 et le 1172 en fait tu y es pas
Boris euh non je
pensais donc l'amendement
1172 est un amendement commun des
députés commissions des lois des groupes
écologistes socialistes insoumis et GDR
qui reprend telquelle la proposition
initiale de l'article 3 mais qui enlève
la mention métier en tension euh pour
pouvoir et bien régulariser toutes
celles et ceux aujourd'hui qui
travaillent en France qui y vivent qui
ne cherchent qu'une chose c'est pour
pouvoir être inclus dans la société
française donc c'est une mesure
particulièrement juste et qui loin de
tout ce qu'on nous raconte depuis tout à
l'heure sur les bans de l'extrême droite
serait au contraire un pouvoir de
négociation plus important pour
l'ensemble des salariés aujourd'hui la
clandestinité elle pousse elle fait en
sorte que et bien des patrons se servent
de ça comme une trappe à précarité à
pauvreté et à exploitation la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier c'est au contraire une élévation
des normes salariales pour tous les
salariés du pays madame la rapporteur
votre avis sur ces quatre amendements
oui pour les raisons que j'ai évoqué
hein précédemment ce sera un avis
défavorable alors Monsieur le Ministre
non moi j'entends l'argument de de
Monsieur Bou et de Madame fausillon
notamment sur les sur les autorisations
de de séjour et laincure administrative
que j'ai même dénoncé suite aux
amendements de de Monsieur
tacher malheureusement votre amendement
monsieur Bayou il est pas il concerne
pas que ça il concerne aussi tous les
autres travailleurs qui ser attention
vous n'avez pasliation voilà bon c'est
un choc de simplification qui va un peu
au-delà de la simplification qui va plus
un peu plus un choc politique mais on ne
peut pas partager moi je veux redire que
si je m'oppose à votre amendement je je
suis toujours pas opposé à bien
travailler sur autorisation de séjour
directement validé après le titre de
séjour et notamment sur les cartes
prannuelles puisque d'abord votre
président de commission je crois en
effet 1645 a un amendement dispensé
d'autorisation de travail les détenteur
de la carte de séjour salarié comme
Madame la rapporteur 1687 à qui jeai un
avis favorable donc ça répond à une
partie de votre demande et deuxièmement
je redis monsieur Bayou que dans les ici
que je suis prêt à retravailler sur
l'autorisation d'engagement
simplification ch simplification titre
de séjour pour tous ceux à qui le texte
actuel et la législation actuelle
autorise évidemment un titre de séjour
pas jusqu'à votre votre suet il faut
bien que nous vous laissions un peu de
travail qu vous serez en en
responsabilité politique donc avouz que
ce sera un premier pas déjà donc je
propose qu'on on adopte plus tard les
deux amendements qu'on rejette
malheureusement les les vôres en gardant
le principe que votre partie
autorisation de séjour soit soit accepté
et qu'on travail avec Monsieur et
d'autres parce que je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui peut dépasser les
l'équivage dans l'hémicycle sur
l'autorisation et le titre de
séjour madame rouso
euh merci monsieur le Président alors
nous ne nous posons pas la question
quand nous quand nos étudiants partent
dans d'autres pays pour étudier et nous
les félicitons nous ne nous posons pas
la question quand les Français vont
travailler dans d'autres pays étrangers
et quand au bout d'un moment ils
finissent par s'installer et demander la
la nationalité nous n'avons pas
l'impression d'être d'horrible
profiteurs au contraire nous avons même
l'impression de participer à au
rayonnement de la France et cetera et en
fait ça ça s'appelle notre privilège
c'estàdire que nous nous pouvons envoyer
nos enfants partout dans le monde et
nous pouvons aller travailler partout
dans le monde et nous y sommes
globalement bien accueilli en fait c'est
les amendements qui sont proposés ici
visent à sortir de la logique de métier
en ttention pour aller vers une des
droits accordés de papier aux personnes
à toutes les personnes qui travaillent
en France et en fait et bien non
seulement c'est un choc de
simplification mais en plus c'est aller
vers une égalisation des droits et de
toutes les personnes quelle que soit
leur nationalité partout dans le monde
et en fait ça nous permettrait de
regarder droit dans les yeux les
personnes qui viennent travailler en
France et de leur dire B merci en fait
de venir participer à l'économie
française merci Monsieur
Dumont merci Monsieur le le président
évidemment les républicains V contre cet
amendement qui vise à augmenter
massivement le nombre de régularisation
et de des S papiers et Monsieur Bayou a
un peu la même réflexion que vous
monsieur le rapporteur général puisque
les tous les deux vous nous dites que
vous ne voulez pas que le préfet a un
pouvoir discrétionnaire mais c'est une
folie il faut évidemment que le préfet
garde un pouvoir discrétionnaire
pourquoi de deux choses l'une parce que
soit le préfet va devoir ultraborder ses
décisions donc encombrer les
juridictions donc surtout encombrer ses
propres services qui n'auront plus les
moyens suffisants pour pouvoir donner
d'autres décision par exemple les OQTF
soit pour éviter cette situation il va
accorder de droit l'ensemble des
régularisations pour éviter d'être
soumis à un contentieux qui ne serait
pas assez bordé juridiquement manque de
moyens et donc dans les deux cas aussi
bien avec ces amendements cette série
d'amendements qu'avec l'article qui a
été adopté précédent tel que revisité
pour la régularisation des clandestins
dans les métiers enenstion on est dans
une situation où le préfet va
massivement régulariser parce qu'il
n'aura pas d'autre choix faute de moyens
ou peur de se faire cartonner par le
administrative merci merci monsieur le
Président alors avec ces amendements
vous vous travestissez la réalité et
pire vous l'instrumentalisez vous parlez
des entreprises du bâtiment mais
contactez les entreprises du bâtiment et
vous verrez ce qu'ils vont vous dire les
chefs d'entreprise ils vont vous dire
que eux ne demandent pas la
régularisation des travailleurs
clandestins c'est une proposition
absolument anachronique leur sujet à eux
en ce moment c'est la crise du logement
c'est l'inflation normative c'est
l'inflation des prix des matériaux et
c'est cette crise pour laquelle le
gouvernement a été incapable hein de les
de de de les protéger et bien c'est
cette crise qui va engendrer d'ici 2025
la perte potentielle de 100000 emplois
et vous parlez de la restauration je
vais vous donner un exemple concret moi
je suis élu en Gironde vous savez en
Gironde il y a une des des villes
touristiques comme par exemple Arcachon
et ce sont pas les gens qui ne veulent
pas aller travailler à Arcachon c'est
juste que si ils travaillent à Arcachon
ils n'ont pas les moyens de se payer un
logement et pourquoi ils n'ont pas les
moyens de se payer un logement parce que
vous avez refusé les augmentations de
salaires que Marine Le Pen avait propos
osé par exemple et vous ne solutionnez
pas la crise du logement par
l'hébergement saisonnier donc nous nous
voterons contre ces amendements qui vise
à favoriser les étrangers au détriment
des salariés français alors le la débat
sur le logement c'est avec Madame lumer
et Monsieur chines c'est la semaine
prochaine en en séance pour le coup je
mets au voix l'amendement de Monsieur
Baou le 500 qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le suivant le 793 madame
fuson qui votre pour contre rejeté le
suivant 1058 madame fossillon qui vote
pour contre rejeté et enfin le le 1172
madame fossillon qui vaêtre pour contre
rejeté nous suspendons là nos travaux
nous reprenons à
14h30 14